and now the c-span series presidential
library's history uncovered visits the
richard nixon presidential library and
explores the life and career of our 37th
president
[Music]
he said is that reading like it
getting anywhere that you can see
i don't think it is i got a barn door to
offer mine
okay
hey you're a berlick and i am why don't
you stay here
blondes they say photograph better than
brunettes
let me see that
you get these lights properly
my eyes always have they will finally
forget the past 60 that's enough
thanks
my friend ollie oh he wants to take a
lot of pictures of me
i'm afraid he'll catch me picking my
nose he wouldn't print that with you
though audi ollie
yeah now you take a long shot but that's
enough right now
i guess i can see it
oh you want a level don't you yes yes
good evening this is the 37th time i
have spoken to you from this office
where so many decisions have been made
that shape the history of our nation
anymore
that's richard nixon on august the 8th
1974
as he prepared for the live television
broadcast in which he would tell the
nation he was resigning the presidency
you'll see more of this rare video later
in our program
we'll also take you live to the newest
member
of the presidential library system
the richard nixon presidential library
and museum in yorba linda california
you'll meet its director tim naphtali
and see this unusual room
that houses life-size statues of world
leaders
most admired by president nixon
before
meeting tim naphtali
joining us as always for this series is
richard norton smith presidential
historian
george mason university scholar in
residence
how are we going to focus on richard
nixon well broadly speaking we're going
to concentrate on
in the first hour on foreign policy
particularly the openings to china
and russia and vietnam
and then in the second hour we'll
we'll look at watergate and the events
surrounding the end of the nixon
presidency and beyond uh need to say
that's not the whole story i mean one
thing that should be said up front
although we don't have
a lot of footage relating to this
there's been a lot of very interesting
revision and scholarship in recent years
from people like joan hoff and melvin
small and others who suggest that the
nixon domestic policy
record deserves much more attention than
it's gotten if you think of things like
the environmental protection agency or
the drug enforcement administration and
the philadelphia plan of affirmative
action and revenue sharing and wage and
price controls nixon was an activist
president on the domestic front which
ironically
makes him in many ways a president
without a party today because his brand
of activism and expanding government
is needless to say out of fashion with
modern conservatives
if this is the first time you've seen
any of these
series of programs on the presidential
libraries this is our seventh there are
12 presidential libraries under the
national
archives and records administration here
in washington run by alan weinstein we
ask
our
special guest every friday evening here
richard norton smith
to
steer this search for treasures
in the libraries hidden treasures things
that people haven't seen these programs
are not demet are not meant to be from
start to finish on the presidency
tonight we have some special footage
we'll show you as the program goes on
shot by bob holloman chief of staff to
president nixon
we have some secret recordings and we'll
learn more about that in a moment
and then there are some new oral history
interviews that tim naphtali has done
and we'll show you some excerpts from
all that but first let me introduce you
to the
new director of the
president nixon presidential library
museum tim naphtali who's standing among
a group of people that he can explain to
us who they are
evening tim natalia
good evening brian good evening ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the world
leaders gallery at here in yorba linda
at the richard nixon presidential
library and museum
in july of this year the national
archives and records administration
inherited a museum that had been
conceived and built by the private nixon
foundation richard nixon was alive when
this museum was was built and one of the
things he wanted was this depiction of
those leaders who quote he said had made
a difference these are leaders that he
had interacted with throughout his long
political career and they're here for
you to see their life size they look
like they're made of bronzer not quite
made of bronze but in a sense they are
representative of the kinds of human
leaders that nixon interacted with
throughout his career
or the two right in front of you there
ah well
these were perhaps if you had been
thinking about richard nixon's career in
1950 and you had wondered who were the
people he was least likely to meet it
would have been joe and lie premier of
the people's republic of china and of
course mao zedong
[Applause]
nixon is most famous for his trip to
china in february of 1972.
in the 1950s the united states
government had refused to recognize the
people's republic of china and created
in the late 40s
indeed when the united states and the
people's republic of china engaged in
negotiations regarding the future of
indochina at the geneva conference in
1954 the secretary of state of the
united states john foster dulles refused
to shake hands with joe and life well
richard nixon was vice president of that
time and perhaps it wouldn't have been
predicted that he would ultimately shake
hands with john ly but he would in 1972
in the late 1960s one could see hints
that nixon as he was thinking about
running again for the presidency was
changing his ideas about china he felt
that bringing china back into the
international commonwealth of nations
and making it a u.s partner not an ally
was key to a successful end of the
american involvement in vietnam
so in mid-1971 he shocks the nation and
the world by saying i will go to china
and then in february of 1972 he goes but
one of the wonderful parts of the story
is that he went not knowing whether this
man mao zedong would meet with him mao
was very ill by this point he had
congestive heart failure he was
bedridden
he
couldn't stand
but he wanted to meet nixon
he like nixon understood the symbolic
value of this meeting of the two titans
if you will
so he had his doctors
pump him up prepare him for this meeting
and
at the moment that nixon's air force one
landed it was still unclear to kissinger
nixon whether mao would meet nixon the
feeling was if this visit happened
without that meeting it would not be
considered a triumph but when the plane
landed mild saint sent word that he
wanted to meet nixon and within three
and a half hours of nixon's arrival in
china on the beginning of an eight day
visit he was meeting in mao zedong's
secret villa and they actually spent an
hour together
tim naphtali we want to show the
audience some
film that you've had there at the
library museum could you set it up for
us this is uh bob haldeman and his super
8 film where does it come from and why
do we see him in the film
it's an ama it's an amazing thing april
30th 1973 haldeman and ehrlichman
resign
when the fbi goes into erlickman's
office they find in one of his
compartments 204 rolls of super 8 film
now people of a certain generation will
remember super 8 film as the kind of
film you used to film your children's
birthday parties and when
when when the national archives and when
the white house started to look at these
films they noticed people's birthday
parties
four members of the white house staff
four members of the white house staff
haldeman ehrlichman
larry higby and dwight chapin
all used the super super 8 camera each
had a super 8 bellenhauer camera camera
which they used not only to film their
children's birthday parties but they
also used to film if you will a back
scenes look at the at the nixon
administration haldeman who was chief of
staff to nixon had been a an ad man in a
sense if you've watched the show mad men
you'll understand haldeman's world view
haldeman believed in the importance of
image and in pictures and he wanted to
record in for himself and also for the
government
um the nixon presidency so these uh
films were actually developed by the
navy they were not privately owned they
were from the beginning government
property they were
developed by the navy made into small
compilation reels and there are about 23
hours of these films some of which are
private we've actually returned to the
families the pictures of their birthday
parties but most of them are public and
are available for you to see at the
national archives
what we're going to show uh richard
smith is about 9 minutes and 40 seconds
of this tell us what we're going to see
yeah basically we're going to see some
of the defining moments of the nixon
presidency with some commentary from pat
buchanan who was there uh it includes
the trip to china uh as well as the
later trip to the soviet union remember
nixon was engaging in his own form of
triangulation he was bringing china in
from the outside at least in part to be
a counterweight to the soviet union and
then of course we're going to see an
administration under siege literally at
the height of the anti-war
demonstrations that all but engulfed the
white house let's watch
the footage is remarkable in many
respects
above all else it provides an insider's
view the ultimate insider's view of the
nixon presidency
taken by
the president's chief intimate
his chief of staff who among other
things found the time to pick up a movie
camera to document what he was
experiencing
h.r holderman used to say that
every president needs an sob and i'm
nixon's and bob was very good at it he
was crew cut steely blue eyes enormously
well disciplined looked like a drill
sergeant
and behaved like a drill sergeant at
times and i will say this he was a
difficult man to get on with
he was not a leader who would mean
inspire his troops he gave orders to the
troops as it were get this over here by
this time
to me anyhow i felt you know a different
relationship than i had with the
president but i will say this
the nixon first term staff
was the most honed finest political
machine
i have ever seen in this town before or
since
[Music]
haldeman more than anyone else was
responsible for catching the inner
workings of the nixon administration
to a lesser degree several other
staffers were involved as well in
filming events at the white house around
washington
and on major trips both domestically and
overseas
one of the things as you can see that
really jumps out at you in looking at
this footage is the feeling that you're
inside the bubble of the presidency
you're there on board marine one
as the president waves goodbye to
everyone assembled on the south lawn and
and then just a few minutes later as he
and his staff
climb onto air force one
and watch on a monitor press coverage
of the very same departure ceremony
uh in which they were featured a few
minutes before
we come out of back air force one and
he's up there taking films of everybody
but he took him everywhere and he wanted
to create this great library of the of
the nixon years and he was taking them
of all these wonderful places he had
been and seen i think and all the
history they were part of and he wanted
to uh but every time he was on a trip he
brought it along with him
one of the real highlights of the
holdwin footage is the historic trip to
china in 1972
here we are on air force one on
the way over
and we see some footage it's a pretty
historic itself bill rogers and henry
kissinger
together
uh talking in a relax to fashion with
the president united states
kissinger for his part
had a very prickly relationship with
rogers
whom he regarded as vain
and not particularly competent and it
made for a very tense
very uncomfortable
ongoing
battle really
some of it institutional and perhaps
unavoidable between the white house and
the state department
but greatly exacerbated by the personal
dislike and almost um contempt i don't
think it's too strong a word that these
two men felt for each other and nixon
was really in the middle
nixon was also preoccupied with
documenting his presidency
you know it makes sense that someone
like holderman
who was perhaps the most important
person certainly the person closest to
the president
would spend the amount of time and put
the amount of effort
that he did into visually documenting
the nixon presidency i think it was also
an understandable
concern that richard nixon was not seen
by most americans
as a touchy-feely
warm
charismatic figure
and there was a great concern presumably
beginning with the president himself
that the white house needed to do a
better job of communicating his humanity
his warmth his ability to write to
average people and what better person to
do that than your chief of staff
the footage in question is a great
metaphor
for a presidency that is
in fact obsessed with images
with how it's being presented with how
it's presenting itself and with how it
is being received both by the press
elite and by the general public
the tv coverage was just incredible and
the anchors went and all the big shots i
remember eric severod was there
and all of them all of the bigfoots were
there and john chancellor it was a great
crew barbara walters was on there
this world had been closed for 30 40
years to the west and to the americans
and here they were seeing this on
television
and here were these you know our worst
enemies on the on the earth and we're
downtown when we first went into the
great hall the people you know they're
playing turkey in the straw and god
bless america
the chinese people's army liberation
band it was just uh it was remarkable it
was just riveting here in another world
i'd been in moscow before nixon went
there in 71. beijing made moscow look
like new orleans and we waved to the
folks and just there wasn't a single
emotion or anything they're just looking
at us going by nobody waved nobody moved
or did anything people were doing their
exercises early in the morning there
were bicycles tiananmen square is a
gigantically open place i don't know any
place in america is that open sort of
and paved and everything very very few
cars or anything you're just in another
world there
if you see the great wall i mean if you
got the right picture with the big
picture i'm behind nixon in this big in
this russian hat that i got in moscow we
walked up the top of the wall and we
walked back down the or up to one of
those parapet type things and and we
walked back down but that was a it was a
photo op we were well aware of that i
don't even know if joe and i then those
fellas went up there with us this was a
little tour thing with us
but it was extraordinarily impressive
back home alderman also picked up his
camera to document some incredible
scenes around the white house and
downtown washington
as war protesters
enveloped the city twice in 1969
at one point forcing the administration
to call in the military
in fact here you can see
an amazing scene there these are
administration officials who are in fact
on top of the white house
watching this
demonstration
a threatened riot
as it is occurring all around them
i worked on saturday went down to get
another pack of cigarettes in the
cigarette machine in the basement and as
i told somebody i walked i ran into the
82nd airborne
it wasn't the 82nd but they were
airborne troops they had their
paratroopers boots on and these kids
were ready for action but we had what we
did is they had buses
a gigantic ring of buses all the way
around lafayette square and all the way
around down to e street virtually around
the entire white house so the huge crowd
couldn't get over now this was the time
in october and november
that one of them they had 5000 of them
broke off and trashed the department of
justice that's when john mitchell made
his famous tape i thought it was the
russian revolution but it's uh it was
enormous and we had helicopters up there
and doing the grid thing and they were
talking about five and six hundred
thousand there and that's when nixon
delivered his great silent majority
speech between those two demonstrations
you have to understand
that this was an administration
at war
that this was a country
in a sense at war with itself
and i think that footage illustrates
pretty dramatically the state of siege
that nixon and his administration felt
that they were
experiencing
and in a curious sort of way
there's a symbiotic relationship
between those waves of protesters
and the
perhaps paranoia that they generated
inside the oval office
it's always
unusual when we
get to peak behind the curtain i'm not
sure whether someone on the white house
staff would shoot this kind of footage
today
i'm not even sure in the era of the
special prosecutor whether we would have
this kind of record it's not just a
written record or diaries that
presidents no longer keep i'm not sure
they would take the risk of documenting
the visual
behind-the-scenes
history of their presidency
so this is a unique record
in many ways
particularly
given the button-down nature of the
nixon presidency that this was a
presidency that was so carefully
scripted
or at least tried to be in so many ways
that to see
this kind of footage
well
it's a record unlike any other
and i think it has a historical value
that probably won't grow
with time
from the
home like video shot by bob holman and
others at the white house to the replica
of the east room there at the yorba
linda base presidential library of
richard nixon it's a it's bigger though
than the actual east room by about 20
feet tim naphtali who is the director of
that library has something in front of
him that's called the image memo we're
talking about images in this last
segment
explain to us what what you have there
richard nixon uh loved the dictabelt
love the dictaphone and at at one point
in december of 1970 he dictated an 11
page memo
discussing his image so it wasn't just
haldeman that was concerned about his
image the president himself was
concerned
and
this passage i mean there are several
phenomenal passages in this particular
document but this passage says a lot
i speak first of the simple idea of
warmth i don't mean by that that we want
to get away from the fact that the
president is reserved dignified etc but
there are innumerable incidents of
warmth which have not come through now
here i want to emphasize a point which
will go against what sapphire would like
everybody wants me to sit down and talk
to members of the staff in a puffing way
about how nicey nice i've been to
members of the staff
that is not the way to do it if warmth
is to be believable it must be
discovered and at this stage there are
many examples
this is quite a remarkable document that
memo we have the entire memo 11 page
memo on our website you can find and
also don't forget that the website of
the nixon library has a lot of other
things that you can see but richard
norton smith when you hear this memo and
watch this footage what comes to mind
this is extraordinary interior
conversation that richard nixon is
having with himself
and the and the great irony is he
despises
most of the instruments the great media
outlets for example
that are
going to be projecting his image and
interpreting his image um it's it's just
it's remarkable and also you know here
is someone who has achieved the the
objective of his lifetime uh it is
extraordinary thing that the people in
the nixon white house are spending as
much time worrying about how they may
come across
um as opposed to simply
getting on with the job i can't imagine
harry truman and dwight eisenhower doing
it uh tim naftali for years this network
has dealt with john taylor familiar
figure to our audience or kevin
cartwright or sandy quinn and lots of
others
out there at the nixon library where are
they today and how did you find yourself
in this job
oh well they they still are
involved in the
nixon foundation john taylor the
reverend john taylor is the executive
director of the foundation uh sandy
quinn is one one of his assistants uh
how did i get this job well lord only
knows um i come come to this job as a
historian
i'm nonpartisan i'm not a republican i'm
an independent
my interest in presidential libraries is
that they be
a meeting place of ideas where people
can learn about history learn about
important periods in our history discuss
debate and disagree so for me it's a
privilege to be here i can't imagine a
more controversial and more interesting
presidency um than that of richard nixon
your background includes yale and johns
hopkins and harvard where you got your
degrees where were you right before you
took this job in april of last year
well i was the director of the
presidential recordings program at the
miller center of public affairs which
was at the university of virginia so i'd
had some experience working with nixon
tapes although most of our work was with
the johnson and kennedy tapes what what
i learned from that though was a sense
of the
the pace of presidential life one of the
things that people outsiders don't
understand and really you begin to
understand when you hear tapes is the
number of responsibilities that crash
and jump and jumble together for a
president every day he and maybe someday
she does not have the luxury of just
thinking about domestic policy one day
or foreign policy another these issues
come to them all at once so it gave me
an incredible sense of how complex a
presidency can be
and i suppose was good practice in
preparation for this presidency
earlier today i i had the uh pleasure or
or uh interest in watching what we're
about to see that uh comes from uh oral
histories and uh also video histories
that you have recorded yourself tell us
a little bit about that project and then
tell us about this story which i had
never heard before that dwight chapin
tells oh well first of all i haven't
done this these myself i mean i did most
of the interviews um but of course
there's a team of people helping me and
i have involved some outside historians
for some of the interviews but here was
the objective
if this library had been established in
the normal course of of events in other
words just after the president left
office they would have done an oral
history somebody would have done an oral
history but of course this this this
library doesn't wasn't established long
after nixon's death and and over 30
years after the end of his
administration so i felt it was
necessary to rush and to try to get on
tape on broadcast video the
reminiscences of the key people in the
air of the era not simply nixon veterans
but also those who mattered like charlie
rangel
and elizabeth holtzman
and john kerry so
we've done 41 up to now we plan to do at
least another 30 and this is a way of
bringing to life that era for for kids
primarily who don't really know these
players don't know the issues and i
think the way people learn these days is
through youtube and through an
interactive interactive experience and
for me that was the way to do it that
was the way to bring documents and the
other wonderful materials of the
presidency to life it was to get people
like dwight chapin who we'll hear from
in a moment actually describe what they
did now chapin was deputy assistant to
the president
chapin was part of the university of
southern california mafia that really
plays an interesting role in the
haldeman operation he like the madman he
goes into the advertising business he's
an advanced man as a young man he's he's
a baby boomer uh and what what happens
to this this man is that um
he begins to acquire more and more
responsibility and he's around nixon
he sees a lot of nixon he's with nixon
right next to him throughout the 1968
campaign and what we're about to hear is
a story that's never been published
never been described anywhere and
frankly if we didn't have an oral
history with white chapin we probably
never he never know about it and it
involves an improbable
relationship between richard nixon
and martin luther king jr's family
here's what i remember i remember this
incredible
tugging and pulling
does he go to the funeral does he not go
to the funeral does he go to the funeral
does he not go to the funeral
nixon's gut thing was i don't go to the
funeral because it's not credible i mean
i don't
you know i yes he's a national leader
but
i don't like taking advantage of going
to a funeral and being there when
uh
martin luther king and and i were not
good friends
we flew
it was uh
myself
and uh mr nixon
flew to atlanta
nick rui picked us up at the airport and
he had hired a guy
a kind of a limousine driver man
and and paid him enough to said this can
never be talked about
to the limousine driver
we got in the car
and we pull up in front of martin luther
king's
junior's home
we go in and we go up
onto the porches it was a very modest
home
and here were all of his children
and mr nixon talked to each one of them
and expressed his condolences
we then went down the back hallway
and and
into a bedroom
and laying on the bed with her propped
up on pillows was mrs martin luther king
president went over and sat on the side
of the bed
by the way he wasn't president the
candidate
went over sat on the side of the bed
took her hand and started talking to her
and i left the room
and i went back up with the kids
and i would say that
mr nixon was in there maybe five minutes
then he came back out
talked to the kids a little bit more we
got into the car
and we drove over to martin luther
king's seniors home
and he
went in he found
dr king
senior
and mrs king expressed his condolences
we were only there i would say 10 or 15
minutes
got in the car went back to the airport
got on the plane and went to the key
biscayne
villas and hotel in key biscayne florida
bb robozo had met us at the
airport drove us over there
so
now it is let's say 7 30 at night
and i'm in my
room my i had actually a little villa
kind of oh i'd say 30 yards from nixon's
and
he i get this call he says dwight can
you come over
so i go over and he's there with bb
robozo jane lucky who was bibi's
girlfriend and nixon there are three of
them are sitting on the couch it was
like a surreal thing i mean
watching some television show
and he says to me he said white house
how's our trip to
atlanta plane
and i said sir i have no idea
i'll i'll go check
so i go back and i called john whitaker
who had been the point man on putting
all of this together with nick and
i said john i said i think we've got a
problem
mr nixon is asking him it's plain john
says what the hell do you mean he said
this whole thing was to be off the
record nobody was to know
and i said well he's asking me about you
know how it's playing i think i think he
thought it was going to leak or
something
so
he said you better go check him and see
what he wants to do so i go back and i
said mr nixon
nothing's happened because you had
wanted to have this confidential and
nobody was to know
and he got furious he said damn it he
said i'm going to have to go back there
and go to that funeral if this is not
the whole purpose in our doing it was so
that we would do it privately we were
not taking advantage of it and
we would not have to go to the funeral
so
i
uh went back called whitaker whitaker
called
nick rui nick ruiz started calling radio
stations saying
i think i saw president nixon here
or a
former vice president nixon here
visiting the king family the radio
station is called the king home
and the king family wouldn't confirm it
because they had been told that it was
to be confidential that mr nixon didn't
want anybody to know
and they wouldn't confirm it so i mean
this thing was it was a disaster
former nixon aide dwight chapin telling
a story i've never heard it before what
well first of all that is a textbook
example of what oral history at its very
best is because we all know in this town
there's a lot of history that never gets
put on paper and there's a very good
example that at the nixon library and
and tim in particular had not gone out
after that story it would have been lost
to history the footnote of course is
that that funeral
was very largely organized and paid for
by nelson rockefeller
how do you know who did keep it a secret
who wanted it kept the secret and kept
it i mean he paid for the actual funeral
yeah he he sent as soon as dr king uh
was uh was assassinated uh rockefeller
who had a long-standing relationship
with the king family sent his best
advanced people down to atlanta and said
money's no object you're there to you
know to help the king family um and to
organize this thing and actually an
advanced man named joe canzeri went out
and found the wagon
that was drawn the mule-drawn wagon that
people remember of course from the from
the uh from the public procession
and rockefeller said there's one thing
though i wanted kept absolutely out of
the press and and it was until now but
you mentioned uh it's easier for me to
ask you this question than tim naphtali
about this oral history thing you've run
the eisenhower reagan ford uh
hoover libraries uh
do all the libraries expect to do this
kind of thing that's a great question
you know the earlier libraries did do
oral histories they had oral historians
on their staff they had a budget to do
oral history
and it was just part of the program and
somewhere along the way
um
say post-johnson
that no longer was the case now the
miller center at the university of
virginia has sort of stepped into the
breach and done a lot of oral history on
its own
but i think this project at the nixon is
up is again is a classic example of
intellectual entrepreneurship the next
little bit of information we're going to
show you is three minutes and 28 seconds
long and then we're going to take some
calls so the numbers you'll see up on
the screen and you can begin dialing now
we want to get your questions or
comments in remember this is not meant
to be an in-depth look at president
nixon or any of the presidents its
approach we took was to look for new and
interesting information to give you some
idea of how you can do your own research
if you're interested in getting behind
the stories that you've heard in the
past what's next this clip first of all
daniel ellsberg
was a former defense analyst
who in fact had been supportive of the
war turned against the war and decided
in 1971 to leak what were known as the
pentagon papers which were a 4 000 page
government commission history of u.s
involvement in vietnam
the nixon white house decided to
prosecute
ellsberg
and the case in fact against the times
went all the way to the supreme court
which ruled six to three against the
president uh who you're about to hear
commiserating in the wake of that with j
edgar hoover might suggest you listen
carefully to this
edgar yeah i wanted to tell you that i
was so damn mad when that supreme court
had to come down i first didn't like
their decision but neither unbelievable
wasn't it
you know those clowns we've got on there
i'll tell you i hope i outlive the
bastards well i hope you do too i mean
politically too because
we've got to change that court there's
no question about that whatsoever i
thought it was a possibility of a five
to four yeah you know i thought i
thought we ought to get white what's the
matter with him i don't well of course
wizard white is an old kennedy crowd
well then the other one know what in the
hell is the matter with stewart well
stuart is a is a very wishy-washy
individual he switches from one side to
the other yeah and i wasn't surprised
that he on this thing he switched uh you
know one thing i was gonna i'm gonna ask
your question but a lot of people have a
feeling that i ought to
not a lot some if they're all mixed as a
matter of fact some people think that
now that this court has acted that i
ought to make a statement about the
freedom of the press and that we are
trying to censor them and so forth
my inclination
whatever is worthy is not to say so i
tell you i think you're right i i kind
of think i should stay out but what's
your what's your public relations
judgment on that girl i'd just like to
remember the judgment uh mr president is
that you should remain absolutely silent
about it you would i would watch it now
you don't think that that that's any
great problem that they
they've been uh
you know that naturally been charging
that we have been trying to keep the
press from printing the truth about the
war
that's involved because as a matter of
fact these papers don't harm you one bit
no actually that's stories in the in the
post and time this morning were all
about kennedy and dm kennedy he was the
one who started it and then lyndon
johnson escalated it and then you
inherited it and you have brought it
down you never sent an additional man in
there but you brought it down and i
think what they're trying to do is
debate tuned in into taking a position
that
the freedom of the press ought not be to
that to that extent
and i think we ought to be awful careful
what we do in this case of this man
ellsberg
because there again they're going to
make a martyr out of him
all of the press of the country are
going across come to the front
that he's a martyr and when you what the
supreme court has now said
uh i doubt whether we're going to be
able to get a conviction of him i hope
so but i doubt it we've got a good
strong case on him and his wife tested
his first wife testified very
vigorously against him
and uh
it's a good strong case but i'd like to
check some of the other people around
them that's the others there's i think
there's a conspiracy involved
of the new york times is involved is
full of jack henderson here in
washington that skunk that we have here
too oh yeah he's in it he was at the at
the post and had copies made
i saw her on the tv last night mrs
graham i would have thought she's about
85 years old she's only about i think uh
something like 57. oh no i know that and
i had an idea she was a great year older
when i looked at her last night his age
terabytes she's a terrible old bag oh
she's an old [ __ ] in my estimations
right but uh i i i think from your point
of view it would be very ill advised you
don't think we should i should say
anything i don't think you should say
anything just let it cool let the papers
come out and let them reflect on whoever
they reflect what they want to print it
doesn't reflect upon you you had nothing
to do with all of this i had nothing yet
that's not nothing it was about me
tim nestali at yorba linda how many more
conversations like this have we not
heard
many
there are three 3 800 hours of tapes and
we've only revealed we've only released
2 000. one of the things i'm
we're focusing on in college park by the
way the library is still divided i have
staff in both college park maryland and
here in york linda we're focusing on the
releasing the last crown the last 1800
hours of tapes there's a lot to come so
there are more many more conversations
like this one to come richard norton
smith what about the
president nixon and his relationship
with the media well i think it's fair to
say it was tumultuous
although actually it's funny you know
they thought they got a pretty decent uh
shaken during the 68 campaign but it
really didn't last very long and what
we're about to see
really uh reflects uh again another
defining moment the nixon presidency in
the fall of 1969 uh as we heard earlier
from pat buchanan in between two of the
of the great moratorium demonstrations
in washington there's a real turning
point a fork in the road the nixon
presidency
rather than lose the agenda nixon goes
up to camp david for several days and
comes down from the mountain with a a
really pivotal speech
in which he coins the phrase silent
majority an attempt to rally
a majority of cultural conservatives
behind his vietnam policy and that in
turn sets in motion uh a sequence of
events that you're about to hear
described
what happened was the elites and the
media trashed the speech uniformly the
media then was television two-thirds of
the american people got their news from
network tv and the networks had their
instant analysis
and i sent him a memo and he they were
saying again you know write letters the
editor and i said we got to go after the
after the networks directly publicly use
the bully pill but counter attack them
and and and i got a note at the top of
my memo it says p has seen
go ahead
and so i write this speech
and i worked it up and it was really it
was you know and i've been thinking of
it for a long time
and i send it over to nixon
and uh i get a call
and so he calls he calls me over there's
nixon and he's got his glasses on he
very rarely wore those he wore those in
the oval office and this speech is
really honed and ready to go
and he's sitting there and he's writing
little things adding little animals
which i didn't want in there and so i
could feel the pain all sudden
he looks up and says
this will tear the scab off those
bastards
let's take a call miami florida you're
on go ahead please uh good evening i
i heard a glimpse of
some of mr nixon's profanity and
vulgarity but i think it should also be
pointed out and that it's often
overlooked how anti-semitic he was he
made many many anti-semitic statements
over the years and he and he had his
public enemies list and i think very
often your presidential historians like
to gloss over that i mean mr buchanan
was also involved in the presidential
election in florida and we had problems
with that as well and his cronies mr
nixon's cronies were well-known
anti-semites and it's never never
reported by any of you and one other
little thing i also note that on your
screen when you give the telephone
numbers i'm amazed to see that the
republicans are listed on the top line
they're finally out of power and you
folks don't seem to want to recognize
that the democrats now control congress
tim naftali what do you say about the
earlier comments from the gentleman
well the the beauty of this library is
that we're completely transparent and
open
on our website when we open in july we
posted various memoranda
because they were interesting not
because they put the president in a good
light or a poor light
we plan to have interactive exhibits
here that show all elements of the
presidency including the personal
aspects that this gentleman raised there
is no question but there are slurs
in the tapes slurs against very various
minority groups we don't take sides here
we don't say
this is what it is if you want to study
president nixon you have to study all of
president nixon you can't just study the
good side you can't just study the dark
side
the the beauty of this library is it's
completely transparent you'll get it all
here no filtering we're non-partisan
we're american remember the beauty of
this country is we're not afraid to tell
the truth about our leaders that's what
makes us different that's why we're not
like north korea or not like uh iran and
this library like all the libraries this
library is going to make sure you will
learn it all
to the caller on the second point
we switch
the
party uh every month so just hang in
there we'll have the democrats back on
top for you a skoda michigan you're on
the air oh thanks glad i'm on top right
well i thought it was zero zero one and
then zero zero two but what do i know
right hey i do remember uh president
nixon as a young boy well teenager
and certainly his uh intellect was
undeniable i'm just wondering in i don't
know if you want to comment on this but
do you think if president nixon had say
the style or even should i say the looks
this is a fluff question i understand do
you think he could have withstood
watergate
he certainly was a dedicated man i doubt
that he slept too much i think he
studied all the time
can you give us a little insight on it
mr smith
well i don't think luke's had anything
to do with nixon's election or the way
the nixon presidency ended i think
if you forgive me what really fascinates
me i've often said that the remarkable
thing about the nixon presidency isn't
how it ended but that it occurred at all
and i mean by that nixon's temperament
nixon himself famously said that he was
an introvert in an extroverts profession
he was a closet intellectual he was not
a natural william sapphire in his book
before the fall has a wonderful little
vignette uh they're on the campaign
trail nixon's about to weave the plane
and uh sapphire says boy you must enjoy
this this you know all of this
campaigning he said nope campaigns are
just something to get through
and and that's
that's
revealing chicago you're next go ahead
please
good evening c-span it's really nice to
be able to speak with you evening
i love the program and this series is
excellent
here is my question
how are this is directed to mr smith
how are you myself our children our
grandchildren anyone supposed to believe
what is
documented
his history that's documented about this
country when it is well known that
persons like j edgar hoover
edited many files he
took things he had things he had
information destroyed he had information
inserted
to
his liking and to what he wanted
the public to know how are we supposed
to believe anything that is on film that
is memorable that is written that is
recorded when this man manipulated
historical documented files thanks well
that's a fair question but i guess i'd
answer i asked your answer your question
with the question is
um
maybe not a question in the end there's
something that hoover couldn't
manipulate it's called history
and historians
um the fact of the matter is that
hoover's reputation since his death in
1972
has tumbled uh pretty significantly uh
we've learned a lot of things we didn't
know about hoover we learned a lot of
things we didn't know about or maybe
only suspected about the way he ran the
fbi the fbi is an organization that
certainly has been transformed
the fact is through a free press through
historical intellectual inquiry and yes
through
instruments like c-span
letting the opening the windows letting
the air in if you will
in the end
history
has a way of
humbling
even the most powerful semi-florida go
ahead please
yeah hello
my name is garfield washington adams
my date of birth is march 21st 1972.
a year later i was uh celebrating my
first birthday with my parents
and uh it was march 21st 1973 and that
is the same date of the the smoking gun
tape
with uh um nixon and john dean it was
march 21st 1972 and that was my first
birthday
also my other antidote
i had a cousin he was serving in um
in vietnam
south vietnam with the um the special
forces and he he was leading a group of
of south vietnamese popular forces
in a place called the rock sac special
zone because his name is
lieutenant he's commander william culley
like that he served with the green
berets like that
and the rucksack special zone is a place
called it that has an escort that leads
to toward the mekong delta and he was
out there with a couple of uh um south
vietnamese popular forces you know
because after special forces were being
being withdrawn because of
vietnamization
when which we'll call it um
north vietnamese sharpshooter you know
um
sized him up and he was killed he was
killed in action on march 21st 1972.
that's also the day of my birth thank
you caller uh tim naphtali uh tell us
some more about uh the the uh
room that you're in and other figures in
the room who are you standing by there
i just before before i i tell you that i
just want to comment on the caller's
point
one of the things that's really
important to keep in mind is a
presidential library is a point of
intersection not in in one's personal
history um so that people come here not
simply to learn about the life of one
president but also of an era an era they
grew up in in the case of the caller
who's very young but an era that means a
lot to them and that's important for us
at the library one of the things i hope
to do eventually is not just capture the
the memories of very famous people from
the 70s but the memories of of younger
people or older people um who whose
children and grandchildren and
great-grandchildren should be coming to
this library
in decades to come and will find not
something it's not simply information
about
richard nixon in the 70s but also
information about their own families i
think i think you've got to maintain
that point of intersection between
personal history and national history
now around me speaking of great
historians and great history historical
figures
we have here
two of the russian leaders soviet
leaders that nix interacted with when he
was vice president he was engaged in the
famous kitchen debate in mid-1959 with
nikita khrushchev remember this is
life-size he was a small man but he was
built like a mack truck and believe me
he was full of energy this is leonard
brezhner leonard brezhnev ultimately
would have the sort of historical
reputation of being rather ill
the soviets came to call his period the
era of stagnation but in fact he was a
vigorous leader during the early 70s and
it was he as much as nixon who pushed
for de taunt between the soviet union
and the united states
here to my left we have
a conversation that never happened
sadat never had a conversation with
golda meir golda meiner was prime
minister of israel sadat of course was
was
nasser's successor as the president of
of the united arab republic or egypt
very important characters in nixon's
history nixon is president during the
yom kippur war of october 1973. it's in
that period in october 73 first of all
that the united states and israel were
both taken
by surprise when egypt and syria and
jordan attacked israel
israel was caught off guard and in the
early going was in military trouble the
united states responded
the united states responded by sending
six seven days after the invasion
a massive airlift that
richard nixon okayed symboling this
symbolizing this country's commitment to
the state of israel for israelis what
the united states did in october 73 was
the greatest symbol of this country's
commitment to israel's independence
so these two uh leaders uh symbolize the
yom kippur war and then in the last year
of nixon's administration as he was
desperately looking for some political
triumphs he went to egypt he went to the
arab world he went to syria he met assad
in syria and he went to meet with saddam
azad in the beginnings of the
relationship with the egyptians that
would lead to the famous camp david
accord between bagan and sadat when
jimmy carter was president were laid in
the nixon administration over here we
have three titans from europe the first
of course is winston churchill whom
richard nixon had met when he was vice
president
churchill by the mid 50s he was premier
again of great britain prime minister
after his wartime premiership he was a
little bit uh a little on the soft side
but he was still representative of the
great lion who had stood up against nazi
aggression in world war ii
de gaulle i believe it's in nixon's
writings gaga was perhaps the leader he
most admired
in many ways de gaulle was the man that
nixon had hoped
would be his mentor in europe but de
gaulle would die early in the first term
of nixon's administration and therefore
that relationship that nixon had wanted
never came to pass but nixon did meet
with him on his first trip to europe in
1969. this is conrad adenauer conrad
adenauer
was the first chancellor of west germany
and adenauer had been a staunch opponent
of the of the
nazi regime he had in fact been in
prison by the gestapo briefly um and he
was a symbol of the new germany
nixon knew him from his vice
presidential period
so these three men represented for him
the new europe the post-war europe that
the united states helped reconstruct and
then ultimately help defend against the
soviet union next call north
attleborough massachusetts good evening
hi how are you this evening
um you know i noticed the derogatory
nature with which you know mr nixon
spoke with the supreme court justices to
mr hoover and i was just wondering might
they have been privy to any of these
tapes or
you know were they just locked in a lock
in a file at that point mr smith
uh i'm not sure if you mean were the
justices yes privy well ironically of
course um
the case that in some ways doomed the
nixon presidency involved 64 tapes that
the watergate special prosecutor wanted
and in the summer of 1974 nixon had
invoked the doctrine of executive
privilege to try to keep those tapes
out of the hands of the of the
watergate special prosecutor's office
and the supreme court including several
of his own appointees ruled unanimously
that the doctrine of executive privilege
did not apply
uh where a potential criminal conspiracy
was involved westchester pennsylvania go
ahead please
when richard nixon
ran against jfk
he lost by a very small
vote
richard nixon never contested that
election it's my understanding
could you give us some insight into why
he did not contest the election mr smith
well you know that's a very good
question
the debate goes on as to whether
particularly in the states of illinois
and texas which were carried as you've
indicated by very narrow margins mayor
daley in illinois and the
texas was texas in those days
there were those um including the
republican national chairman thurston
morton even dwight eisenhower for
example uh had suggested that maybe his
vice president should contest this um
nixon seems to have given it some
consideration but not much he thought
that it could tear the party or tear the
country apart
the cynics say that
republicans in downstate illinois may
have stolen as many votes as democratic
the machine in chicago
but i think it it really
does testify uh to nixon's character and
a certain degree of self-sacrifice
last call for this segment baltimore
maryland you're on the air go ahead
please no i'm scared
hello
hello you're on the air
i visited the nixon museum in july of
05. i'm interested in how the museum has
changed since detroit revealed his
identity
kim natalie
well the museum is going to change
completely in 19 in 2005 it was owned
and operated by a private nixon
foundation which had a different mission
from the united from the national
archives we are developing a
non-partisan interactive museum in fact
one of the things we've done is in
consultation with the foundation we had
the watergate exhibit dismantled and
we're working on a new one i believe
later in the program we will be
discussing that
by the way what was wrong with the
watergate
display under the other regime
well
it presented watergate from only
president nixon's perspective
and this is a museum paid for by the
right now this is a library paid for by
the american people this is not in a
republican library this is not a
democratic library this belongs to
everyone everybody's tax dollars goes to
this library and therefore our exhibits
have to reflect history
one of the biggest selling items in any
presidential library is the elvis
t-shirt out there at that library we
you've got an elvis story for us uh tim
naphtali tell us
well
and now for something completely
different
i'm
we have some remarkable things to show
about this and let's start
by viewing something my our curator
olivia anastasiades is going to show a
phenomenal piece that we have here in
your belinda
hi
this here is a world war ii
commemorative
cold 45 gun actually it's a
semi-automatic weapon and it was given
to president nixon by elvis presley on
his visit to the white house in december
of 1970 and the curious thing about it
was that elvis talked about a gift to
the president in a letter that he had
written on american airline stationery
when he was on route to visit with the
president
and
the story goes that he uh had brought it
to the northwest gate and his secret
service were
just up in arms you can't take a firearm
into the oval office so uh
the gun was you know nicely uh taken
away and ellis presley was able to
be taken into the oval office and meet
with the president
tim daphnelly uh we've got some oral
history uh with a fellow named jerry
schilling and bud crow
can you tell us what that is and we'll
show that we're going to have a break
and then we'll come back with the second
half
okay
we decided to bring together the two
surviving participants in the elvis
nixon meeting of december 1970.
jerry schilling
was a long time member of the memphis
mafia he had actually just left elvis
employ when elvis pulled him back
to go on this incredible journey to
washington at to deliver a letter to
richard nixon eagle bud kroge who you
hear was the staffer on the white house
side who was given the job of actually
bringing elvis in to meet with richard
nixon when it was decided that perhaps
elvis should be able to deliver his
letter in person an improbable meeting
and a meeting that was kept secret for
over 10 years
it's it's amusing because if you think
about the administration's concern about
image
how much better for nixon's image
richard nixon's image would have been if
he had actually admitted to having met
elvis presley in 70 but we wouldn't know
about it until long after he'd left
office but now listen to schilling and
bud krog talk about their experience and
see how oral history can knit together
a a period a moment that otherwise would
be lost in time
the driver the limousine driver
it took us to i forgot which gate it was
north
north gate white house gate and
elvis said jerry just stay here i'm
going to
take this to the guards at the gate
and i said fine
well
i'm keeping a pretty close eye on elvis
and he gets out
and you know we all the world knows what
he was wearing you know it's pretty
normal for me but you know he had a high
collar top coat his hair was a little
longer than usual he had a cane
and
it's not full daylight
and he jumps out of the back of a black
limousine
the white house security guards were
pretty stiff and i think they were
you know like
who is this what you know what is this
i see it's not going well so i jump out
of the limousine and
i go excuse me gentlemen but you know
this is mr elvis presley he just wanted
to drop off this letter to the president
and they immediately their whole
demeanor changed what was a was so
amazing to me was after a secret service
man opened the door to the oval office i
ushered him in to the office and elvis
just stopped now here's a man who had
entertained millions of people all over
the world and i thought that he'd be
right at home and feel very comfortable
in the oval office but such was not the
case
he looked up in the ceiling and he saw
eagles and blazing in the ceilings in
the ceiling he saw an eagle in the
carpet in the floor eagles festooning
the service flags to the right of the
president's desk and it was like oh my
gosh here i am a poor boy from tupelo
mississippi in the oval office
well i had to sort of nudge him across
the room over to the president's desk
out came his badges from different law
enforcement departments around the
country a picture of priscilla
his wife a picture of lisa marie and
then we began show and tell in the oval
office
and they talked about how elvis could
help the drug program
uh basically help us with a number of
things how to reach young people with
the dangers of drugs and then he asked
the president can you get me a badge
from the bureau of narcotics the
president looked at me said bud can we
get him a badge i said sir if you want
to get him a badge we can do that he
said we'll see that he gets one
elvis was so overwhelmed with this he
stepped forward grabbed the president
with his left arm and hugged him
now
hugging was not the norm in the oval
office at least in my in my experience
and after that
his bodyguards came in president nixon
came over kind of
like a guy's guy hit me on the arm and
said elvis you got a couple of big ones
here
and he said you guys play football and
we talked a little bit about football
and
and the president went behind his desk
to give them gifts which was customary
open the bottom left-hand drawer and one
of my abiding memories
is of elvis presley realizing that's
where the gold was going behind the desk
rooting through the drawer with the
president
both of them coming up with gifts and
then and then elvis saying mr president
remember they have wives and he goes
mr president
called him mr president he said mr
president
uh you know they have wives too and
and the president said oh well let's see
what we can you know let's see what we
can find he walks back over to his desk
and he's rummaging around
this is how comfortable elvis felt
elvis is rummaging in the president's
desk with him looking for things for
our wives and out came the gifts for
girls and sweethearts and wives they
left loaded down in fact they've done
all their christmas shopping and a five
minute trip into the oval
we now continue with our visit to the
richard nixon presidential library
exploring the life and career of our
37th president
welcome back to our program on richard
nixon you're looking at the video of the
37th president
at the white house wedding of his
daughter tricia
tonight we're focusing on the
collections of the nixon library both
from yorba linda california and college
park maryland
we begin the second part of our program
with nixon library director tim naftali
as he takes us on a taped tour
of the artifacts vault in college park
maryland
we're now in college park at our
facility at a2
the nixon library is divided between
the collection here in college park
maryland and the library itself in yorba
linda california
what you see around you is something
extremely unusual you normally wouldn't
see this but then there's nothing really
usual about the nixon library
here you have the head of state gifts
and the domestic gifts received by
president and mrs nixon and some of
their associates during the nixon
administration
those gifts were wrapped up put away in
storage after president nixon resigned
and for the first part for the most part
have never been exhibited anywhere
so once they get to your belinda
we will be able to exhibit these for the
very first time and we're talking about
gifts and we'll be looking at a few that
range from textiles to jewelry
to folk art
anything given to a president of the
united states by anyone is cataloged
preserved and then put away for ultimate
display at a presidential library
so let's start with
some remarkable pieces
in 1973
an international convention
to protect endangered
animals
made the importation or sale of ivory
illegal
president nixon is the last president to
have been able to receive ivory as gifts
and we have perhaps the best collection
of ivory presidential ivory
anywhere
you will see some ivory here there's
some other ivory in the remainder of the
vault
this particular piece comes from the
government of south vietnam
other pieces come from african
governments
this collection
is of pieces of solid ivory
shaped like fruit
and these were present
from the emperor of the central african
republic
the infamous bokassa
all of these pieces
will ultimately be on display in europa
linda
i'm just giving you a smattering of some
of
my favorite pieces and the favorite
pieces of of the archivists
here are some examples of
a folk art and gifts from the public
this
is a footprint
of a dinosaur from the
uh triassic period
uh this footprint was discovered by two
high school students in livingston new
jersey
in 1972
here is a little folk art
a gift from an american citizen to
president nixon
of course it's a milk jug and this is a
milk jug that celebrates his trip to
china
and the
possibilities of peace
from his triangular diplomacy
here we have two different
kinds of gifts
on the right hand side
you have again some folk art
uh from a lady in new jersey
oh no this one actually i'm sorry this
one is from a gentleman from orlando
florida
and the title of this piece is
perfectly clear it's perfectly clear
there's a cube he's looking into the
cube and the cube or here
either one is making it perfectly clear
uh that arrived to the white house in
1972 actually during the campaign of 72.
on the left
is a remarkable head of state gift
this is
real malachite green malachite and it
comes from
uh general mobutu of the congo this is a
gift to mrs nixon and
the first first ladies cannot keep these
gifts
whenever something is given to either
the president or the first lady it is
cataloged and put away
they may be able to wear it on
ceremonial occasions but at the end of
the administration it's
returned to the night it's given to the
national archives so here is a present
from
general mobutu of the congo
perhaps the most beautiful head of state
gifts that we have
are from africa
and this is
jewelry
pure gold
from
the government of
cote
or the ivory coast this is pure gold
you have here a pendant
and a bracelet
we have other gold jewelry this is just
representative of some of what we have
and i i felt this was and
archivists agree with me this is perhaps
the most the most stunning of the gold
jewelry but there's quite a bit of gold
jewelry from africa that president mrs
nixon were
given now
not everything is jewelry
or
a gem
it could be a gem of a different kind
this is a gift from a private citizen a
pakistani gentleman
who was struck by the election of
president nixon
and decided to
give him
what he called
nixon's multi-man personality
and this is a depiction
of nixon's various personalities as seen
by this gentleman from lahore pakistan
nixon churchill of america commanding
appearance friend of the world nixon
peacemaker nixon judicious and nixon
intellectual
much of our collection has been packed
and is ready for shipment your belinda
but we have a few things that we've put
out just for you to look at today
remember that the nix administration
occurred in the 70s
think about the colors of the 70s if
you've seen that 70s show you you were
you've been reminded of it if you didn't
live through that era this is a perfect
representation of the 1970s
this is from a lady in mississippi
um mrs adair
this was sent to the white house in
december of 1971 so it's just after
uh tricia nixon married edward cox in a
in a celebrated and beautiful wedding
ceremony
uh you can see uh edward cox and trisha
on the left you can see the president
and king timoho his dog
in the foreground there of course the
president and pat nixon
julie and david eisenhare on the right
and then various mythical beings that do
not animals that do not live
on the south lawn of the white house
i just there was something psychedelic
about this image that i felt really
captured the era
and again it's representative of
rose of this kind of
uh folk art that has been has been given
to the president
now we moved from american folk art uh
to
some russian fine art this was a gift
from
the the kremlin
from brezhnev
padgorni and kossigan the three top
leaders of the soviet union at the time
that richard nixon
was in office these are the three
leaders during the period of dayton
between the united states and the soviet
union this is a
vision at dusk
of moscow this is the moscow river
this painting
was a gift during
the second summit
this
is a gift from pope paul vi
to richard nix nixon just after his
inauguration went to europe on an
extended
tour
um and one of the places he visited was
the vatican
and he returned
in air force one with this uh this is
saint peter's of course is saint peter's
basilica
painting dates from the 17th century
this is another beautiful piece of ivory
um we as i said we have many pieces of
ivory
uh
and we're
coming up to
my favorite
of all of these
gifts i mean
the
the the piece from mobutu is beautiful
and the uh the the jewelry from the ivor
coast is stunning and what complements
by the way the jewelry from the ivory
coast is some remarkable textiles that
we have from africa now those have
already been packed so i can't show them
today but eventually we'll have a
remarkable show of african textiles just
remarkable because the
the preservation staff at the national
archives have maintained these items so
that they retain their color and they
have
wonderful dyes and wonderful colors so
you'll have that remarkable group
but not every gift is that serious in
fact i have a gift here on my left that
i haven't the foggiest idea what to do
with
just because i'm director of the library
doesn't mean i know where everything
should go and this particular gift which
i love is one that well i love your
suggestions as to what to do with it
make those kind suggestions please this
is
a very large clamshell
this was a gift
from the philippine ambassador to the
united states to president mrs nixon
uh
this is a
created i can take it out of the crate
it's going to find its way to your
belinda
and i haven't the foggiest idea what to
do with it
it um it would make a nice fountain
uh it might we could use it as a table i
suppose uh no i'm just kidding because
in fact it's an artifact
what's going to surprise many of you and
that's i think you've noticed this as
you've watched the series about
presidential libraries is that when
something is given to the national
archives when it's given to a president
it's treated
as you would treat the most the rarest
piece of a museum collection
so this
clam is an artifact
and
we have to find an appropriate way to
display it in your belinda
as i said i'm looking forward to your
suggestions
the voice of tim naphtali the director
of the president nixon library in yorba
linda that though was in college park
right out here in the suburbs on the
screen president nixon is meeting with
his cabinet officers william rogers is
secretary of state there on the right
and uh
we're moving into another segment here
of uh some oral history with john
mitchell and uh leonard garmut
the subject uh
tell us more about
this segment richard norton well first
of all
john mitchell who is a very prominent
name in the history of the nixon
administration
attorney general and it's appropriate
that we're looking at footage of the
cabinet because every president wants to
have at least one
person in the cabinet who's his guy
john kennedy famously made his brother
bobby attorney general nixon didn't know
many members of his cabinet he didn't
have long-standing relationships with
him
he did with john mitchell john mitchell
was at the law firm in new york to which
nixon relocated in 1963 after his defeat
in the race for governor of california
he was a bond lawyer expert on municipal
finance
tough guy very knowledgeable guy and
someone who'd actually been around the
political process because of his work in
municipal finance particularly in new
york
john mitchell
well john mitchell becomes first
campaign manager well no
he becomes a campaign manager in 1968
then attorney general and then of course
the head of the committee to reelect the
president in 1972
when garment is also at the law firm of
nixon mudge rose guthrie and alexander
and in his own words is a liberal jew
from new york and someone who
illustrates i think
something that may surprise people the
the diversity of nixon's
closest associates
um government would come down to
washington eventually go into the white
house was very involved with
school desegregation
national endowment for the arts and the
humanities uh and other policies never
really got into the inner circle uh and
as a result was spared the
stigma of watergate
the gentleman that we have had here at
c-span uh during this last year working
on this and doing all the research at
the libraries working with people like
tim naphtali and his staff eric nelson
who we uh
appreciate every week as we see some of
this stuff for the first time this is a
an oral
history interview tim f tally did with
len garman it said two minutes and 30
seconds
armature was a very a very interesting
very good man
um a strong character
who
was very good at
at politics
and very bad at measuring his own
capabilities
uh
and with the
assistance of richard nixon made him
what was a fatal mistake
which was being persuaded to take on the
attorney general post
he was
completely unqualified for that job
particularly since he was also
president's
primary political advisor
i mean it
was a conflict of interest and
a marriage of incompatible
qualities
of a historic nature
and that was the way
his history and perhaps the history
of the nixon presidency was was
written
because uh
you can
follow that line all the way down to
watergate
and you find that he
had lost his capacity for independent
action by then as a result of
the mistakes he made
in this mixed role of political advisor
and attorney general
he's a very good man i mean he was uh
and he tried
he
wanted to do the right thing he was
burdened by a very a wife who was sick
um who had
not only a drinking problem but had a
kind of a related mania
that drove
mitchell somewhat crazy and contributed
to his
episodes of instability
[Music]
and he was indispensable to the election
of uh
of richard nixon
um
probably both times
and he was
a
major contributing cause to the
collapse of the nixon presidency
tim naphtali
and uh your belinda
martha mitchell is who len garment was
referring to
do you have anything in the library that
you've seen that we could i mean i know
we don't have it tonight but is there
anything on martha mitchell what she
looks like what she sounds like and how
important was she to this story
well she's very important to
understanding john mitchell
they had a celebrated love affair
uh and her personal collapse really
undermined his ability has it distracted
him and many people in our oral
histories refer to
uh the the personal strain uh on
mitchell
some argue that that's why he gave the
go-ahead for operation gemstone for the
political espionage operation that would
include among other things breaking into
the watergate hotel
and office complex
um one of the things that's really
important to understand is that when len
garmand is asked by the president
to be his his lawyer
uh near the end of the administration
garment and the and president nixon have
a one-on-one conversation and
and president assures garment that he
did not participate in covering up
um the break-in he says i wasn't
involved in the breakup i did not order
it and i didn't cover it up
what we're about to hear
um is the tape of a conversation that
when it's revealed in august and on
august 5th of 1974 makes clear to a lot
of people that president nixon
uh engaged in a cover-up
after the break-in on june 17th 1972 and
people like glenn garman would be
shocked
when they heard this tape
this tape is of a conversation that
comes only five or only six days after
the break-in
and there
both ehrlichman and mitchell and john
dean are thinking about what to do and
mitchell and john dean come up with this
idea what we should do is we should get
we should get the fbi to stop its
investigation of the cuban
cuban burglars the cuban-american
burglars who are who are actually
captured the night of june 17th what we
should do is we should tell the fbi that
in fact this is a cia operation and they
should back off we should get the cia to
do our bidding to be the one to go to
the fbi to acting
fbi director patrick gray someone who
had replaced jedi hoover who died the
year before to get gray to say to have
great back off when richard helms who
was then director of central
intelligence said to him sorry this is
actually cia operation covert operation
and frankly justice department fbi
should should just stand away from it
this is what happens
in the oval office when this idea about
how to get the fbi from to stop
investigating the money and the other
elements of the story that would make
clear white house involvement how the
fbi is to be handled and hear the idea
the proposal is made to richard nixon
and it's richard nixon's response that
would cause him such political trouble
two years later
that's fine
now on the
investigation you know the democratic
break-in thing we're back in
the problem area because the fbi is not
under control because grey doesn't
exactly know how to control this and
they have their investigation is now
leading in some productive areas because
they've been able to trace the money not
through the money itself but to define
you know
sources and the banker
stuff and it goes
some directions we don't want it to go
uh
also there's been some
things like the employment came in off
the street to the fbi in miami were
photographer who has a friend that's a
guitar who developed some films for this
guy parker
and the belts had
pictures of democratic national
committee
letter in
documents so he's
mitchell came up with yesterday
and john dean analyzed very carefully
last night and concludes concurs now
with mitchell's recommendation that the
only way to solve this and we're set up
beautifully to do it
uh
in that the next the only effort that
pays me attention to last time was nbc
who did a massive story on a human
thing
that the way to handle this now is
for us to
have walters call pat gray
and just say
state of hell out of this this is uh
there's business here we don't want you
that's not an unusual development
will then have the faces he'll call mark
and the two of them and mark bell wants
to cooperate because he's ambitious you
know
uh
they'll call them in and say we've
gotten a signal
across the river to
put the holes on this and that'll fit
rather well because the fbi agents who
are working the case at this point feel
that's what it is
there's a cia
but there's
that went to the mexican bank which they
can also trace through the next event
they'll get their names today
and
well i mean uh there's no way that i'm
just thinking
if they don't cooperate what are they
saying that they they were
approached by the cubans and that's what
dahlberg has to say in the texas two of
them
they say the only way to do that is the
white house instruction
and it's got to be to help stand
uh what's this name
walters
and the proposal would be that our hero
and
lot of skin obviously open that scan
there's a whole lot of things that we
just feel that this would be very
economical to have this thing going
further and this involves cubans and
a lot of hanky-panky that we have
nothing to do with
ourselves what the hell did mitchell
know about this thing that it wasn't we
had that stuff
i don't think he knew the details that i
think he did like he handled the dollar
texans
who is
[Music]
apparently to get more information as he
got more pressure he pushed
the people harder to move harder
apparently
oh mentioned visualism
all right
on your screen is a video tape of the
president's diary from june 23 excuse me
1972
tim naphtali did the
you know the language the president uses
uh on that tape did he realize it
someday that he think that it was going
to be
exposed at some point
not at all in fact
president nixon from february of 1971
through july of 1973 had a sound
activated uh taping system it captured
everything
that occurred in the oval office he also
had uh one room in camp david he had his
telephones
wired he had
his secretive office in the old
executive office building wired that's
why we have 3 800 hours of tape richard
nixon never expected the tapes to be
made public and why did he believe that
because he wasn't the first president to
tape from franklin roosevelt on
every president had to one extent or
another taped indeed there are 280
hours of john f kennedy tapes that have
survived and and lyndon johnson who in
fact had shown richard nixon his taping
system left over 800 hours of tapes and
until the revelation of the nixon tapes
none of those tapes were made public so
richard nixon was pretty confident that
nobody would ever get to hear the june
23rd 72 conversation
tim i'd like to ask you do you have a
theory as to why
nixon in february of 71 what was it
about that period in the nixon
presidency that led him to install this
system
hey i don't need a theory richard
we we've interviewed the people who
actually installed the system it's
amazing the reason he puts the system in
is is that he is
competing with kissinger
he's afraid that when the presidency is
over
that people will think that kissinger
was the source of his great foreign
policy ideas so he's saying i want to
prove to people that i'm the reason for
these great foreign policy breakthroughs
because remember richard in february of
1971 we're on the cusp of him
going to china announcing that he's
going to go to china we're on the cusp
of him starting dayton with the soviet
union and he's the one pushing for them
so he says to his people to haldeman and
secret service i want i want to wire
this place so that when i write my
memoirs i have the detailed proof that
it's me and not kissinger who's beyond
is behind the uh structure of peace
if you're listening to the radio it's
tim nastali's voice he's the director of
the president nixon library at yorba
linda and we need to set up this next
one richard norton smith presidential
story and it's only two minutes and 36
seconds but it's a campaign video yeah
and this is a this is a remarkable in a
couple of ways first of all is a
historical curiosity this actually this
was a film made for the 1972 republican
convention it just so happens that the
filmmakers showed up on june 23 1972
needless to say
this did not show up in the final film
but it's even more significant because
the 1972 republican convention is the
first
in a long series to be totally scripted
any spontaneity was purely orchestrated
and if if you noticed that conventions
today have turned into infomercials it
really began in 1972 with this
convention and in many ways with this
film
[Music]
the 37th president of the united states
is richard nixon
we know him best as a public figure we
seldom glimpse the president behind the
scenes
but now we shall take measure of the man
as he works
gather insight from those who know him
best
see revealed something of the man whose
vision guides the nation whose actions
affect the world
the president must be jealous of his
time
the function of his staff is to assist
the decision-making process
yesterday
what they bring to him must be pertinent
and concise ready for his decision
the president is tough-minded straight
to the point when the occasion demands
as in this discussion of revenue sharing
we don't have any assurance that if we
put federal money into that reform that
property taxes are going to go down in
the localities well then we won't accept
it
what's the matter with these clouds well
it's a question of local option you know
remember you've got a lot of water oh
right now i know that's the whole
purpose of this
the whole purpose of this is to get
property taxes down the purpose of this
is not to
increase the budgets for local officials
to continue
to raise property taxes that's what i
think and unless you put the heat on
these local officials they'll just take
the money and pour it into all their pet
projects and not get the product that's
okay not the way it's going to be we
ought to have a recruiting program at
the high school college level not just
for these symbolistic jobs we don't want
to have basically a white house mexican
a white house a negro a white house
woman and so forth that's what everybody
else has done i mean this this whole
jazz about the affected well there ought
to be a woman in the cabinet or a
mexican in the cabinet or italian in the
cabin that is
what matters is that
whoever a person is he's got to feel
whatever his background is and he's got
a chance to come into government
and is welcome because again it's for
the interests of the country minority
groups traditionally
have felt
that
in government they were limited to what
they're called basically the menial
tasks and they end up pushing the cart
or delivering mail or licking envelopes
the major incentive for individual
coming to
go to government is that he's got to
look at the top and say gee i might get
that
i and i had a chat
there's the front of the
nixon library and that was videotaped
prepared by the republican party for the
convention in 1972 right
in and around the time period of the
watergate uh break-in and tim naphtali
is there still documents to come
on watergate
well we we released some remarkable
documents this summer as part of the
agreement negotiated between the
archivists of the united states alan
weinstein
and uh john taylor of the nixon
foundation the nixon foundation deeded
to the american people the documents
that richard nixon had won through court
cases in the 1980s and early 1990s among
those were documents deemed political
which had actually been in the national
archives
facility and then were moved out to
your belinda we now have them back
they're under national archives control
and i have in front of me two remarkable
documents that we released to the public
on july 11 when this facility became a
presidential library i say remarkable
because
in the testimony before the white house
special prosecutor and also before the
senate these kinds of documents were
described as having been destroyed but
this one these survived these are the
handwritten notes of gordon strawn who
was an aide to nixon's chief of staff
h.r haldeman
the way it worked was that strong would
meet with people would write down what
they said to him the type up
report and give it to haldeman haldeman
was a master of paper flow so too was
nixon he liked things written down
well the
typed up memos were destroyed
but the uh
drafts remained and here is a document
from
april
uh april 4th of 1972
which records a meeting between
jeb
magruder who was mitchell's number two
at the committee to reelect president
nixon
and strawn and it's in this meeting
that among many things
uh strong says to
um
magruder says to strong regarding the
liddy operation
there's approval for two operations not
four
one of those operations was gemstone
which would include the break-in at the
democratic national committee
headquarters in the watergate
this is evidence
that the white house strawn works for
haldeman
was told that mitchell had approved
liddy's plan
now it does not say how much we can't
tell from this fragmentary node how much
of the operation was described to strawn
nor because of the lack of other
evidence nor do we know what strawn
exactly told haldeman but here it is the
reference to liddy is the liddy
operation which we also know as gemstone
now here is a document
from april 14th 1972
uh that documents a a discussion between
haldeman
and strawn which strawn would testify to
before the
senate watergate committee before the
senate watergate committee he said
haldeman told me to shift the political
espionage apparatus which include
breaking and entering from muskie who
had just lost the wisconsin primary to
mcgovern who'd won the wisconsin primary
and here you can see liddy switch
switch
missions from muskie to mcgovern
uh this is a this actually is what
strawn testified to but it's evidence
that for the haldeman people the
haldeman group
liddy was a known quantity his political
espionage was understood and the fact
that it had been approved was known in
the white house what richard nixon knew
we can't tell from these fragmentary
notes but this is the first time we've
had evidence quite like this richard
smith
pat buchanan
well uh i'll tell you this doesn't need
much of a setup uh pat buchanan uh who
um was one of the speechwriters one of
nixon's three chief speechwriters uh and
all was very much the uh the guy the
go-to guy for red meat for the for for
the conservatives uh i simply asked pat
buchanan how did you find out about the
watergate break-in
you got a phone call did you
it was on a saturday and i got a phone
call from ken kachigan
and he said kankachigan was ken cagan
worked with me
and he was a political guy he was on my
liaison to the committee
and he where he and i worked on memos on
political strategy and writing and he
was in the writing shop
and he called me on a saturday and his
voice was a little sick and he said they
caught
five guys in the democratic committee
last night
and i said oh no because we had been
getting
kachika and i have been getting and ken
was sending it into me materials
photographs of documents
out of musky's campaign and things
and i was surprised you get xerox stuff
all over place but this was photographs
it says where's this coming from it's
well it's a chauffeur up there and
apparently it's working for us
and i thought oh my gosh these guys have
broken in they're telling us it's just
chauffeur they've broken in
and gotten it fortunately they had not
what the story we had was true
but i knew it was our guys in a second
in a second
so caucus new jersey you're on the air
go ahead please
yes this is for mr smith
um two questions sir the first question
is
richard nixon lost the presidential
election at kennedy in 1960
and he emerges as a republican nominee
in 1968.
my question is why would the republicans
choose nixon again after he lost in 1960
and the other question i have is when
nixon
when nixon chose ford as a vice
president
did he know that he was going to resign
at that point or had an inkling he was
going to resign and thought ford was the
best candidate to succeed him as
president thank you
well those are two very good questions
let me take the second one first in fact
it's just the opposite quite frankly he
regarded jerry ford as his insurance
just as earlier he had regarded spiro
aguddu as his insurance
ford was not his first choice john
connelly the former texas governor and
secretary of the treasury was the man
that nixon would have nominated if he
could have confirmed him um so now as
for your first question as to why the
republicans nominated him in 1968 there
are a number of reasons first of all
you know he had in 1966 campaigned very
vigorously very successfully that had
been a big republican year he had piled
up a lot of ious but beyond that there
was a sense particularly as the vietnam
war ground on and the cultural
revolution of the 60s were beginning to
shift public attitudes on issues like
law and order for example
nixon was the man who managed to define
the middle of the republican party
nelson rockefeller was too far to the
left ronald reagan at that point was too
far to the right nixon actually
and he went into the primaries in 68 and
swept the primaries and so actually by
the time he got to miami he was almost
the inevitable choice vessel new york
you're on the air go ahead please hi
thank you for this great series it's
really very educational
could you clarify
wasn't this the administration that
after all the legal battles over
everything that
of what had happened in the white house
wasn't this the administration where
everything changed about what could be
archived what was the personal property
of the people leaving the white house
and what was the property of the people
and then there's a second part to my
question too do you want that now sure
okay the second part is and it relates
to the the family of the president
and i remember on larry king the two
nixon daughters were on larry king after
president nixon had passed
and they both
differed tremendously on how they felt
the library
should handle especially the
controversial matters
and
what artifacts of the families belong to
the archives and what is able to leave
the white house
mr smith can you uh
the first part of that was uh yeah in a
nutshell basically you're absolutely
right after richard nixon congress
passed something called the presidential
records act
um the presidential materials act in
event 1978
and basically
they impounded all of richard nixon's
presidential papers up until then
presidents had essentially been free to
take their papers with them
nixon was three generous a wall was
passed he in fact contested that for
many years
and eventually i believe his estate
received something like 12 or 16 million
dollars the courts basically upheld the
law but said that the estate was
entitled to remuneration
uh and maybe tim could talk more about
the relationship
with the with the with the daughters do
you know he's not with us
do you know do you know anything about
that relationship i don't i know that
there has there had been a period of um
at least some estrangement apparently
disagreement over the direction of the
library but my understanding is that
they are very much
on board with its coming into the
federal uh into the federal system for
richard norton smith we got in fairfax
virginia good evening
good evening uh two quick questions for
mr smith uh what uh if any is there
information about whether
vice president agnew objected to being
uh sort of put in charge of uh beating
up the media in the early 70s and
secondly what are the uh is there any
speculation by historians as to what is
in the 18-minute gap in the watergate
tapes thank you
well two again good question i don't
think spiro agnew put up the least bit
of resistance uh to beating up on the
media first of all i think he rather
enjoyed it secondly it made him
overnight a celebrity you know he had
been a rather obscure governor of
maryland and remember during the
campaign everyone said spiro who no one
said spiro who
after his des moines speech in 1969. in
terms of the 18 and a half minute gap
sure there's still speculation as to how
it happened it apparently involved more
than one erasure i'm not sure anyone
really believes at this point that
rosemary woods was responsible for the
for the entire gap but i also think it's
as i understand it and i have not i have
not looked at this closely my
understanding is that there are
contemporaneous haldeman notes
that others have have used in order to
reconstruct at least what we think the
conversation was about detroit michigan
go ahead please yes good evening this is
either for mr naftali or professor smith
i was wondering about the chronology
you've touched on bits and pieces of
this but the chronology of why the nixon
library remained outside of the library
system for so long why it took that
30-year period before it was constructed
and put together and if you could go
into detail of of why it remained out
for so long and if now there are any
restrictions on the materials still
well first of all it was a nomadic
institution um
from the beginning uh there was talk at
duke university where of course richard
nixon had attended law school
and i believe the faculty opposed that
they looked at a site uh
down at um
oh san clemente which had been the the
home of the the summer white house uh
and eventually they wound up i think
actually where they really should have
been all along uh next to the house you
know remember richard nixon's memoir i
was born in a house my father built and
that house stands uh next to the library
and now president mrs nixon are
interred on the grounds between them so
it seems like a very appropriate place
to be it stayed out of the system for a
very long time because like everything
else about richard nixon it was
politically controversial i think there
were some doubts quite frankly on the
part of some in the scholarly community
about the the willingness of those who
had created the library
to observe the same
impartial scholarly standards
that the national archives would require
that test has been more than met
and now you have the library inside the
system we watched early as this program
started some video that never been seen
before
it was the
six minutes before the president gave
his august 8 1974 address to the nation
resigning
very quickly
by the end of july the house has uh the
judiciary committee has adopted three
articles of impeachment simultaneously
the supreme court has ruled as we said
earlier that richard nixon has to give
up those 64 tapes
on august 1st alexander hague the white
house chief of staff hears the june 23rd
tape that we've heard tonight and he
just
concludes that the ball game's over
that becomes public on august 5th it's
very clear that the president's support
even among republicans is crumbling
his family which has displayed
incredible fortitude throughout this
tries to talk him out of resigning but
he makes the decision that he will go
and he will announce that to the
american people and uh speech from the
oval office at nine o'clock eastern time
on august 8 1974.
you're gonna
hear a couple of names ollie atkins was
the president's personal photographer in
the white house and you'll hear him
referring to him and also i think you
hear the voice of bill headline with the
time work for cbs cbs had the pool the
only cbs cameras in the oval office bill
headline went on to run the bureau of
cnn here in washington for a lot of
years let's watch
[Music]
okay is it how's that
he said is that reading like it
getting anywhere that you can see
i don't think it is i got a barn door to
open mine
okay
hey you're looking i am why don't you
stay here
blondes they say photograph better than
brunettes
not true or not
you're
you are blonde aren't you
redhead
we were same
have you got an extra camera in case the
lights go out
or who'd you look at it from it is that
an nbc
standard joke
let me see that
you get these lights properly
my eyes always have they will find it to
get
past 60 that's enough
thanks my friend ollie oh he wants to
take a lot of pictures of me
i'm afraid he'll catch me picking my
nose
he wouldn't print that with you though
audi ollie
yeah now you take a long shot but that's
enough right now
i guess i can see it
oh you want a level don't you yes yes
good evening this is the 37th time i
have spoken to you from this office
where so many decisions have been made
that shape the history of our nation
anymore
each time
i have done so to discuss with you some
matter that i believe affected the
national interest
okay
ollie
no only the cbs crew now is to be in
this room during this only the crew
no there no there will be no picture
no
after the broadcast you've taken your
picture didn't didn't you take one just
now
that's it
uh because you know we don't want it we
didn't let the the president take one so
you've taken it and you just take it
right now this is right after the
broadcast you got it
come on
okay
i'm not going to make the other
photographers mad but giving you too
many that's enough okay
all secret service there any secret
service in the room
out
you don't have to stay do you
you're required to
i just kidding
i always try to get
get a position
i'd like they'd like to move the pages
away from the microphone
well if i can
i mean
it just depends whether i
i can see him
i'll try to
you mean move them like this
would that help you
[Music]
my my straight in the back would you
mind checking my collar is it
fine i mean it's not it's not ruffled up
[Music]
good evening
this is the 37th time
i have spoken to you from this office
where so many decisions
have been made that shape the history
of this nation
richard norton smith what do you think
well you know for anyone who lived
through it and we did
i think it still has an impact akin to
what maybe the pearl harbor generation
or the kennedy assassination has tim
nathalie what do you think
again it's it's just so ironic this is a
presidency that tried so hard to be
scripted and yet we have so much of this
unguarded material whether it's tapes or
behind the scenes super eight movies or
behind the scenes video it's remarkable
it's a feast for historians and lovers
of american history
oxford union speech from 1978 richard
norton smith
four years later four years after what
you've just seen uh richard nixon is uh
making the ultimate comeback uh the the
last campaign as it were uh he'd written
his memoirs he'd done the david frost
interviews and he was
more than edging back onto the
end of the stage
he goes to europe
and very tough audience the oxford union
famous debating society and in some ways
this is emblematic it seems to me of
nixon's later years the man famously in
his own words in the arena
surrounded by a hostile audience to
begin with you can hear the the chants
of protesters outside and yet by the
time he's done uh he's won this audience
over gets a standing ovation
wars for a great power
which are big wars
are tough but
when you have the country behind you
that's leadership but
for uh wars against a little power when
a country is divided
it's difficult
uh you hear these people outside
and i uh
it's not pleasant
i mean i i'm used to it i've had to
develop a little stronger voice as a
result but i'm used to it
but i never forget you know there are
many moments that stick in your mind
this is sort of inconsequential i went
down to williamsburg colonial
williamsburg
i think it was in 1971
to to make a speech to a world law
conference on world peace and that
and a very very attractive
girl i i would guess she was 16 17.
sort of reminded me of my daughter when
she was that age my older daughter who's
blue eyed and blonde this girl was blue
and
and as i was walking in
she
she came
right up against me
walking up to me broke through the
secret service line
and just spit right in my face
she said
you murdered
well i
borrowed a handkerchief from the secret
service guy and wiped it off i went in
it's about as hard as speeches ever made
because you don't you don't want anybody
i don't mind
you know adults saying i don't agree
with you i don't mind getting a few
rocks thrown at me i've had that too
i don't mind being cartoon i may not
like it but i got a reason to fight back
but to have young people like this
to think that
somebody who has been president
uh
is one who
has not even tried to make a
contribution to their lives
then you kind of think you're a failure
but let me say this
i did fail in the political area i
failed and handling a little thing
and by failing to handle it well
that colors everything that you did
but on the other hand
i feel that when it comes to the great
goal of building a better world
that if we had not made the china
initiative if we had not made the moves
that we had to destroy the soviet union
even though it's pretty hairy and it's
going to be some tough negotiation
before it works out
i think the chances for a world of peace
will be far less than they are
and for that
i have no apology
tim naphtali we're out of time but
when you
finish what you're doing there will the
image of richard nixon change at all do
you think
i'll leave that up to other historians
my job is to make it possible to learn
everything you need to know about nixon
it's to make this a transparent and open
place for debate and discussion uh you
will get more material we have
post-presidential material that our
supervisory archivist gregory [ __ ]
has here to to show we've got 42 million
pages of presidential material in
college park that will eventually come
here to your belinda
there are releases to come for years and
1800 hours of tape with all kinds of new
treasures so
i would say don't think the nixon story
is set
expect a lot of nixon revisionism there
is
i think the term is that nixon is the
gift that keeps on giving and i can't
wait to see what americans and
foreigners interested in that era make
and do with this new type of stuff thank
you very much for to you and your staff
and the folks at college park for all
the help you've given us in getting this
evening ready and we hope the car
pleasure i'll come back and see you soon
richard norton smith we move on after
this to gerald ford what's the
connection here
well of course uh richard nixon uh
uh exercised the 25th amendment to the
constitution and
made gerald ford his vice president at
the end of 1973 uh not really believing
that
a few months later less than a year
later he would be vacating the white
house and
making way as that image suggests uh for
a most unlikely
uh president
tonight's and other
of these the whole 12 ser part series
produced executive producer producer
mark farkas and his staff thank you very
much mr parker as usual for what you do
and thanks to richard norton smith tim
naphtali and everyone else and to our
audience for joining us this evening
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
washington journal continues
we want to welcome to c-span edward
nixon and the new book the nixons of
family portrait thanks for being with us
thank you for being here why this book
and why now
those questions always come up this book
was
in my mind for a long time i brought my
brother don who was two years older than
two years younger than dick
was
pretty close to the end for his life and
he had
non-hodgkin's lymphoma
which got him a year later after he told
me this but he said eddie you've got to
write this book i'm not going to be able
to finish it
but we have to straighten out the story
get those
innuendos in place give us the right
facts
so it began
but it took a long time to get it going
let me read a couple of excerpts from
the book first of all you say that dick
was the most self-disciplined person i
have known
the most serious minded more so than
others and i think a great amount of
reading he did influence that as did the
early deaths of our brothers he accepted
responsibility in fact he sought it more
readily than most of his age
i think that's all together right on
target because he was so affected by his
older brother harold when he passed away
i was three years old when harold died
and
arthur had gone five years before i was
born
so here he was with
two brothers
and
tough times
the depression years were just about
where i began
and he really sought to find an answer
for all the things i would be asking
as i grew up there's a lot to ask about
your brother richard nixon but i want to
ask you about the period between 1961
and 1968 when he lost the presidency to
john kennedy and came back in 1968 you
quote in the book whitaker chambers
first of all who is he whitaker chambers
was the
key witness in
in the trial perjury trials that turned
out of them
alger his elder hiss and uh
that really gave the spotlight to this
young man who
really i think the only thing he could
see was
the perjury aspect
was what had to be addressed
and he's he angonized over it a long
time before he decided to pursue and
pursue he did and won the case well
whitaker chambers wrote to your brother
in february 1961 and said that i do not
believe for a moment that because you
have been cruelly checked in the
employment of what is best in you what
is most yourself that the check is final
it cannot be
you have years in which to serve service
is your life you must serve and he said
this in 1968 as he accepted his party's
nomination once again
eight years ago
i had the highest honor of accepting
your nomination for president of the
united states
tonight
i again proudly accept that nomination
for president of the united states
but i have news for you this time
there's a difference
this time we're going to win
edward nixon how did he prepare for that
moment and his win in 1968
well it was a preparation that began
many years before
and i'm not sure he was really aiming to
be the president but
later on it became quite apparent that
that was the target
and he just felt that he had a mission
to carry out
and
the most unforgettable keynote speech i
ever heard was walter judd in the 1960
convention
which
convinced all the family and all the
people i knew that this man is on the
right track
so
following uh
the thoughts he had
from that convention in the intervening
years
there was a lot of preparation
foreign travel
foreign attention of course president
eisenhower had put him around the world
on the tour that uh really opened the
eyes of
of many people who otherwise had never
known what was going on out there
our phone lines are open you can also
send us an email journal at csbn.org or
send us a comment or a question through
twitter at twitter.com cspanwj our guest
is edward nixon what kind of
relationship did you have with him
he was uh of course a brother but 17
years older he was also a mentor
and a real teacher
in fact i you know
answered at one of his questions once
when he asked what do you think is the
most important feature that a leader of
the nation should have i said well
i think he first has to be a teacher
and he was surprised at that answer i
said well i don't just meet an ordinary
teacher one that's committed
to educating his constituency
to the point of following his lead
you included an excerpt of president
nixon's speech in 1969 at his
inauguration and you refer to your
mother let me share with you what you
wrote according to what uh president
nixon said that we cannot learn from one
another until we stop shouting at one
another until we speak quietly enough
so that our words can be heard as well
as our voices
that was the way the family ran
we were quaker of course in our
upbringing
and um
that is
the one religion where
you uh
you have your own commitments
your own decisions individually
and nobody is really telling you how to
do to decide or think about issues
and the idea of listening was my
mother's
greatest trait
she was considered the
almost
mother confessor
in the store and live in the growing up
years
arguments what he wrapped in in the
grocery store and
my dad who was quite the opposite
responded
vociferously with an opinion that
was um it was his own
and occasionally
he'd say um
too loudly what his opinions were and my
mom would say frank you just have to be
quiet listen for a while people are
hearing it and you say well they need to
hear it it was the kind of relationship
that it was
did your brother enjoy people
he really did
especially younger people and those who
were
unassuming
and willing to
talk and listen with an open mind
what did he think of john kennedy they
were good friends really i really know
they had a different approach to
the political
potentials
but um even after the uh
after the election in 60
they met at key biscayne and um their
farewell address is not recorded of
course but
uh he he wrote down some of what they
thought in his book uh six crises which
was the book he wrote before he became
president
and we're looking at some of the video
the film we should point out from that
1960 debate there were four of them
did that hurt his bid
or is that uh political lore
it's a
it's a featherweight on the balance
scale but
you think about um
some of the reports that came back
following that first debate
where um
he declined to have his face dusted and
uh he was already very tired and broken
up and
the the people who watched it on
television
had one reaction those who listened to
it on the radio
at the opposite
let's get to some viewer calls first is
joe on the phone from dallas republican
line good morning with ed nixon
good morning joe it's john from dallas
go ahead
yeah you look so much like your brother
gosh
um had nixon had not been for watergate
and had he had a successful second term
do you think that he would have been one
of the greatest probably presidents
maybe since
teddy roosevelt or thomas jefferson
because i know the first term he had a
successful
first term because this trip to china
was very successful
yes that's
that's one thing that uh people have
asked repeatedly and uh
if he had succeeded in his
completing his second term he had many
missions in mind and that's what's
setting me on a course now
to try to look at those things that
weren't incomplete unfinished
and i hope i can still have some impact
talking to younger people
i was down in missouri yesterday and
spoke to a group of middle school
students and they responded very
very interestingly
i was pleased by that reaction and i
think i should probably do some more
because there are many many issues that
should be covered by
uh by his uh
in unfinished business i think he would
have been a great president in all
respects and still is in my guard
did his decision to go to china to open
up relations with that country surprise
you based on your relationship and his
ideology
not really
his um
his decision to go to china was a was a
part of his
mission
he formed many years before even in 1954
and
my grandmother was the one i remember as
being the one who encouraged us to study
the world meet the people not just the
leaders but the small people the
ordinary people that make it run
and he did that
so well all through the vice presidency
that um
it became a real plus on his on his
calendar
andrew is next from new york good
morning to you
well good morning i just have a few
comments on some things that were
accomplished during this administration
um
number one i was of draft age at that
time i was petrified of being drafted to
vietnam for a war i wasn't
backing completely
and
he ended that war successfully in terms
of
the only proper way to get out
second point is the trips to china and
making the world aware
at least a little bit of what they had
gone through through the great leap
forward
but most importantly 35 years later
we are just now reaping the benefits of
the epas and clean water and clean air
act that no one seems to understand when
we swim in beautiful oceans and we have
landfills and laws that protect us
against
environmental polluters this came from
this administration
and in my own mind it was one of the
reasons possibly why the watergate
scandal was so strong against him
because really he went against these
huge corporate corporations and forced
them to stop the polluting
and what people don't realize about
timelines
is it's 35 years later that we're
starting to see
what these laws
came about and how they helped us thank
you we got a response
well it was
it was certainly my
position in writing this to point out
the domestic policy issues that he
succeeded with
as well as the as the international and
he's
usually regarded when you get a first
opinion
a great foreign policy expert
and
that's probably true because he had
great exposure but domestic was also
very important
mark is joining us on the independent
line from san diego good morning to you
yes i wanted to ask about civil rights
because um the
picture that we have of civil rights is
that it's been something led by the
democrats and it's
back in the 1950s it was really a battle
that was led by
eisenhower
by nixon and by
the republican governor of california
um who became a
the uh supreme court uh um chief justice
uh and and um i um
was uh and the filibusters that were
being led in the senate were blocking
civil rights legislation uh that was
being pushed by eisenhower and those
filibusters were being led by johnson
and it's um and johnson's um
uh
cohort on the judiciary committee
eastland who was a segregationist and he
had put the segregationist on the
judiciary committee especially
specifically to block
and kill um
civil rights legislation so
i was just interested for somebody who
was actually there and actually is old
enough to actually have seen this
transition um from the 1950s to the
1960s
uh what he thought like when we hear
about al gore's father and he's a
democrat and everybody thought that he
the press
represented him as being pro-civil
rights when in actual fact he voted
against the 1964 civil rights act um
this transition that occurred uh from
the 50s uh to the 60s i'm just wondering
what his uh view would be on that and as
far as whether corruption in the press
misrepresenting what the republicans
were doing forced the republicans to
abandon civil rights thank you mark
well i don't think they abandoned it in
fact
at least for my brother's
perspective he was
he was the one who actually got the
schools in seven southern states with
the help of george schultz
and to open their doors by getting each
side to sit down black side white side
and get them to sit down and agree on
what's going to happen in the state with
respect to
public education
so
it's
still not finished because prejudice is
still out there but if you read the book
i think you'll see where that all came
from ability abolitionists in our family
are so abundant it's a hard to believe
anybody would say we abandon anything
in favor of um
recognizing
what i call the need to fill out a form
that asks for your race just right human
that's what we all are we're americans
yes about one of the pictures in this
book you're not in the photograph
because you weren't born yet but it's a
picture of uh your brothers donald
richard harold and arthur and richard is
uh right above uh in yorba linda
california right right don in the tire
what was your relationship like between
you and your brothers and between
president nixon and his brothers
well i think
they all respected him because he could
argue anybody out of the their position
but he was um he was one who
insisted on following the rules a
football game or whatever and a lot of
stories have propped up we've omitted
benny would
really uh
respected dick we all did
because he was really a bright bright
respondent
before he talked do you want to share
one of the stories
uh let's see
there's so many
dicks was dick was
one that
was convinced that although i had been
educated up to the
junior in high school in california
my uh
my first great picture shows the wide
variety of ethnic backgrounds
a black girl in front of me
two japanese
many mexican kids
and we went along as children do until
they're taught by elders that there's
something different
so
dick when i was about to go to college
finishing high school in west york
pennsylvania
um
i wanted to go back to caltech or
stanford maybe but they convinced me
my little trip down to duke university
in north carolina that i should really
expose myself
to um
more of the social structure in other
parts of the country and indeed it was
different
but it's um
the effect of that is it made me a much
broader
i respect a much broader field of
interests and opinions because it's
difficult
civil rights problems have gone on and
on and on and way too long except you
have to be patient to accomplish one
that big
from the book you write quote the risk
of getting burned is especially high for
political celebrities who acquire
enemies due to the nature of political
competition while some family members
may withstand the attacks many others
are devastated
it has a profound effect and i think of
mcgovern's daughter and many others who
who wind up
in difficult
un
undesired
reactions
and it really hurt
my own family there's a story that i
don't need to tell i think but it's too
long but
it really reveals the effect it had on
my daughters and um
we still
greatly admire and love
the the family
aspect but it's it's a beautiful
story about
a family that can survive all the
difficulties in the in the um
the opinions that come to us
from people who really don't know
they don't know all the answers so they
talk before they think
and um
i hope journalists will always
report facts that they know
and report all the facts if they can
find them
and then judge
that's for commentators not journalists
one of the questions from william
benjamin who is twittering saying how
would edward place his brother in the
conservative liberal column using
today's metrics
conservative
to the ultimate in some respects but not
on all issues
there are some things the main thing is
is from the
the
the training my father gave us always
referring to the simpler aspects the
more condensed aspects of
of uh
how we treat government
government should be small it should be
limited
and it is really a
it is a republic
unless we let
democracy overwhelm the ideals of the
constitution
and i'm just convinced that
dick nixon was some called him a new
dealer in fact because he did so many
things
but whether a president has a congress
behind him or not will usually determine
whether the government grows or
has holds its own
and um
that's the whole point
limited government will
succeed
and we can't print our way
out of debt
michael jones with a family question mr
nixon i live in southern indiana near
jennings county where there is a
historical marker about your mother
being born near here i know president
nixon visited jennings county once have
you ever visited there she moved from
there as a child correct correct yes i
visited several times in fact
three years ago i think
my wife and i
toured
from paducah kentucky all up the ohio
valley and stopped by in jennings county
the little town is called butlerville
and it's right across the fence from the
jefferson proving grounds in southern
indiana
the house is gone it burned down several
years ago but
that had many sentimental
memories
how did your parents meet
my dad was a single man
driving as a motorman on the pacific
electric line in whittier
um
from los angeles to whittier was a big
line back in the days when we had public
transportation to an extent
and he wanted to find
as young men will do find a suitable
partner for life
so he went to churches
where do you find a decent woman
usually in a church
at least they're taught something of
value
and he spotted
in the choir to for your friend's church
my aunt jane
milhouse beeson who
had a beautiful face and a magnificent
voice
and dad asked somebody in the
congregation who is that woman and
so that's a milhouse girl you ought to
go down to the milhouse family and meet
them there's six of them
which he did and
my mom was a little bit taller and just
a little bit older than jane
and they struck it up
it was a bit of a conflict conflict
because
my dad had a fifth grade education
and my mom was well into the studying
the classics to teach greek and latin
and
german
when he uh interrupted that and started
a family
is this the house pictured in your book
that uh the photo was taken back in 1950
but the house that is at the nixon
library that's the one at the library
where dick was born he's the only one of
us born there
and four of my brothers lived there i
never did because by the time i might
come along they'd already gone back to
whittier
next call is dan joining us from bay
meadows florida for edward nixon good
morning to you dan
good morning gentlemen
when i first heard this book was coming
out what hit bye bye big time was
oh my god this is a smart man
either he planned this or he's just got
good intuition
the fact that this book is coming out
right now right at the end of the bush
administration i'm hearing people
comparing watergate which definitely was
the fact that nixon was brought down
as a child's play compared to the bush
administration and uh you know the
torture situation and i think it's going
to make
you know the bush administration being
compared to the mexican administration
it's going to make it actually look like
a
a real good man
as far as i'm concerned because
bush was just just destroyed the
republican party and i'm part of it it
just breaks my heart we'll get a
response thank you dan
actually comparing presidencies
is something that
everyone will try to do who is better
than whom but
when you think of um
the the
positive side of any president's
administration you can put them up
pretty well
above most other people
decisions are made
in all of these
uh
administrations that sometimes come out
negatively in favor of the other side
um
as it's reported in the media you can
take it or leave it but most people will
take it as they see it
and that's the danger
i think
when you realize that
presidents former presidents
getting together are in a very
close-knit
club it's almost a rule they don't
criticize their predecessors
until maybe recently but it's a it's
well the story of my brother's funeral
in the book is uh
points it out
because doc
president clinton
greeted me at the door as i went back in
after the burial ceremony and uh
um
we started talking about this and that
began to get a little on the political
side and
president bush h.w bush took me by the
elbow and took me aside and said let's
talk navy so they defend one another
even in adverse conditions and yet at
the funeral ceremony on april 24 1994
president clinton said this quote he
knew great controversy amid defeat as
well as victory he made mistakes and
they like his accomplishments are part
of his life in record
but the enduring lesson of richard nixon
is that he never gave up being part of
the action and passion of his times may
the day of judging president nixon on
anything less than his entire life and
career come to a close
i chose that from his eulogy that he
delivered at the funeral and it's um
it's right on target i thought it was
very well put and i thanked him for that
because it was really beautifully
written and yet there's this from gary
in lesbian maryland who's saying given
that your brother was so far ahead in
the polls in 1972
why did he surround himself with people
who are willing to violate the law in an
effort to discredit his enemies
i think when you um
anybody
when enough people gang up and start
criticizing and picking on him
the
reaction can even destroy the most
self-disciplined person anywhere
and uh he was he was defensive because
he had this mission to carry out
and people were picking on this
break-in at the watergate as
as a the focus of his whole
administration which was so far off
track so many other things to do
extending the possibility for world
peace and so on which was really his
main mission
in life
um it was sad to see
the attention given to uh
an issue that um
he had no need to get involved in really
none at all one of the moments from your
brother's presidency came one year after
he was reelected winning 49 under 50
states from november of 1973
this from president nixon's news
conference
i have never profited
never profited from public service i've
earned every cent
and in all of my years of public life
i have never obstructed justice
and i think too that i could say
that in my years of public life
that i welcome this kind of examination
because people have got to know whether
or not their president is a crook
well i'm not a crook
i've earned everything i've got
[Applause]
that's the most
um quoted i think
anti-nixon quote they love it
and of course it's uh it's for amusement
of those who don't like him in the first
place
but the haters will all come around to
realize that
in the long run
this man was not a crook or anything
like it he was
in fact when he resigned he didn't
resign in disgrace he resigned in honor
of the office which is above any man as
he saw it and he had beloved the
constitution the nature of america as it
had come from 200 years before
and wanted to pursue it in that same
direction
that was that was it over this next call
we'll share with you what ed nixon
writes about watergate in the book and
will listen to becky who is joining us
from greenville michigan democrats line
good morning becky
good morning what an honor sir
it's so hard with this new way you're
doing things i got to close my eyes
i can't figure out what's going on
i just wanted to tell you that i was
raised a republican born back in
1949
and my mother and my grandmother were
staunch republicans
and
they used to debate politics all the way
to church and back every sunday
and
my mother just loved your
brother and it wasn't i was a republican
myself all the way up through i think it
was bush
1 or senior bush senior
and that's when i switched over to the
democrats i i guess
you know i i'd look at watergate now
with all
that's been going on
since
and i think of it as just being the
stupidest reason in the world
you know to to lose a good president
well i haven't agree but
i think first of all
democrat or republican keep in mind
first we're americans
you make a judgment
on
evaluating candidates
and however you come out will still mean
that you're an american
and uh if you lean this way for a while
and then lean that way for a while well
think of this my father was an
all-democrat family in southern ohio
when he was growing up
and until he met william mckinley in a
parade in columbus ohio
um
he would have been a democrat too and um
that governor who became president in
98
1898
early uh
80 96 i'm sorry
my dates will go off i'm off off channel
right now
but anyway i uh
i know that opinions change
but don't let it change you from being
just what you think you should be
figure it out yourself
study the characters carefully
and the consequences
of going one way or the other will
really tell you what's what's the best
thing that's the way we vote
we all need to be americans first then
make a decision
and support the side that does
come closest to your beliefs
president nixon talked about the highs
and lows the the peaks and valleys of
life and politics
what was the lowest day in his life the
lowest moment do you know
i think probably the um
the
the day was at august 9 1974
where he had agonized over
uh what to say
and ray price who wrote many of his um
uh drafts of speeches
can agree that uh
that was really a rough time
uh there are many i think the other one
of course was when he was only time i
ever saw him break up was at pat's
funeral
and that just got the best of him
that was a down down day
and resignation of course was
also
overwhelming
his comments from the east room of the
white house on
august the 9th 1974 as richard nixon
said farewell to his staff and talked
about his mother
nobody will ever write a book probably
about my mother
well
i guess all of you
would say this about your mother
my mother was a saint
and i think of her
two boys dying of tuberculosis
nursing four others
in order that she could take care of my
older brother for three years
in arizona
and seeing each of them die
and when they died it was like one of
her own
yes
she
will have no books written about her
but she was a saint
that was a rough day
he didn't really recover from that day
for a long time
the thing that put him through it of
course was focusing on his
his memoir which really
summarizes the whole thing is nine earth
i guess it's almost a thousand page
volume
and that began the uh
this the following books that he got he
was felt free then to to sound off on
many many
different issues and more eight more
books after that memoir was written
philip is next from durham maine good
morning to you
hey uh thanks um
i guess what i'd like to ask is a little
bit about nixon's quakerism and how that
affected his life and political
philosophy as as well affected the in
the entire family and the other thing
i've noticed about nixon is that you
have on the one side a real peacemaker
somebody who is very much committed
toward peace world peace even
and on the other side if you read some
of the transcripts and just the way he
carried out the presidency and the war
a real a real brutality for a lack of a
better word
it seems that way when you listen to his
tapes
um in the oval office tapes but i think
um you're listening to someone who
spent a lot of time in the south pacific
in world war ii
he was um
confronted many times with so many
people that hated him that he had
eventually he had to react
in an inappropriate way as my mother
would say did you hear him swear growing
up
rarely
very rarely he was
pretty well self-disciplined as i am
pointing out he just
avoided it but
when he got into a place like um who
knows
the bohemian grove in california or
places like that you let your hair down
and that's when the weakness the weak
side of the human comes out
and maybe it's therapy maybe it's
cathartic i don't know but
he did do it did he have any prejudices
against religious groups or ethnic
groups not really no
we were
often accused of that
but that's because we sometimes don't
stand up for one side or another
because quakers simply say it's yours
you decide and you're on your own and no
minister between you and god you just do
it as you best as you see best fit
harry is next from norcross georgia good
morning to you ah thank you very much
uh and i just want to thank csvan this
is i'm so pleased for this moment
uh
i i have uh so many memories of richard
nixon and my father supporting richard
nixon and of course it takes years for a
man to understand how smart his father
was
my question for mr nixon here is is
did uh
richard nixon after his long
post-presidential
life
feel satisfied that he had had
vindicated himself i feel that he did
i've always admired the man i felt that
he was
probably one of the last honorable
presidents that we've had
interesting um
i think the last face-to-face meeting i
had with dick was
after pat had died and i visited him in
um
no no no she was still there in in new
jersey
and uh that was the only occasional new
jersey yes saddleback new jersey
um
and the only time i got into it with
with what he thought about watergate and
the effect it would have and he said
well historians will
will record it and keep it alive for a
long time
but the balancing on the other side will
be a mass
understanding of what we were trying to
do
and that he thought would be
the vindication that would eventually
come
and i believe it's coming it's really
showing up now that
he had some foresight that many people
just can't reach for let me share with
you another moment in the watergate era
and this is the speech delivered a month
after your brother resigned from office
on a sunday afternoon in september of
1974 when then president gerald ford
granted a full complete and fair pardon
not fair but a full and complete pardon
to richard nixon
finally i feel that richard nixon and
his loved ones
have suffered enough and will continue
to suffer
no matter what i do
no matter what we
as a great and good nation can do
together
to make his goal of peace
come true
ed nixon that
i did watch that and um
it impressed me as being
what an american should do for a fellow
countryman
and
gerald ford knew that he wasn't doing it
for richard nixon he was doing it for
the country
why drag it through why drag it out is
too inconsequential when you think about
the better world we could make by
focusing on a free and open
review of everything
the book is called the nixons a family
portrait and our guest is edward nixon
17 years younger than the former
president the book now available at
bookstores around the country and daniel
is next from woodbridge new jersey good
morning
good morning daniel hello um
this is really a great and absolutely
great honor to be able to uh have even a
brief conversation with you
and as you probably guessed uh i am a
foreigner here i have been here since
1979
but uh i had i did study uh watergate
crisis
and i just want to ask you uh
you may have gone to so much pain and
suffering because i have my brothers you
know we have very different people
so in that sense um i really want to uh
sympathize with if that's the right word
i don't know
in any case um
i want to uh i want to go
as soon as i finish this conversation
and listening to you i want to go and
buy your book
and i hope you have made other
contributions to the united states
policy and politics and so on and so
forth
one of the things that i wanted to ask
you is uh because you are his brother
what you really did think about
the taping of the white house because in
that
the words that we have sometimes sound
crude and
difficult to listen to
particularly with regard to some ethnic
groups and so on
and let me ask you first why he had the
taping system in the first place that
was a
that was his love of history
his uh reaction to it initially was what
he would do that for
others have done it it's been done
before
and um
he thought well you know in the in the
in the future 75 years from now
we'll have
historians pouring over the recordings
and they will see
a direct view inside the oval office and
by that time vernacular manner of
speaking and so forth will be completely
different
and historians will have a direct line
into a piece of history that's recorded
unfortunately
and that could have been kept 75 years
and we'd still be waiting to hear it
but now that we've um broken through the
watergate mess
they opened up the tapes alex
butterfield
um let it be known that that's that it
existed
and
so in the interest of history he decided
to let it go
hindsight would always say
should not or have done it or perhaps i
should have done it but burned him when
i got through with it
but you're writing the book and we
showed this earlier that the watergate
era you say was a bad time for america
but the constitution did prevail the
presidency was preserved
but
didn't the nixon presidency the
watergate scandal
disillusion a generation of americans
and create skepticism that continues
today it did sure it did and um
my appeal now
i thank you for the comments there but i
i am not a politician in fact i declined
any every opportunity to run against a
local congressman because as a geologist
people tell me i have rocks in my head
but i see missions that go beyond
what the political
experts can say
energy independence things like that
that just got me off the road
and i'm just
i'm convinced that the general
population
will be affected by big news like the
resignation and the and the scandal
uh it's gone on with in the clinton
administration the same thing
many others through history
have gone through trials and think of
the teapot dome scandal in the early
twenties
um
they put a man down but the office
will stay
and that is good and i think young
people have to take heart look at the
constitution appreciate what it offers
us and what it's provided us through
these 200 years
in making the strong this country so
strong
and so much admired by other countries
they have their
immigrants coming in and
attempting to change it
that's not a good idea
don't change too much not too rapidly
anyway
in february of 1992 richard nixon
appearing on two hour book notes
interviews and in part of that interview
he talked about how people treat him and
what surprised him about that here's
part of that interview from 1992
i want to ask you are you surprised
about how people treat you today and
what i mean by that is
just take your visit here and
you can't walk outside here the camera's
waiting for you and the people surround
you they want your autograph are you
surprised after being out of the white
house since 1974 and what you went
through that people are
approaching you the way they do
well people are
the american people are
sometimes for the underdog
and maybe i'm gaining a little from that
and also the american people like
so-called celebrities celebrities uh
whether they're celebrities for good
reasons or bad reasons
and maybe i'm a ben benefit from that
uh but
i i would say
to me
what is
what means the most is when somebody
came up to me comes up to me as one did
just recently just today
said
he was a little bit older he was a
little younger than you are
and he said i just want to thank you he
said
because of what you did i got home from
vietnam
and so that makes it all worthwhile
that was two years before he passed away
yep brian lamb does such a super job and
all of c-span i'm
just glad we got it
it's um
he looked back on those
those
encounters with tabloid media people and
so forth and regretted that it
kept coming up but
he uh he was
the first i mean he when he the first
day after he was in office he began
pulling the troops out of vietnam aiming
to make it a vietnam vietnam war if it's
going to be a war
and get us out of there but nobody would
understand that or even
try to
quote him on that until it's over
so i think um
the the
the people that he met
afterward and especially after reading
the books that he's written
everyone should read those books it's a
fascinating chain of thoughts
on why we have to be
strong
and
responsive to young voters especially
they're learning they're learning how to
vote they're learning why to vote
and
he doesn't want it to be
a discouragement
laura is next she's joining us from
baltimore with edward nixon good morning
to you
um hi mr nixon i just wanted to make a
couple of comments and then ask a couple
of questions if i could
um
i i'm sorry but i i came of age during
watergate i was taking current events i
think i was in 11th grade we subscribed
to the washington post
i've i've read all the president's men
several times
and i do agree with them that that was
the tip of the iceberg and that really
did turn me off to republicans in
general and i've kind of and i felt that
way since then
and i do think
that your brother was involved i'm sorry
to say and i do think and i really
believe that it was the populist anger
a lot of people refer to america as the
second front during the vietnam war i
had a stepbrother and stepsister who
were very active
in demonstration
but having said that
my father
especially detested um your brother
and
he thought he was the worst president
that could ever be but looking back at
your brother
i'm so mystified by him because
obviously he was it's obvious he was
very intelligent but i also get the
feeling that he desperately wanted to be
liked
but wasn't especially in foreign
countries where you would hear accounts
of people throwing stones at him
and
i think really what i want to say is
i i think i was influenced a lot by my
father in thinking that he was the worst
president ever he certainly was not
that was more than that what was proved
by bush
and i think your brother
as you said
as you have indicated was to a large
degree misunderstood
well you're right there he was
not so much wanting to be liked he just
wanted his image to be respectable to
the point where he could make his points
and have them respected and uh
and judged fairly
it's difficult to get that kind of
information that you need
to make clean judgments based on real
facts and a person who has a reputation
for being a scoundrel or whatever will
not have much say
to young thinking minds
and the
respect for the person is is what's
important to the leader
he has to
get their attention and march on down
the road bringing as many as he can with
him hopefully a majority which will make
it a greater country our last call is
from kaylee in kona hawaii for edward
nixon good morning
good morning
i shared this statement with my best
friends of over 20 years after this past
the election and the statement is
the first and last time i voted was for
richard nixon
i was a 17 year old boy
1a in the draft
when along came a man saying he will get
us out of vietnam
then a few years later there was what i
thought was the worst situation a
president could do
now i know after the bush administration
nixon was mild
aloha
aloha
what is the worst president what is the
best president
moot points you'll never get it that way
you can't just compare
presidents with one another or with
anybody else for that matter to decide
who deserves credit who deserves respect
um
there's so many aspects of an individual
thinking
in terms of the nation's health
strength and longevity
and that's got to be
foremost in any young voter's mind how
do i make a good decision
and all of these
these
media that use things like all the news
that's fit to print which should really
be all the news that's bad enough to
sell
we get the wrong impression from reading
headlines
you have to read much deeper and find
the thesis of the writer before you
understand what he's trying to say
finally when he passed away in april of
1994 he suffered a stroke lingered for a
couple of days and then died
did he die a broken man or was he at
peace with himself no no i think he was
at peace with himself
um julie
noted that
as she left his room for the last time
he was he couldn't speak but he um he
gave her a thumbs up and that that
proves something to me that that's what
we all do if we're really on top of it
feeling right about it all
edward nixon the book is called the
nixon's portrait
a family portrait co-written by karen
will karen olsen karen olsen yes very
interesting story on her she was
yeah she really i should really not tell
that story it's too long for me to get
into it but she only lived about 20
minutes down the road from me where i am
in seattle
and
she was
well trained in
journalism at the university of
washington
fluid in spanish
mostly because as she says it because of
richard nixon's visit
when she was crippled and he was
visiting with his family to the world's
fair in 1962 that's where it all began
she's been my researcher very very good
writer
thank you for joining us thank you steve
good to meet you
when we come back we're going to
introduce you to our latest student cam
contest winner it is sunday morning
april 26th the washington journal
continues
[Music]
we need to teach our youngsters how to
innovate it's a teachable skill
congressman mike honda represents
silicon valley on capitol hill
and education is one of his high-tech
concerns i don't think that our
educational system should be the
scapegoat of this day
each week american history tv's american
artifacts takes viewers into archives
museums and historic sites from around
the country
next a visit to yorba linda california
and the birthplace home of president
richard nixon
docent darlene skye gave american
history tv a tour of the house that
rests on the ground of the richard nixon
presidential library and museum
the 37th president was born there in
1913 and he was laid to rest near the
house in 1994.
welcome to richard nixon's presidential
museum it really is an honor having you
here today and most fortunate to be able
to share with you where our 37th
president of the united states richard
milhous nixon was born and so if you
look behind me you can see this
wonderful house this is the birthplace
of president nixon i'm very excited and
pleased to say you tell you that the
most often yes question i get out here
has the house ever been moved and no
it's never been moved it's always been
on the spot it's actually a kit house
and please use your imagination for a
moment because let's go back to 1912 in
1912 frank and hannah nixon arrived in
this area and believe it or not there
was only 200 people
in population in yorba linda now there
is thousands but if you look around you
can see how beautiful the grounds are
here today
1912 there was plenty of lemons and
orange groves and frank and hannah nixon
arrived here and said what a great place
to raise a family so he literally frank
nixon literally went through a catalog
and it wasn't a sears robot catalog and
it wasn't a montgomery ward catalog we
still don't know the identification of
the manufacturer of this wonderful house
and
but we know that it was a kit house so
he actually took his horse and buggy and
drove it to the train station and
there's actually a section of the train
still there on imperial highway that you
can see
frank nixon brought these boxes and
crates back to this yorba linda site and
he built this wonderful house and as you
can see
as i mentioned to you it's never been
moved
now it's interesting you probably would
like the story because it's kind of cute
in 1990 when the library was being
set up president nixon was approached by
the architect and the architecture said
president nixon is it okay if we turn
the house around you know so all the all
the visitors can actually come in the
front door and they can see the
reflection pool and all the beautiful
gardens
and president nixon just looked at at
him and said you know what please leave
the house the way my dad built it
because it meant so much to him and what
an american dream as you look around to
see that this uh the milhouse nixon
family came to this area
to raise a family
so 300 orange
trees and 300 lemon trees were planted
by frank nixon but they did struggle
financially and hannah nixon would
actually walk to a packing house there
was two packing houses here in yorba
linda and to help with the income she
actually um would go pack lemons she
would walk over there and remember there
was no concrete and there was no cement
it was lots of dirt
lots of mud sometimes but you would walk
there and put in
lemons into a crate you may find it
interesting to know that president nixon
is a small child would attend the yorba
linda elementary school and he was
barefoot there's a picture in the reader
board you might may find that kind of
silly but it's cute to see that in the
reader board in front of the classmates
on the picture you'll see him
with no shoes barefoot so that's
probably how he went to school i know
you're very anxious to probably go
inside and so am i but i must share with
you that this wonderful california
pepper tree is the original tree that
frank nixon planted in 1912 and it's you
can see a little help there see what
happens when you get old you need a
little help i guess but the wire is up
there that's the original tree that the
boys
were known to the story is that they
would hang a rope with a tire underneath
and play under it and the other
original landscaping is the palm trees
so how quite
magnificent those palm trees but those
are from 1912 also
president nixon was very proud this
birth place meant so much to him because
his father built it you know the
american dream the roots of working hard
and working with the soil
he did plan his funeral when he passed
away in 1994 of april and i wanted to
share with you something quite
interesting from the funeral that he
wanted his
casket placed in front of the birthplace
and see how magnificent view that was
and that showed you how important the
birthplace was to president nixon
today
in this service
we remember with gratitude
his life
his accomplishments and we give thanks
to god
for those things he did
to make our world a better place
over 50 000 people attended his funeral
to pay their last
respects to him as you see reverend
billy graham
has given the eulogy and for those of
you who are very interested in history
and i know how magnificent this is this
is a wonderful opportunity for you to
see the first time and the only time in
the history of our country that five
presidents and five first ladies
attended president nixon's funeral
president reagan in this photo got sick
just directly after that so that was the
last time they were together
and you can recognize president clinton
president bush senior
president reagan president carter
president ford and their lovely lovely
first ladies speaking of first ladies we
have a gardens here of first ladies
gardens many people come here just to
visit the gardens
and
every first lady has a rose named after
her and i'm proud to say that pat nixon
has a lovely rose so many of you who are
interested in gardens to please come
here what a great place to stress reduce
and relax just by the gardens because
pat nixon has a beautiful rose come and
see it it's a deep red rose and quite
beautiful but we have the lincoln rose
magnificent gardens so i do hope
you come to see the gardens we will go
inside now because i know you're just
very thrilled to see the birthplace of
president nixon
president nixon mentions in his um audio
that when he lived here he would hear
the train whistle all the time and he
would dream of being a train engineer
because of it
welcome to president nixon's birthplace
i hope you can smell history because
when i tell my visitors that visit the
library please smell history because the
majority of the furniture is original in
this house
clara nixon the sister-in-law of
president nixon is still alive she's 91
years old and i got to see her the other
day and she's just sprite and a
beautiful lady still at 91 and she
shared with me the fact that i said to
clara how did you get to save all the
furniture and she said to me darlene i
was just lucky and i and i she said
that when president nixon's mother
passed away just before he was elected
she put all the stuff in storage and
what a treasure we have today it's so
exciting so the majority of the
furniture is original please use your
imagination for a moment can you hear a
baby cry
true story
a bouncing baby boy by the name of
richard milhouse nixon was born in this
bedroom and that original bed isn't that
exciting as a matter of fact the doctor
that delivered president nixon january 9
1913 said it was the most
loudest cry he ever heard of all the
babies that he delivered and he put the
uh baby in wrapped them up in a blanket
and put them in a basket to keep them
warm because the reason hannah nixon
you know she had five sons there was
five nixon boys the reason nick's
mrs nixon mrs hannah nixon gave birth to
richard milhouse nixon in this room and
in that bed is because it was so cold
that day i know it sounds silly i'm
originally from chicago and i know what
cold is but hannah nixon said that was
one of the coldest days of the year here
in california so she gave birth to that
baby in here
interesting to know please look at the
wonderful blankets the quilts the
friendship quilt and the blanket look
1837 ohio isn't that amazing to know
that these are the original blankets
that were given to hannah nixon
for her wedding day when she met frank
nixon within three months they got
married look at the special frames that
are made on those two pictures those
frames were made by hand by richard
nixon when he was a small boy and he
surprised his mother and gave it to
hannah nixon as a gift
please notice the title of one on the
left says mother's boys it's a beautiful
poem and hannah nixon cherished it
because she had five sons directly to
the right of that frame see a lovely
picture of the four boys it's a great
picture to see because you i will
explain to you um all the four boys that
were born in here but the fifth boy was
born later in 1930 he never lived in
this house so but please direct your
attention now to the dresser the dresser
was made by hand by richard nixon's
uncle and the wonderful photograph how
wonderful it is to have a photograph of
sarah and say sam wadsworth nixon the
paternal grandparents of richard nixon
to the right of that is the bible that
bible belongs to the firstborn harold
nixon one of a treasures there's many
treasures but please notice the fan this
fan was the graduation of
hannah nixon when she graduated in
school from school in
1906. as we walk across here a little
bit and don't laugh when you hear the i
don't know if you notice the the floor
it's almost 100 years old you can hear
it squeak
so um i always think the floor is
talking to me that's the original floor
that was built in 1912
wonderful exciting take a moment and
treasure that high chair that high chair
had all five nicks and boys in that high
chair
if it could speak what a story it would
tell
in fact one of my favorite stories from
ed nixon because he's still alive and
he's in the 80s and he's very kind to
have some conversations with me in fact
he wrote a book the book that he wrote
is called nixon's and it's a great book
to give you more history about the
family but he mentioned to me a great
story aha when he was little how he
would be put in that high chair and it
would sometimes pinch his fingers
because the boys his older brothers
would put them in and they were in a
hurry so it was a cute little story of
that high chair one of my favorites is
the table and the chairs here it's a
true story in richard nixon's memoirs
he mentions how he got the joy of debate
this is the original tear uh table and
the chairs and richard nixon has a small
boy would sit here and his father frank
nixon would debate with him and say oh
richard what do you think about this or
how do you think of the days of of
what's going on in in the history
and guess what richard nixon they debate
back and forth and he said
i got it that's what i want to be when i
grow up it happened here in your belinda
at this table in these chairs
now if you look around and i know you've
been looking you can see all the
computers richard nixon had the
telephones the televisions the radios he
had
i'm just kidding i'm just joking because
you know what he didn't have any of
those things he didn't have a television
he didn't have radio what did he do at
this time well i will show to you as i
indicate over here something quite
magnificent maybe many of us don't see
this enough nowadays do we a treasure of
books president nixon as a small child
would read a lot in fact it was very
known that his grandmother elmira would
give him a gift and the other boys also
for any holidays or birthdays
books to read
instead of toys sometimes an apple or an
orange but a book and that was
considered a treasure for richard nixon
as growing up his favorite author was
leo tolstoy that was his favorite author
a fun little photograph just above the
books i need to point out to you because
it's such a treasure
richard and pat nixon had a lovely
family of two daughters and they have
four beautiful grandchildren but you can
see a nice picture of julie and trisha
nixon when they were quite young
and uh it's a picture of the
grandparents so you can see frank and
hannah nixon the grandparents there in a
beautiful poem by julie nixon on the
left and i think she even got an a on
that one so it's entitled beauty so it's
a great little story to show you um the
wonderful family of the nixons and also
the fact that they were very well read
and all one of the exciting things i'd
like to share with you is the fireplace
now to supplement the income frank nixon
did they did struggle a little bit
financially but this is a handmade
fireplace and the our lovely curator
here at the library actually told me one
day and said darlene you know what i can
drive around your belinda some of the
older homes and pick out the chimneys
isn't that neat you go oh that's that's
a frank nixon chimney so it's pretty
neat to have that with us today
and above the mantle there you can see a
wonderful wedding photograph of frank
and hannah nixon when they uh got
married in 1908 i always think what a
beautiful wedding dress she had and she
had that fans she has a fan in her left
hand how beautiful the um wonderful
clock in the middle is the original
clock believe it or not 1908 that was
given to frank and hannah nixon as a
wedding present from frank nixon's
parents and to the left a wonderful
photograph i think it's such a kick to
know that hannah nixon that's a pretty
picture of hannah nixon in the back but
she had five sisters and one brother
growing up and then guess what god
blessed her with five nixon boys here i
always think that is quite interesting
so this is a great photograph if you
take a moment to look all of the nixon
boys were named after english kings
except the one in the center he was
named after his father francis donald in
fact he's the one that married clara
nixon later in life and this sprite
young person at 91 that
has such a a treasure of information for
us at all times but the first born here
is harold nixon harold nixon was 23
years old and suffered a long time from
tuberculosis as a matter of fact hannah
nixon did for several years take her son
to arizona and she even helped three
other young men who had tuberculosis and
struggled so so so many years to to keep
him alive and what a tragedy in the
family harold nixon did pass away when
he was 23 years of age next in line i'm
sure you can guess this wonderful
picture this is our future 37th
president richard milhous nixon and over
here in the sailor outfit over there is
arthur nixon arthur nixon i'm sorry to
say uh passed when he was seven years
old he woke up one day with a headache
and he goes oh mom he goes i don't feel
good and so within several days with a
tragedy in the family so um many people
don't know that richard milhouse nixon
did lose two brothers at a very early
age and many people say perhaps that's
what gave him the drive and the ambition
to do something with his life last but
not least i'm very happy to say that ed
nixon is still alive as i told you
because he's the author of the book the
nixons and he was born in 1930 so he
never lived here but such great stories
he can tell you about
when richard nixon did ask him to take
him
a cross-country ride in the car and he
was able to drive the car and one of the
favorite things i kind of like nixon
shared with me is he said to me darlene
one of our favorite foods that dad would
make for us was beef stew the best beef
stew ever that was so succulent with
vegetables that the beef would just melt
in your mouth he said the best speaking
of food hannah nixon was a wonderful
baker wonderful cook and i will tell you
more about that when we go into the
kitchen but i want to mention to you
about this wonderful magazine now how
many of you read this magazine it's a
great magazine because at that time the
national geographic magazine was a great
way to open up the world to so many
people and as you know president nixon
wanted to be remembered as a peacemaker
well he traveled to all continents
except antarctica and he was the most
well-traveled statesman for the history
of our country for that time so many
people say perhaps that was from the
national geographic because we didn't
have the internet done did we
wow i'm very excited and happy to share
with you that these instruments
president nixon as a small child played
five instruments he played the saxophone
the clarinet the piano the accordion and
the violin
i always say hi i play the radio i don't
know if that counts but it just kind of
gives you the impression of what a great
musician that president nixon was and
just a little reminder of history
president nixon played the piano in the
east room of the white house for duke
ellington and when he played the piano
it was happy birthday to duke
ellington's the violin is the original
violin also and when you take a close
look at that violin how beautiful it was
and clara nixon told me how she had it
restrung because it was so well worn
president nixon is a small child did
live a few months with his
uncle
griffith milhouse who gave him violin
lessons and also gave him piano lessons
so what a great musician he was and uh
he sometimes joked that he liked music
so much that if there was a good rap
of music then he maybe would have been a
a rap artist so that would have been fun
and interesting the religion of the
nixon family was quakers i don't know
too much about the quaker religion but
it's very interesting now president
nixon shares in his memoirs that when
hannah nixon his mother would go off to
sew
and there's the sewing room off there
that that's where she would pray so it's
very interesting to know
the privacy of the family and the
richness of all the treasures here and
little did they know that their son
would grow up to be the 37th president
so thank you and we're now going to go
our head our way into the kitchen except
i have a little fun thing to share with
you because many times when i give tours
people will ask me they'll say gee how
come hannah and frank did not have a
curtain or you know a door on the
bedroom in those days it was the only
source of heat the fireplace that i was
telling you about so if they put a door
up here they wouldn't be able to get
heat
however for privacy's sake a rod would
put up and maybe a sheet hanging here
but this was usually open now the boys
they slept upstairs so you can see the
vents up there
on the ceiling and that was their source
of heat from the fireplace isn't that
fun
so boy how they got along you know in
our days of microwave ovens and all the
fancy kitchen utensils they had hannah
nixon and frank nixon raised four boys
here richard nixon was about 10 years
old when they did go to whittier
and they opened up a gas station and a
market there and it only was because
they kind of struggled financially but
they did really well there so we will
walk into the kitchen
please imagine hannah nixon cooking for
her four sons and her husband in this
little quaint little kitchen now the
stove and the ice box are not original
but it's something similar to what
hannah nixon would have cooked on but i
bet you don't know why this number is in
the window believe it or not hannah
nixon would put safe for today
20 pounds of ice a truck would pull up
and the truck driver would know she
wants 20 pounds of ice he would take the
tongs come up to the side here put it in
this wonderful ice box and when the ice
would melt
it would be down here and the tray would
open and it would be full of water and
that was one of richard nixon's chore is
to actually water the plants on the side
here by the door left and right
to see i have to show you what a
beautiful view to it is out this way
when you can see the beautiful gardens
which i encourage everyone to to see
it's so stress reducing and relaxing
just the aroma if you notice the
reflection pole the reflection pole is a
reproduction from at washington dc so it
reflects the birthplace on one side and
the lobby on the other side of the
museum very beautiful this is hannah
nixon's utensils the pan and the grater
and the colander these are all her
her cooking utensils and baker and she
was a very good baker richard nixon as
president wrote in his memoirs he said
one of my favorite was the angel food
cake my mother hannah nixon in this
house so use your imagination she would
take this batter and it was really
important to her and this may be a
little hint for those
cooks out there she'd open the door
walk outside
and whip up this batter and she always
believed this fresh air of the batter
actually made the angel food cake
delicious and ed nixon said to me too
the other day which was cute he said my
mother hannah nixon she made the best
pie such great crust the best crust in
the in the world it was always very thin
and very crispy in fact it was one of
the biggest sellers when they did move
to whittier because in the market she
would make the pies and everything that
was one of the favorites the pies over
here is a cookbook interesting you may
find the presidential white house
cookbook hannah nixon actually had a
cookbook from the white house
that
she loved to use and interestingly
enough did she know that her son maybe
it was from her cooking he became the
37th president of the united states very
interesting now i know you're all going
to get a great
laugh about the pantry because there's a
bathtub in there
that bathtub is a favorite of all the
guests and visitors that come from
throughout the world and i think what's
so neat visitors from around the world
come here and they visit and they
connect so much with this birthplace
because no matter where you live
somebody will say that's the bathtub i
remember that when i was growing up well
the story goes
the cleanest boy would go in first the
dirtiest last so how silly that is and
boy wouldn't you want to stay clean to
be the first one in the bathtub sounds
like a good plan to me
the story also goes in the house in a
cute story about when hannah nixon would
bake or cook and the boys or the family
would be sitting maybe the table would
be directly beyond that window
many people believe it's for the breeze
but sometimes she would pass some
platters of food through the window it
just made it easier instead of having to
go back and forth and it's such a
beautiful and that's the original um
window there as you walk over here what
i think is so outstanding now visitors
are not allowed to go upstairs on this
kit house and it's so quaint it's so
full of love like i told you even though
president nixon would say
even though they lived poor the glory of
it is that they never really knew
because there was so much love and the
american dream of the hard work and and
and just aspiring to always to do their
best and that's what happened in this
house even though they didn't have so
many things i love this entrance way
going upstairs notice it's 22 inches
wide quite narrow so that's why the fire
department doesn't let us go up there
because it could be dangerous but those
boys
two boys to each bed up there but
upstairs in the bedroom president nixon
will share in his memoirs
that he would
get together with his brothers up there
have some pillow fights and they got
along pretty swell up there but he would
hear the train whistle up there and he
dream of being a train engineer so
interestingly enough the concept of
railroads and trains were such a big
part of president nixon's life the
memorial gardens interestingly enough
are just steps away
from his birthplace the memorial gardens
have the gravesites of president
nixon and his lovely wife patricia ryan
nixon president nixon passed away in
1994
and his wife a year earlier in 1993.
she passed from
cancer and he passed away from a result
of a stroke
we usually take a moment of silence here
many people ask me about the memorial
gardens of president nixon and pat nixon
please notice the epitaph the patniks
and the beautiful butterfly that just
landed on the tombstone is an indication
to me of how beautiful the gardens are
here to remind you to come here but so
peaceful patricia ryan nixon
our first lady was a great ambassador
she traveled to
78 countries on her own and one most
horrific one on the presidential
helicopter to peru she was such a
peacemaker in her own right but she
wanted everyone to know that even when
people can't speak your language they
can tell if you have love in your heart
and please notice the epithet of
president nixon his um
entitled the greatest honor history can
bestow is the title of peacemaker and
the most important thing for him to be
remembered at as or he wanted to be
remembered as as a peacemaker
i've been here 13 years and it's amazing
to me that we have people from so far
away they can go anywhere they can go to
yosemite they can go to grand canyon
where do they come to president nixon's
museum and they have this connection
it's like amazing i
what i you know most of the docents here
will attest to that that people find it
a very warm friendly beautiful place and
i was born and raised chicago and
president nixon i have to tell you right
off the bat the the thing that i can
remember immensely is how he made me
feel safe as a teenager
my father was a chicago police officer
so the fact that uh in chicago in the
late 50s early 60s it was really a tough
time so i remember sitting on the floor
with a black and white tv and just
seeing president nixon's voice coming
across you know he
gave the message of of keeping america
safe and
now that i moved to california it was
just a blessing in disguise that i could
be part of such a historical moment of
of being here at president nixon's
museum it's truly an honor and i
appreciate the opportunity to share this
with the viewers and
i hope through this message that they
know that the 37th president the united
states of america has a magnificent
museum there can be a connection to
anybody who comes to visit because
president nixon was so global
before the internet
you can watch american artifacts and
other american history tv programs
anytime by visiting our website
cspan.org history
the eisenhower national memorial is
planned for a four acre site at the base
of capitol hill in washington dc visit
our website cspan.org history
the richard nixon presidential library
convened a symposium titled
understanding richard nixon and his era
this program is the first panel
discussion from that conference and
addresses the former president's life
story from his parents political views
to the writing of his memoirs
this is about one hour and fifteen
minutes
good morning everyone
uh it's great to see everyone here at
the first scholarly conference it's
great to see the library buzzing with
scholarly conversation and activity and
we are the first conversation
and i'm going to make introductions for
all four of these gentlemen they're all
going to speak for about five to seven
minutes raising some of the big
questions um and research areas that
have yet to be explored
and then we're going to open it for
audience conversation because we really
want to invite you into this discussion
so let me start with the introductions
up first will be joe domikowski my
colleague at whittier college
joe was an associate professor and
serials librarian with special expertise
in nixon materials at whittier college's
wardman library his most recent article
under the table michael wilson in the
screenplay for the bridge on the river
kwai which appeared in the spring 2009
issue of sinaste focused on the politics
of the hollywood blacklist
our second speaker is going to be
anthony rama matavias he earned his
master's degree and phd at the
university of illinois at chicago under
under the direction of richard freed
after completing his graduate work
professor maravias has taught at various
universities and colleges in chicago
he's now at the college of dupage
and he has researched and written about
the career of richard nixon
concentrating on his career in congress
his dissertation topic was nixon in the
50s
our next speaker will be irv gilman
irv has written three monographs on the
presidency of franklin d roosevelt
roosevelt and batista published in 1973
good neighbor diplomacy published in
1979 and secret affairs franklin
roosevelt cordell hull and sumner wells
published in 95
since 1995 he's embarked on a
multi-volume biography of the life and
times of richard nixon the first volume
in the series is the contender richard
nixon the congress years published in
1999. he's currently finishing the
second volume tentatively titled the
apprenticeship richard nixon the vice
presidential years
1952-1961 and he expects it to be
published this year
our final speaker will be perspective
from someone within the nixon
administration frank gannon
and uh frank received his doctor of
philosophy from oxford university he won
a white house fellowship and served in
the nixon white house from 1971 through
1974. he accompanied president nixon to
san clemente aboard air force one on
august 9th and he organized the
researching and writing of the
president's memoirs
so i'll turn it over first to joe
all right good morning everybody
uh first of all i'd like to thank the
nixon library and the staff for all
their hospitality and welcoming the
the group today
also i want to acknowledge
mel small the editor of the wily
blackwell companion to richard nixon
project and which i think was a uh
of work turned out very nicely
my task for the project was to assess
the biographical coverage of richard
nixon's pre-political years from 1913 to
1945.
i focused on the accuracy and
reliability of the work and looked to
see if bias was apparent with the author
in the early works errors were often
prevalent
statements or direct quotes were
unattributed
regularly
my chapter was organized chronologically
i reviewed 23 works with publication
dates spanning from 1952
to 2009 for the companion
and so i'm looking at trends in uh
biographical coverage of richard nixon
the first full-length biography of nixon
was called fighting quaker by c richard
gardner which he wrote in 1952
gardner was a former nixon publicist and
a white year college honors graduate the
book was never published
the only available copies are at
whittier college special collections
richard nixon cooperated with gardner
and author also interviewed members of
nixon's family so there were significant
topics covered for the first time
this included frank and hannah nixon's
personal biography and family background
the tragic death of two brothers arthur
who died in 1925 at age seven and harold
who died in 1933 at age 23.
gardner also discussed the religious
background the quaker heritage of the
nixon family
and explored nixon's wartime experience
in the united states navy
fighting quaker was a useful resource
for a number of future nixon biographers
so during the vice presidential years
richard nixon received surprisingly
favorable coverage
he was friends with a number of
journalists and then allowed interviews
access to his office
and files that helped the biographers uh
just pointing out one earl meso who
wrote richard nixon a political and
personal portrait came out in 1959 and
there's new information
about nixon's active duty in the south
pacific and it's where mazel claimed
that poker winnings financed the first
congressional race in 1946
i also like to point out richard nixon's
memoirs came out in 1978 and this is
important work
released four years after his
resignation
served as an instrumental step towards
his rehabilitation
only 27 pages out of 1120
were dedicated to the early years and so
this is still an essential starting
point for biographers
in the early 1980s we had academics came
into the picture professional historians
now provided access to extensive
citations notes lists of references and
bibliography
their research was scattered over a wide
variety of sites
they used primary sources such as
manuscript collections
from presidential libraries national
archives including the main
main branch and the regional branches
such as the vice presidential papers
that were formerly in laguna niguel
library of congress and special
collection depositories at colleges and
universities
i'd like to focus on julie nixon
eisenhower's 1986 work called pat nixon
the untold story the biography of her
mother
she had unique access to diaries and
correspondence not available to other
biographers and of course access to her
parents which gave her a special
place as a biographer
she presented outstanding coverage of
her parents courtship
and then
in 1945 she detailed the story of how
whittier banker uh herman perry
contacted the nixons while they were in
baltimore and that's september 1945 and
asked if richard was interested in
running against incumbent representative
jerry voorhees
and truly verified that her parents
savings which was ten thousand dollars
all went into the congressional race
and they had planned to use that money
for a house and it was in war bonds
i'd like to talk about a uh one
biography by roger morris called richard
milhouse nixon which presents a problem
i think for a lot of scholars and
students
morris was an ivy league educated
journalist and historian he resigned in
protest from the national security
council in april 1970 after the
cambodian incursion
he showed a strong underlying bias
against nixon
at the same time he's actually a very uh
methodical researcher so you have to
kind of weigh
uh kind of proceed with caution
these types of uh coverage and just to
focus on the lingard and beauty law firm
days when nixon was uh working as a
lawyer in whittier
his first case was uh
morris portrays that has been mishandled
by nixon where he represented marie she
and there's also the citra frost is the
company that richard nixon is first and
last business venture it was the
president of the company it went it went
down it was frozen orange juice and they
ran into some technical problems
in 1993 jonathan aitken wrote nixon
alive a very favorable work akin is a
british politician an associate of
richard nixon since the mid 60s
it's not an authorized biography
but he had 60 hours of interviews with
richard nixon so gave him unprecedented
accents and there's some things here
that i found very useful uh for instance
and when 1926
freshman year of high school for richard
nixon at fullerton
he was on the football team and they
took an x-ray and he had like a spot on
the x-ray so tb ran in that family
and because of this they took him out of
any strenuous activity and contact
sports for the rest of his high school
days that's the only place i'd heard
about that
uh ola welsh was richard nixon's
girlfriend
uh he knew her with your high school but
they went to get dated during the
college years
jonathan aitken had access to both her
material with her interviews with her
and interviews with richard nixon so he
got both sides of the story which i
think was very useful
and then last i'm looking at
another family biography this is ed
nixon's and karen olson's the nixon's
family portrait
and he described the story this was
before he was born of course but frank
nixon's
building the
birthplace home that we might have right
here on the grounds
no sewer no electricity no gas lines
they had to pump water from a well
hannah cooked with a distillate stove
using white gas
they had what he called a california
cooler which i believe is just a screen
out in the shaded area
that for the produce and then in the
early days
the workers harvested ice from lake
arrowhead or big bear lake i found it
quite fascinating
ed told the story of how he went drove
back with his family for richard's
graduation from duke law school
at age seven that was 1937 traveling
with amyra
and she was then 87.
ed joined richard in 1939 for a train
trip to michigan to pick up a new car
this is something that frank nixon also
was in the habit of doing
and richard brought a brand new
oldsmobile drove at home so this was a
wonderful bonding opportunity for the
two brothers
so in conclusion
richard nixon attracted loyal partisans
garnering more individual votes as a
candidate in national elections than any
other american politician
conversely he repelled a legion of
detractors
nixon's biographers often split into
opposing camps as well offering highly
subjective perspectives
objectivity has not been a prevailing
characteristic regarding nixon's
biographical coverage
for the most part and this is certainly
manifested in the nature of the
materials reviewed in my chapter
covering the pre-political years
okay thank you very much
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
i've got news for you richard nixon was
no new dealer
having studied the congressional and the
vice presidential uh periods of richard
nixon's political career
a question crossed my mind
or a thought crossed my mind it does
happen once in a while
what are the true roots of nixon's or at
least the young richard nixon's
political ideology
i've got a few ideas
one
it was the new deal era
that roughly eight year period between
1933 and 1941 which encompasses the
great depression
uh the new deal
and the beginning of the second world
war
this period
formed a crucible
upon which richard nixon's jack
armstrong all-american persona we see
that as a young man certainly
you know full of
a belief in sturdy self-reliance and pep
was tested and challenged by
well a few things
the mass deprivation and general
suffering that one saw during the great
depression that that was no picnic
certainly
the uh
relatively radical efforts by the new
deal agencies to
um
intervene some would argue in the lives
of the individual citizens
and finally the polarization
of much of the citizenry in response to
the new deal in general
okay
second
the company you keep
richard nixon the young richard nixon's
association with various political
mentors advisors handlers
fundraisers donors and supporters
help further this
what i call
quote the conservative education of
richard nixon
you look at his influences like any good
musician
anyone ask me who are my influences i'll
say well the carpenters barry manilow
want to feel like telling the truth
his his maternal grandmother
almira milhouse
was known as a lifelong republican maybe
his own parents but nixon himself said
in his memoirs in 1978 frank nixon
disdained stan pat republicans like
harding and coolidge in fact
frank nixon may have voted for fdr back
in 32 and 36.
big news uh hannah nixon herself
according to
melvin small voted for woodrow wilson in
1912
probably at least in 1916.
maybe his recreational reading he read
in addition to the la times as a young
man
good housekeeping the saturday evening
post
both of which may have praised uh
1920s america hoover's america to some
degree
uh
some of the members of his committee of
100 who helped push his 1946 and 1948
campaigns
frank jorgensen
he said
i didn't trust fdr i distrusted him
a lot of us felt that he had been soft
on communism i think he was befuddled a
lot of the time and fooled by stalin
john francis nylon he was a big
fundraiser in the san francisco bay area
for richard nixon in many of the
elections between 1952 and 1968.
he told
his own
employer william randolph hearst
that governor fdr who he met who he had
met in
late 32 or early 1933 did not understand
the fundamentals of the national economy
or the u.s stock market
quote
when the two of us got to economics
he seemed to think that all
industry consisted of stock market
operations
end quote
earl c adams
a san marino lawyer a local guy he
helped fund the
1950 run
quote the new deal
the fair deal the new frontier all
that's just hogwash
it's a lot of rhetoric
builds up
a
pie in the sky for people people get up
their hopes and ambitions
and i mean their goals never get met
so these are some of the people that
that nixon surrounded himself with in
this phase of his career who stephen
ambrose calls
uh at least uh in terms of the committee
of 100
rotarians
lawyers realtors insurance men auto
dealers here in the old 12th district
south pasadena el monte
whittier
by 1938 richard nixon had registered as
a republican
up to that time melvin small claims
nixon was a non-ideological centrist
in 1936
or in retrospect richard nixon's one of
nixon richard nixon's roommates from the
period 1936 and on at the end of his law
school career duke claimed nixon
believed that the individual should push
back against big government big society
and big business
and amer and an american could never be
free if he or she
abdicated his or her personal
responsibilities to someone else
so
finally
nixon did pledge in a letter to herman
perry his first political mentor
a letter dated 6 october 1945
to practice quote practical
liberalism as opposed to quote that
particular brand of new deal liberalism
pushed by nixon's opponent jerry
voorhees in the 1946 campaign
well this is a topic that i believe
deserves further research
and it's something i will work on
but something i wanted to share with you
folks today
what are the true roots of richard
nixon's conservative political views of
this period those folks who believe in
small government
low taxation and no state intervention
in a free market economy
it's something that needs to be worked
upon
thank you very much
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen normally i'm a
little irreverent and i'm standing here
just so she can't get the hook on me but
i'm sure she'll grab me
i shall find a way but i i'd like to be
serious to start with and say
without mel small this conference would
have never happened he has his hand over
his head
and we all owe him a thank you
and and what he's done
knowingly or unknowingly by bringing the
archivist of the united states and
having some of you that i've talked to
that are on the program i mean it's just
been a pleasure
just in a day what i've learned
from dean kotlowski in civil rights
having a chat with
keith olsen and other of you folks here
has really been an honor for me and to
be on the platform with these four
people is is really my honor and
hopefully the nixon library will keep
this kind of tone to have serious
symposiums on nixon and his life and
times
and in my spare time i spent
a lot of time here
and sitting right in front of me who
helped me and did a mammoth job on the
richard nixon
campaign is beverly lindley and she was
just a sweetheart
the other young lady who i've asked to
run away with me louis gaunt has been
working for for nixon
for since 1951
since 1951 and then finally sitting in
between the two musketeers is susan
nolte the third musketeer who did more
work for me
pulling papers getting documents helping
me out
far smarter than i ever hoped to be you
know and susan i really do appreciate it
you've been superb
finally in back the guy with a large
part with a beard is greg [ __ ] and he
has gotten pulled records for me and
been helpful for me
lastly i'd like to thank uh tim naphtali
sandy quinn
and
all of the rest of the people that have
worked on this project together what
you've done has been beyond the call of
duty and and i praise you highly
now now my work on the volume i'm
finishing now and yale university
presses just allowed me to say that they
are publishing my volume
uh
is that
the whole story of richard nixon's vice
presidency and his relationship with
dwight eisenhower has been told with the
basis
that they didn't like one another they
detested one another they hated one
another as stephen ambrose said they had
an ambivalent relationship
none of those are true
i've looked at about three million pages
of documents thanks to susan
helping me and others helping me and
basically what you find out is that
richard nixon and dwight eisenhower
had an a-minus relationship
they got along fine together they not
only got along fine together
that dwight eisenhower used richard
nixon in a superb way
eisenhower never ever
got nailed he never got criticized for
the things that he told other people to
do
whether it was massive retaliation or
brinkmanship by john foster dulles
whether it was sending troops into
vietnam allegedly by richard nixon
whether it was farming affairs by ezra
taft benson
all of this stuff
never stuck to to dwight eisenhower it
always went to somebody else
and i spent you know several two to not
enough minutes
talking to dean kotlowski about civil
rights
now just a taste for you all
i started out with three paragraphs on
richard nixon and civil rights i now
have three chapters when richard nixon
and civil rights he was the lead
person in public affairs
under dwight eisenhower pushing
desegregation
pushing equal job opportunity
he was
next to
lyndon johnson in 1957
bringing republican senators on board
for the civil rights act of 1957
the story about lbj
and richard nixon not getting along i
have their letters they got along fine
they worked well together
richard nixon taking all of these
goodwill missions abroad
to get him out of town so he won't be
around
every time with one exception
when richard nixon goes around abroad
the first person that sees him before he
leaves to brief them is dwight
eisenhower in the white house
the first person that richard nixon sees
when he comes back is dwight eisenhower
in the white house
so the whole nature
of how richard nixon is viewed and how
he operates under the presidency of
dwight eisenhower in many ways he
becomes a sponge
where he absorbs what dwight eisenhower
once done how it fits into his life and
times and how richard nixon moves
forward in his political career
was he conservative sometimes was he a
liberal oh such a terrible word
sometimes was he a moderate sometimes it
really depended what the issue was
nixon i know this is going to surprise
you was a terribly complex individual
dwight eisenhower
was equally if not more so the man was
absolutely brilliant in how he
bureaucratically managed his government
so the nature of this
incredible relationship
and how nixon rises to power as a
foreign policy president how he becomes
fascinated with civil rights how he
works towards that
how you know uh black americans move
into the democratic party
irrespective of what the gop does
all of these are stories that have been
voided or vacuumed or whatever during
the period of the 1950s so i hope that
you enjoy the rest of the seminar i hope
that you enjoy meeting my colleagues as
i've enjoyed meeting them and i really
hope mel doesn't have his hand in front
of his face that he does accept my
appreciation for mel a job really well
done
thank you
[Applause]
one
i am a sheep in wolf's clothing although
as you can see i didn't even get the uh
the dress code memo
uh
i in true nixonian style i had prepared
and i had prepared it sufficiently so
that it would appear to be spontaneous
talk about nixon's early life and i only
was informed on arrival that i was to
comment on the
um
on the previous speakers and this would
be like
barry manilow commenting on beethoven
so at best i have a
a smattering of ignorance on these
things i did work with the president on
organizing the researching and writing
of his memoirs from 74 to
78 and then i worked
with him again in 1983 on doing
producing and conducting 30 uh about 38
hours of interviews which were to be a
video biography based on his uh based on
the memoirs
but that was a long time ago and so i'm
not i'm not
really an expert in um as you're about
to see
in 83 in those interviews uh
the president told me two things that uh
that i think are relevant to today's uh
panel one is that he didn't much didn't
have much uh wasn't much interested in
psycho historians because all
psycho-historians are psychos
and
so
the
i apropo joe's remarks excellent remarks
oh and before i go on i i should say
thanks certainly to mel small for
writing this uh or or collecting and
editing this uh this important book
and to the library and the miller center
and to the archives for uh making all
this uh
possible uh
joe's comments the the 27 pages of the
11 20 were devoted to early life in
writing the memoirs
we didn't have uh access because the
papers had been
nationalized
and uh
the the president's lawyers advised him
a a provision of the law was that he
could have access to the papers while he
if when while and if he challenged it
and he did challenge it and his lawyers
advised him that it didn't serve his
best interest to avail himself of a
provision of the law that he was
challenging
so for the first two years
we worked on the early life
and wrote uh
maybe close to three quarters of a
million words on it
uh which we knew would be cut
but uh it's a fascinating the richard
nixon uh
had a life in full really before he
before he became president uh
and uh he used to say uh that he thought
the most interesting period of his life
was the uh the wilderness year
62-68 went from
absolute abject defeat
uh within six years he was
the president
the uh
as joe says the the the biographies of
nixon ray range
i put them on a sort of scale from
a geography that he was one step short
of canonization
to um
positive
which would be the the the the the
geography would be something like bella
kornitzer in 1959 who had which is still
worthwhile as a period piece and because
he had access to hannah nixon and he got
a lot of family stories
uh
so that's
nixon could do no wrong
uh not to not to demean or dismiss the
book uh
and then sort of the positive books in
into which i would put jonathan atkins
uh book
uh
neutral books into which i would put
conrad black's recent biography which
although he knew nixon and is certainly
sympathetic towards him in many ways
he's also extremely critical of both his
his his personality his policies and his
conduct
and then there are the negatives uh
of which uh in which roger morrison's
book although it is uh finely researched
i think it's hobbled by the fact that he
he sees tends to see everything in a bad
light and then there are the books that
i think can only be described as rabid
and that would be uh sadly fawn brody's
book and anthony summers book the these
are the these are the books these are
the authors for whom nixon could do no
had no could could could do no good deed
or have no decent thought that he was he
was
evil was bred in his bone down to his
dna
and uh the mark of the beast on his
forehead
that's my that would be my uh assessment
of some of those books and it surprises
me
and disappoints me that a lot of nixon
scholarships accepts
uncritically
uh these books which are based on two or
three or four secondary
defective sources
for a lot of these these quintessential
nixon stories
uh
they're
so i don't think they're very good
scholarship but i'm not a scholar
julie i think julie
eisenhower's book
pat
nixon is a
gem that's hiding in plain sight and
because it was easy to dismiss it not
that it was dismissed it was very well
received but it's easy to think that a
daughter that it's a filial work but in
fact she had tremendous access to um
materials from her mother
and uh that aren't that don't appear
elsewhere and i think she's uh uh
remarkably objective i would certainly
put her in the positive category uh but
i think it's a book that deserves uh
revisiting for a lot of the material
that's in there
uh
again i'm so far over my head but
anthony's points that nixon was a known
new dealer
frank nixon i think voted for fighting
bob lafella and
did vote for fdr in 32 and uh
nixon's great uh
hero
initially
because he had admired his career harold
stassen the boy governor and uh he had
followed his career before he went into
the navy and then in the south pacific
he met stassen and that was and and from
that meeting stepson was going through
and he actually i think he actually
brought mail with him but he was going
through on a uh
a goodwill tour
to the troops and uh that made a great
impression on nixon and nixon in 48 at
48 convention was a stasson man
uh one of his other nixon's other great
memories from the war was uh
that he that even talking to me in the
70s uh that he remembered fondly was
ella seeing eleanor roosevelt he didn't
know who it was he knew that there was a
motorcycle array not a motorcycle but a
jeep convoy and he sort of craned his
neck to see who it was and riding in the
back of the jeep with no particular
protection with eleanor roosevelt and
that made he had never seen a uh
first lady and that uh that made a great
impression on him
the uh
i think the i think the the early life
is is uh i'm very partial to it uh both
in the terms of the formation of nixon
uh his character and his his ideas uh
but also because it can correct a lot of
the misunderstandings
gary wills memorably in nixon agonisties
writes about driving down to yorba linda
to see the birthplace
and
he says that driving through this
wasteland of oil derricks and used car
lots with american flags the size of
city blocks
what else would you expect
from richard nixon
but whereas in fact
the orb linda and whittier and fullerton
this area of orange county nixon's youth
was was idyllic and he writes in the
memoirs about that on a clear day you
could see the snows from the snows of
mount baldy to the pacific
and uh and whittier was a remarkable
enclave a quaker enclave of faith of
theology and education
in
southern california they came in the
1880s maybe
and built first church and then a school
and then and then a college
so nixon uh and it was also a a
a
considerably racially diverse community
so nixon's uh
early life i think has been much
disserved and misinterpreted by some
uh authors he was not the psycho the
psycho
biography is applied uh from almost from
the cradle
although he didn't help us in the
memoirs because as he said his first
memory was of running first of all being
dropped on his head
and then running
after a wagon from which he had been
dropped afraid of being left behind
well you know freud is in the wings
waiting to
deal with that
and that's as he
uh said in the interviews of the reason
he uh
somewhat
combed his head backwards combed his
hair backwards was instead of parting it
on the side was because he had a big
scar from that from that early fall
i had argued
and this you can
by looking at his bibliography you can
see my success but i had argued that the
first the first book or a book he should
do after the memoirs was a book on his
early life and i was partly inspired by
president carter's books about growing
up and christmas in plains
but i thought that the that to tell that
this the nixon story in uh your blind
and whittier and fullerton in orange
county uh in his youth and up to the
time that he went away to uh
that he
responded to the ad and the paper and
the letter from herman perry
uh and started his political career um
is is important formative charming and
interesting
am i
three to go
good lord
well i'm
i think i'm sort of out of things to say
did you want to help did you want to
comment on herbs
i'm sorry
well irv is first of all it's great news
that the second volume is uh going to be
uh published
uh and soon sooner than later the first
herb is a uh is an indefatigable
uh scholar
uh a uh an impeccable researcher
and uh i think remarkably fair-minded in
terms of his judgment so he's a triple
threat and is a great uh a great
contribution to nixon uh uh literature
and and historiography um
has erv has gone back and actually gone
to the sources and read
in human capacity the uh
papers and documents and
and and researched to get back
i i have a thing about nixon why did
nixon
with most politicians
as they if they uh succeed upward
the baggage from their earlier careers
is sort of
unpacked and becomes part of the
uh
the mythology with nixon the baggage
from each of his careers was
rechecked weighed opened and inspected
and then sent on to the next stage of
his career i can remember when i was a
white house fellow we invited henry
fonda and his wife to come and speak to
the group and spouses and he was uh then
pushing he was in a play in washington
at the national theater and he was uh
that was produced by a non-profit that
he was trying to get started called the
plumstead playhouse and it would be sort
of a national theater
and uh i was the middleman on this and
he said um actually got him at his hotel
and he said well he was not political
and he he
but if we were a non-partisan or a
bipartisan group which we were that he
would consider coming and speaking so
and that was that was the terms and that
was in fact what we were
so he was charming and great and his
wife were charming and great and after
lunch he said a few words about the plum
stead playhouse and he said you know i'm
not political
uh so i'm a little
strange for me to be here i'm not
political and they thought and he said
except i would go anywhere and do
anything to prevent richard nixon from
being elected to anything
at that point and we were up in an
office in the eob looking down on the
white house and you know you sort of
expected either a missile silo to open
up or lightning to come down
and uh
and i think he thought that that would
have well it did have a great effect on
the group but i think he thought there
would be rending of garments and
and uh so somebody said well well uh
is that because of vietnam
and he said no he said i hate the war
but i think uh i don't think we should
be there but i think nixon is getting us
out as fast as
can be done this was in
the it was in 72 and i think it was in
the spring of 72. and then somebody said
well is it the economy and he said
thought for a minute and he said no he
said i really don't think the i don't
like the way things are going but i
don't think the president has that much
effect on the economy
he thought for a minute and he said i
have to tell you it's because i will
never forget and i will never forgive
what he did to helen gagan douglas in
california in 1950.
and so this baggage this was in 1972
and
that baggage goes on in working for on
the nixon memoirs i had a great
opportunity to talk to uh to interview
for the book both jimmy roosevelt who
was also running for governor that year
and uh paul zifrin who became a
legendary lawyer and was helen keagan
douglas's campaign manager
and both of them told me in separate
interviews that uh that it was a tough
rough as he said like a rocking sake his
nixon said a rocking socking campaign
but uh
not sure now that he said it in
reference to that one but anyway that's
what it was and uh
but they both said and jimmy roosevelt
had actually stood in for her at a
debate she didn't show up for a debate
with candidate nixon and he stood in for
her
and he said that uh that it was rough
and tough but on both sides
and that uh
that uh
nixon won and he won handily as he did
with jerry burris this whole thing about
again my theories am i almost up yes
that you know if you sent to central
casting nixon had was unfortunate in the
people he ran against if you had said
the the year he ran against jerry voris
jory voris had been elected been elected
by the washington press corps the most
popular congressman in washington so
this is the man nixon unseats and then
if you'd sent to central casting and
said send us candidates to run against
nixon who are you know like movie stars
well his next opponent was a movie star
and then he ran against adlai stevenson
who was not a poster boy but he was an
intellectual model and uh and eisenhower
used him to uh
sort of be the political attack man so
and then of course he runs against john
kennedy and pat brown
so he um
in terms of his the press the coverage
and the the baggage uh
uh
from these campaigns just staying with
him and lumbering through all his career
whereas with most people but a lot of
these books these nixon biographies it
would be like uh if if a kennedy
president kennedy biography if you turn
to the index and all the all the quotes
were from
um victor lasky or nigel
uh hamilton
or uh or simon sci hirsch
you know you dismiss it you'd say it's a
screed it's a polemic it's worth seeing
and there might be some good stuff in it
and even some original stuff but it's
skewed
and yet uh the books that do this with
nixon uh are have become part of the
canon so i think that's that's something
that uh that in the future now that the
now that thanks to the archives the
papers are here the nixon library is the
12th of the now 13 presidential
libraries
uh state-of-the-art facility here
archival um so and all the materials are
here so your belinda will become the the
center of
international nixon research and thanks
to
books like mel stalls mel smalls the
historiography of the nixon
administration can be seen in perhaps a
more
uh general not generous
because good and bad things were done at
any a more generous perspective thank
you
[Applause]
by the way i have you i want to invite
the audience into the conversation
questions reactions
uh for any uh of our panelists here uh
there are two people with microphones
who will be running around uh the
lecture hall
so i will call on you
and please don't speak until
you have the microphone so the first
question
rick
right over there
hey my questions for dr cannon are those
did you say 750 000 words
that you wrote about together with nixon
and his early life
that that's how a lot put i mean a real
lot so are those
thousands of pages
i believe i mean they still exist and
are they available to read
i can't answer those i know nothing was
for i mean we all know nothing was
thrown away
um
or erased well some maybe might have
might have been inadvertently erased
or mechanically erased but uh
i don't know the answer that but i'm
sure the answer is yes
and uh as i say for two years
uh
almost two years we worked exclusively
on the early life with the knowledge
that it would be cut
but um
but also with the knowledge that it was
that it was creating a pace that was
creating a tone it was creating a
working operation
uh with a very small uh team operating
under great pressure uh
to to create a style and a method and so
i think uh i don't feel i don't think
anybody felt and certainly the president
didn't feel that it was time wasted or
you know material lost
and again it's it yes i think i'm sure
the answer is it's there in the archives
and it's waiting to be
discovered in mind
this question is directed at the
historian that spent the last years of
his life
examining the nixon eisenhower
relationship
i just completed ambrose's biography of
of eisenhower
in which he speaks at length that the
conversations that took place
between eisenhower and nixon
um trying to
where eisenhower was trying to dissuade
nixon
from being on the ticket for the 56th
um
run for reelection instead saying that
it was in his interest to
run dod
and obviously this must have came from
personal conversations that ambrose had
with eisenhower but i imagine you have
investigated the other side what were
your what are your comments about what
had happened
uh
uh pr and the run up to the 56 and the
decision made for nixon to stand the
ticket
first of all before i answer i forgot to
mention david coleman i don't know if
he's here or not is he is he here
right there thank you david
and
over in the far corner with a shiny
light on top of his shiny head
is ken hughes who's one of the most
brilliant individuals who works at the
miller center and if you want to talk to
someone who really knows
the tapes and the nature of the
presidency
he's one of the primary people to speak
to besides being an awfully nice guy the
answer to your question
is that ambrose
normally gets a lot of stuff wrong
his interviews that he has with
eisenhower
many of them never happened
uh he was outed if you read a thing in
the new yorker called challenging ike
on april 26
2010 i believe
uh
he made up
many of the meetings they never occurred
the answer to your question from the
research is
eisenhower felt that no one since martin
van buren had moved from the vice
presidency to be elected president of
the united states
eisenhower had an incredible sense of
history and was very protective of nixon
in many ways and he felt that nixon
needed training in running a large
bureaucracy
the first attempt at what you're saying
came from a conversation where he talks
to leonard hall who's the chairman of
the republican national committee and he
talks to him i believe on january 9th
1956
and says to len he says look
i really think
that nixon should get a cabinet position
so he could be really an effective
president because he would have the
management of a large organization
lent hall thought so much of that
conversation that when he went out of
the white house in front of the press
congress he said i endorse the
re-election of eisenhower nixon
so the amount of emphasis that
eisenhower really paid
to this was probably minimalist his
brother milton eisenhower wrote a letter
to eric rhoda in 1983
where milton says if my brother wanted
to get rid of richard nixon for the vice
president he could do it in a new york
heartbeat and obviously he never did
question there
my name is uh dr richard arena former
professor of whittier college i'm the
one who
did the richard nixon oral history
project which took which was a two-year
assignment i was put on leave to do that
it took me all over the country it took
me away from my family i'm referring to
the comments in particular of the last
speaker but it's but also the third
speaker
nixon's life
is very complex and that i found out
i worked under
such historians as thomas c cochran some
of you may recognize the name he was
president of the of the american
historical association and i worked
under him at the university of
pennsylvania
he was a totally committed
social historian
even though the l.a
i'm going on with this comment but it'll
come to an end uh we historians love to
talk i'm retired i don't get enough
practice
and
and
thomas cochran
was the uh
american historian for uh
the wharton school of business
and actually it was very leftist
but very socially oriented and when i
interviewed the some 400 persons who are
here located now
at the uh your melinda museum and that
whittier college under uh
professor joe doncoski let me say
one person who did publish some of the
things i
had said
quote
you're too wordy wordy and i was wordy
because i remember one victim
of the training for my phd in history is
in there
take a note
don't don't leave things you know unsaid
so i am wordy i wanted the people that i
interviewed to be completely known to
the reader or listener of the tapes so
when will a complete uh early
life history of
richard nixon which is complex the idea
of black history nixon and whittier
college had
black football players at that time
before world war ii was very few
colleges allowed and richard took the
black historian whom i interviewed by
the way he ended up in the merchant
marine and had nothing but praise with
the nixon family so let me ask them to
respond
clarify the l.a times made the error of
saying that my
that i was appointed and they announced
it as the director of the project to
interview friends and associates don't
believe it i interviewed anti-nixon
people we tried to get jeremy voorhees
among others he refused those who know
whittier we did interview judge martin
ray who hated nixon's guts the last
thing i would do would
try to give a a biased
interview collection on nixon let me ask
you let me ask you too history let me
ask one of them to respond
the last speaker in particular who says
there's a need and the third speaker
there's a need for
a good early life history of nixon thank
you very much thank you excuse the
wordage
okay one of you would like to respond
first of all frank gannon has his
interviews nine days long
very profitable on a university of of uh
george georgia website and it's where i
learned
when nixon met lbj it's the only
document that shows the early
relationship between lbj
and richard nixon second dr arena i hate
you
i really do you did
335 of these oral histories and i'm
almost two-thirds through them and i
gotta tell you
it's long
and the other person that i should
comment on who's no longer with us is
harry jeffrey who did a marvelous series
of about 212 interviews
but
the one question that you had is when
will an early life be done
and the problem with an early life of
richard nixon has nothing to do with the
fascination it has to do with the state
of publishing in the united states today
and it's very very hard to get someone
especially a commercial press to do the
early life of richard nixon
i should say i i went to
like a lot of my things i started and i
didn't finish the thought
uh
i had uh urged the president to consider
writing a book partly because we had
written a lot of it already uh about his
early life and he said to go and see uh
which was a memorable event for me he
said go see his publisher who was
michael corda at uh simon schuster so
that was an adventure for me
and uh he said pretty much the same
thing that it's that and this was 25 30
years ago
and in the wake of the success of the
memoirs
that it's just it's not a and even i was
again as i say i was suggesting it in
terms of the carter books which were
commercial successes
but uh
it's it's a tough
it's a tough sell
um i still think it's worth doing and
the other thing is that the early life
and the jeffries uh collection uh yours
at whittier and the jefferies collection
at fullerton is uh is is a tremendous
resource and ed nixon's book
um
and others uh
but it's it's since it predates his uh
it's more bucolic and formative as
opposed predates his political career i
would i was going to suggest ending it
when he goes away to war because that's
a big change where the non-drinking
non-card playing non-swearing
nixon
pacifist
nixon goes away to war
and uh so that's the end you can't and
although he did you can't go home again
he came home but everything was
different after after that in america
and the world and and and with him so
it's a it's it's not necessarily
something that appeals to a uh
to an historian
um
unless perhaps an historian of place or
the psychobiographer and and and so much
i think of the uh of the unfortunate
stuff all this orthodonians and
franklin's and stuff about what nixon
was like he was a very serious he was
nixon i mean even when he was young he
was a very serious person but he was
very popular he was the president of
various classes
he but he was a serious uh
fellow and uh
so
there isn't a lot of there's a lot of
material but it's not necessarily going
to appeal to a uh
to an historian who is interested in
politics or in later career in his later
career which is so vivid
joe did you want to respond to that
well we have the uh the whittier nixon
oral history has been
we got that in 2008 from the nixon
library and we started a project to
digitize the
transcripts and those are all digitized
but we're still in the process of
developing a website to load the
materials on
so i think the one thing i agree also is
the
cal state fullerton collection has uh
some really valuable materials that are
maybe maybe overlooked but it's uh those
are still
the
uh yorba linda public library put about
20 of those transcripts that are on
on their website at the at the library
but all the other uh
fullerton or the transcripts are in the
office there and you can uh a uh
researcher can come in there and use
them it's uh i think a very valuable
resource
the questions
i'm sorry we don't have a paper program
the author of the forthcoming vice
presidential book
um
irv gilman yes mr gelman the uh
you uh your research indicates that uh
the eisenhower nixon relationship was an
a minus
why is the more common public perception
that it's c minus d plus how did that
come about
was it on purpose or
just lack of research
well since i already need a a visa to
get to uh harvard to let me into the
into the boston area
what what i think happened was this
that the academics
who were and authors lesson june junior
was a wonderful friend of mine
but the academics
who were in the ivy leagues and great
graduate scholars
all supported almost to a man richard
hofstetler henry steele commander
john kenneth goldbreath authors listen i
mean
these are seminal figures
in the historical profession
couldn't get a life every time they they
worked and worked and worked and
there was never a prayer for adlai
stevenson
to defeat
dwight eisenhower i mean the first time
in 52
stevenson lost by 3.5 million votes
the second time he only lost by 9.7
million votes
when these folks went back to their
graduate programs
either consciously or subconsciously
they taught graduate seminars
on what a twit
eisenhower was
and what iraq think
nixon was
it it and it became the stuff
of
the writings
and of their graduate students and their
graduate students graduate students
and it's virtually lasted
until now there's a brand new biography
coming out on dwight eisenhower as
president of the united states
man is a journalist who did enormous
amount of research
he went to dartmouth to take a look at
the sherman adams papers
went to the library of congress
spent considerable time in abilene he
lives
in los angeles
and never came to the nixon library
that's
that's the the long and the short of it
it's it's it's an ingrained nature
among
a certain subset of very very
influential people
that looked at nixon
from the beginning of his vice
presidency and and for that matter
dwight eisenhower was a twin in his the
original books written about him in the
late 50s and early 60s and and sometimes
even now but
it's it for whatever reason
nobody really passionately look
at the papers of either dwight
eisenhower
and richard nixon
and to give another plug if you're
interested online and in the major
libraries
there are the private papers of the
presidency of dwight eisenhower as well
as his early years it's only 21 volumes
so if you wish to peruse it in a half an
hour it should be no problem
but
dom vani and louis galambos did this
brilliantly and those manuscripts that
were are put into book form are terribly
terribly underutilized
another question up here
yeah my name is jeff kimball and i have
a comment and question about psycho
history i agree that a lot of the psycho
history i've read about nixon the
freudian based on freudian theory is
nonsense but it seems to me that
in doing biography you have to do some
kind of
psychological analysis
and i had a question about one aspect of
nixon's psychology i've not looked at
millions of papers but maybe
thousands
of papers on his foreign policy it is
clear from memoirs oral testimony and
documentation that he believed in the
principle of excessive threatening
the principle of threatening excessive
force otherwise known as the madman
theory and it's in its memoirs it's all
over
it was both intellectual and emotional
do you guys have any idea what the basis
of it was aside from intellectual theory
you want to do it
what's the psychological thing either
you guys want to do it
um
i actually wrote about psycho history in
the chapter but today i didn't really i
didn't have time to i don't particularly
uh care care for the
analysis but i know there were um
as far as that i believe it was just a
threat
i don't know maybe kind of simple but i
believe that he thought that if he could
scare him enough that they might take
him seriously
jeff
in
i have done a bunch of work on this
and
it is a basis in eisenhower eisenhower
also thought of excessive force and also
preached
vaguely
obliquely
yes we're going to use a nuke no we're
not going to use a nuke
yes mao you better behave in the taiwan
straits or we're going to
bomb you it is part of our arsenal we
can use it ira churnis talks about this
and the apocalypse man you know this but
it's a long involved thing i think that
nixon looked upon this coming out of the
vice presidency and part of his own
presidency as part of his training that
it was an acceptable thing here is the
general of the army the 800 pound
gorilla dwight eisenhower who did you
know the march all the way from north
africa through france etc and based his
position wherever he was
on whatever force he needed to use
so there is i mean there's just a myriad
of ways we can go into this if you want
to talk about it later you know and go
into it further but that i really think
his background comes from the training
he has under eisenhower in the use of
military power i propose the uh the the
that although it had to do with
journalists not scholars also in my
interviews he told me that
he said that he expected to be put under
a microscope but when they used a
proctoscope it was going too far
and i i think books like the uh baselish
and abraham's abraham said i think some
of the the the psycho they weren't even
psychobiographies they were
psychological assessments
uh of a patient
uh they had never met so i think that
set him off and then i think font
brody's book which is i say uh
just just uh
finds the worst case explanation for
anything
and then uh and then accepts it but also
i think the poignant thing early on is
that when he came in apropos vietnam he
uh he came in with great hopes of ending
the war very soon
and when they were with the secret
negotiations and when they were dashed
he decided and then by then he had the
things going on with china and russia as
a way of bringing pressure on these what
turned out to be very recalcitrant
allies
ally uh
but but at the beginning
he his bone i think his bona fides were
great of thinking he could end the war
in an honorable way to all sides and
just and just end it and when the uh uh
the enemy uh turned out to be
recalcitrant for whatever reasons or and
or figuring that if they could wait him
out it had been a very close election
and if they could wait him out
uh
they'd have another that they might get
a better deal
but his decision then was that in order
to still bring them to the table
and achieve a piece he had to he had to
let them know that he wasn't afraid to
escalate which had which in his
assessment uh was one of the problems
with president johnson that he had
that he had appeared to they to them
whether he did or not this was the idea
that he appeared to be vacillating and
that nixon was not going to do that and
so the other thing was that i think the
the balance of the madman theory was
that while kissinger would be
there there would be
one hand one talon would be holding
arrows and the other talon would be
holding it was it was a balanced made it
was a it was a modified limited madman
uh theory
and
and just to add one thing about this
psycho history stuff
most of us that are pros at this know
about arnold hutchnecker nixon
psychotherapist
well i have arnold hutchniker's medical
records and he came closer to a
proctoscope doing general exams in 52 53
and 54 the last time
hutchnecker saw nixon as a paper as a
patient was a thank you in june of 1956.
he never treated him for psychological
or psychiatric problems it's all jive it
never happened
he never was a psychiatrist
other questions
over there and then down here this panel
ends at 10 30 so these probably will be
our last two questions after that we'll
have a 15-minute break go ahead sir
uh actually a question for frank gannon
i can't resist uh asking um
about the role of formality
in mr nixon's
behavior particularly as president
i remember the the telling
question of
john ehrlich have you ever seen mr nixon
without a suit the answer is no i spoke
with a secret service agent who uh
served with mr nixon at san clemente he
said that even when they went to visit
his mother he was wearing a suit what
was it about wearing a formal attire
that was so important to the president
in his manner
i don't i don't think it was important
to him i think it was just
i mean i think it was generational it
was it was lots of things but it was
just what people did
a lot of people did i can remember as an
undergraduate
the late 50s and early 60s everybody
wore coat and tie jacket and time
so it wasn't that unusual
he
he did have there was a very fine i mean
an artist i guess would you know what
the the this infinite degrees within a
single color and a palette and there
were uh there were infinite degrees of
nixon sartorial
formality and informality and so he
would wear but again i think it's
generational and i don't think that's
anything weird about it uh
it
he would have smoking jackets that were
for relaxation and he would have sports
jackets
but that would be uh informal something
when you'd go out in golf he'd wear
slacks and a and a polo shirt um
so that was uh
i mean it got
the the image got sort of nailed down by
some unfortunate things the the walk on
the beach they was meant to be a
sensitive walk on the beach and wingtips
and
but so it can be overdone
uh but on the weekends uh because we did
we did work uh
i can remember one of my favorite
phone calls was frank i know tomorrow is
christmas
but if you're not doing anything i'll be
in the office and we could catch up on a
lot of work
and
so we
we worked well we had a lot of work to
do on that book but he would come in on
the weekends in a in a jacket and they
and a polo shirt
so it was he would it was
he was a formal uh person uh but i think
those were more he came out of more
formal times and he also had a um
a sense of the mystique of leadership i
think it's interesting in the in the
library here uh the the lincoln sitting
room is recreated and uh
one of where he to which he would retire
at nights and think and write and
sometimes just to turn the lights out
look at the fireplace and listen to
music
and the book that's open on the table in
this replica of the lincoln sitting room
was his copy with his yellow highlights
and it was the one of many copies of de
gaulle's uh edge of the sword
the uh
19
30 something 32 uh collection of essays
and that has to do with the mystique of
leader among other things
with the mystique of leadership and that
the leader was essentially how there had
to be a kind of a distance and i think
that nixon had a sense of this that the
leader wasn't
wasn't meant it wasn't good for the
leader to be one of the people the
people wanted somebody to to admire and
some kind of distance in their leaders
and i think that factored in but again
not in a weird psycho
way um
okay this gentleman's been waiting i'll
get thank you
i'm blake thomas a u.s history teacher
from wineme high school in oxnard
california
and i find
using the psychology angle as accurate
as we can be helps three-dimensionalized
historical figures for our younger
students and i was just wondering
thinking about some early formative
things that happened to both eisenhower
and nixon
eisenhower and mamie i think both lost a
child very early scarlet fever
they never really got over that sting i
still think it that's why i never pushed
all the way to berlin just to save that
many more parents the same heartache
experience
and nixon you read in one of the
displays here about how he listened to
his mother hannah go in and console
his brother at seven just hours before
he finally passed
and you would think that those formative
things might have the effect of
you know i'm not saying wow nationalized
healthcare so these things don't happen
but it was just sort of a them's the
breaks or
how do they
take these things in and keep them from
imbuing their worldview as something
where wow this is the place where
society should step in to save us all
this well or instead it was it's
bootstrap's world and that's just the
way it is i'm wondering i'm not sure
which person would reflect on that but
thank you for answering my question
you know both you and and
professor kimball are absolutely right
in the sense that looking at these
people
from a psychological
value is is is is good serious stuff i
mean i really think it should be done
the problem is is so much of the basis
of how people do this is
not the quantity but how they want the
story to come out
the fly leaf of fawn brody's book says
i am going to prove to you how nixon
lied from the time he was in the womb
until
until the book came out i mean that's
nutty stuff it says more about fawn
brody who by the way the book was
published posthumously so i don't even
know how much of it she wrote
but the nature of what you say and and
and izzy and and uh you know harold and
and uh
the other brother and and the nature of
how these people were affected by death
certainly is is fair game for any good
uh
scholar journalist uh
anybody you look at because sure it
affects and and it's fair game to talk
about this stuff the only thing is is is
to do it within a context of stuff you
know about
dr arena's got
336 oral histories
how many people other than he
and joe
have read all of them you know how many
people have read all of harry jeffrey's
oral histories and and by the way the
bella cornitzer papers are
are posted in drew university in in
madison new jersey and they're available
for research and there are the cassettes
five cassettes with hannah nixon there's
a cassette in 1960 with richard nixon i
mean this is the stuff that historians
you know you know just just love to see
but
for whatever reason
many of my colleagues
don't do the work
and they've got to do the work if if
they're going to be credible if they're
going to be acceptable
then the entire panorama has got to be
what's examined and then let the chips
fall as they may
i i know others of you have questions uh
this session is ending i invite you to
bring those questions to the panelists
who will be circulating we're going to
take 15 minutes
and we will resume in this room with a
session on politics
please thank the panelists
[Applause]
you were both fabulous thank you so much
you did well
this was his yeah
yeah i'm a pleasure to meet you
please please please
all weekend long american history tv
joins our time
and now the final panel from the 14th
annual annapolis book festival a look at
the presidency of richard nixon we'll be
talking today to two
superb authors who have both been
treating
richard
nixon
nixon is back
something more recently said of
voldemort
but also nixon
is back
and uh
i remember just after he got on the
helicopter the vice president he
appointed who became president gerald
ford
said the
my fellow americans the long
national nightmare is over
but like a lot of nightmares there are
flashbacks so it's time we thought this
through i hope they'll even be a few
remarks that reflect on our
current crazy primary
season
but in any case these two
top flight
writers have given their
sharply contrasting
readings of richard nixon
tim
weiner
on my far left
in one man against the world
the tragedy of richard nixon
records in dramatic detail exactly how
lawless
and devious nixon really was
his indictment is just
excruciating and fascinating
detailed
deep
very convincing
evan thomas on my immediate
left right to your eyes
by contrast in being his book in being
nixon a man divided
seeks to explain
what it was
like actually to be
richard nixon
he summons great sympathy and
compassion and understanding that
anxious
conflicted ultimately self-destructive
person
now there is plenty in
tim weiner's book about
self-destructiveness of the man
but the approaches are very different
and that's why with these two major
books by major authors both of them
experts in national
security both of them have written books
about the the cia
these are are people who really ought to
be read
together
their books are very complementary
and it's it's great to
focus in tim's book about some events
like dealing with brezhnev and then to
turn to evan's book and hear in
much more detail that for example
brezhnev when he insisted in staying at
the western white house did not bring
his wife but brought a very
buxom masseuse who wore the same
perfume as pat nixon and raided up and
down the hall after dark in the pat
nixon was not pleased
so
tim weiner's career especially when they
ran into each other on their way to the
bathroom at that time oh so bad
tim weiner was the national security
correspondent for the new york times
his book about the fbi is called enemies
the history of the fbi
and his book about the cia is called
legacy of ashes
the history of the cia and he has won
the pulitzer prize and the national book
award
and evan thomas
is a journalist and an editor with
newsweek for much of his career and his
book about the cia is called the very
best man
and he won the national magazine award
now it strikes me that both men were
just excellent candidates for nixon's
enemies list
these were the kind of journalists with
establishment
journals like
newsweek and the washington post of the
new york times rather mr winer's case
evan went to phillips academy and
harvard and he's the grandson of a man
who ran six times for president as a
socialist
norman thomas he was not
he was not nixon's kind of guy
and yet he writes a very compassionate
biography
and
mr weiner went to columbia university
and columbia school of journalism and
the new york times was almost as much as
the washington post a real
antagonist of
mr nixon at least in nixon's point of
view so my argument is just read these
books together
one concentrates much more on specific
events like the war in vietnam
chile
the daetant
dealings with china dealings with russia
that's mr weiner's book
and it
it's very well complimented by evan's
study of what it was really like to be
richard nixon evan thomas's book
takes the entire life of mr nixon
birth
through the full extent of his life and
offers a great deal of insight about him
as a father as a husband
as a man
who was just always
striving
whereas
tim weiner's book tends to capture the
way that he was truly a raging insomniac
who as he just remarked in the attempt
to deal with his insomnia by medicating
himself with alcohol
not
not a good formula
so each book is so convincing you really
need to sit down with the two of them
together
evan's book is not so sympathetic i mean
in his last paragraph he does remind us
nixon was no
saint but he does seem to have kind of
martyred himself in a lot of his
self-destructive behavior
i thought that i would ask first mr
weiner to tell us what it was that
caused him to
set out to to write this book
well about three years ago i was at the
nixon presidential library in archives
in his hometown about an hour south of
los angeles
talking about nixon's relationship with
j edgar hoover
whom nixon called not entirely sincerely
my closest personal friend in all
political life
over the course of 25 years
when hoover actually died six weeks
before the watergate break-in
which probably wouldn't have happened
had he lived
um
nixon actually said well the old boy
died for the right moment didn't he
he'd been trying to figure out how to
get rid of hoover for years but never
summoned the courage to do it
so three years ago after giving the
speech the archivist at the nixon
library came up and sort of took me
aside and they were excited i said
what's what's happening and they said
well by the end of 2014 everything all
the
tapes
the quarter of a million words of
haldeman's diaries h.r haldeman being
nixon's chief of staff
that were classified top secret
everything will be out
and i said that's amazing it's a 40-year
struggle
to get this material into the hands of
the american people where it justly
belongs
so i put aside what i was working on
and
the tapes began
uh coming out in 2013 they continued to
come out and i have now listened to so
much richard nixon that i can plausibly
do richard nixon which i will not spare
you
uh unless commanded to
um
and
what i finally understood were two
things that i don't think had been fully
understood although god knows richard
nixon has been
um
written about and uh put on uh these
analysts couch
uh for low these many years something
laterally by the way being
psychoanalyzed he detested
um
one was how the war in vietnam
was fought on two fronts
abroad and at home
and how the ward home became the wars of
watergate
it was nixon going after his political
enemies
those who opposed the war
and who opposed him that led
to the crimes that brought him down
the two wars were as one
vietnam and watergate
and the second was after listening to
the newly released tapes which cover
roughly
the
end of the summer of 1972 until
the taping mechanisms were revealed at
the watergate hearings in the summer of
1973
the torment that this man went through
he knew
before he was sworn in for his second
term
that he was doomed
that the presidential chalice was
poisoned
and
the agonies that he put himself and this
country through
trying to cling to power
must never be repeated
the violations of the constitution under
the knicks administration were as
grievous as anything that we have
witnessed since the civil war
and no free republic has survived for
longer than 300 years now that was the
roman empire
in the history of civilization we've
made it to 240. we need to remember
what happened what really happened
in the nixon years
to make it to 300.
evan i would suppose there's kind of a
story of behind your book of how you
decided to
to do what you did
uh i worked for the washington post
company for uh 24 years
and where i worked nixon was the devil
uh a view i shared
uh
and but when john meacham at random
house approached me about writing about
nixon
i i felt that this was going to be the
12th or 13th nixon biography
and i thought you know i i think that
the picture of nixon as bad guy is
pretty well established by now and and
rightfully so
but i want to see what it was like to be
him
uh to sort of put myself into his shoes
uh so i set out to do that uh the good
news about writing about presidents is
they leave an amazing paper trail they
and nixon even more nixon partly because
he hated talking to people
uh took a lot of notes himself he would
have his aides called his yellow legal
pad his best friend because he liked to
be alone with it so he wrote a lot of
notes to himself
there was an amazing paper trail within
uh the white house with his aides
actually have quite an excellent paper
trail i mean excellent equality nixon
had quite a well run for all his
grotesque
uh actions and crimes uh the white house
was a fairly well-run place under h.r
haldman with a paper trail
then of course
nixon wrote thousands of pages literally
thousands of pages of memoir
of varying degrees of reliability
uh and they're the tapes 3 700 hours of
tapes that start they really only cover
a couple years of his presidency but
they're a deep rich motherlode so you
can actually get pretty close to richard
nixon
and that's what i endeavored to do
what i found
was
not the criminal mastermind yes he
committed crimes but rather
someone
who was pathologically shy
and
unable to confront his subordinates a
big reason why he dug himself into such
a big hole in watergate
was his fear of others his inability to
confront his own top top aides for
instance
nixon did not know about the watergate
break-in himself he participated in the
cover-up well
he did but he could not get everybody
his top aides into one room to ask him
what the hell happened here
for about nine months
after the break-in by then it was way
too late felonies were being committed
it was it was a cover-up
uh and that was partly just shyness
not not criminal malevolence but shyness
on nixon's part now that's not excusing
him he committed a crime but i'm
interested in his worldview and his way
he got along with other people and the
way he dealt with other people because i
think it's significant
tim mentioned that
there's a nexus between
vietnam and watergate there certainly is
uh watergate begins at various places
but one big beginning is when they
decide to break in uh when nixon says
three times on tape
that he wants to break into the
brookings institution
after uh the pentagon papers have been
revealed
well the pentagon papers you remember
that this is june 1971 it's a secret
history of the vietnam war pentagon
papers never mentioned richard nixon
but nixon is obsessed about leaks he's
running
private diplomacy at the time secret
diplomacy to china he's got henry
kissinger over in china and he's
obsessed about leaks and he's obsessed
about the times in the post and
and he has this he thinks that somewhere
in the brookings institution
there is a report that he himself
commissioned
on a long and convoluted story about how
he did something illegal before the 1968
convention of communicating
a convention of community 1968 elections
excuse me of communicating with uh the
south vietnamese government to tell them
not to take a deal with lyndon johnson
something that johnson thought was
treason
and nixon is obsessed that there's some
report and he tells his folks to break
into brookings well
one of his aides h.r holdman said why
don't we just go ask them
but nixon was
crazy and it at various times and
certainly at this time and and one thing
that this is where historical context is
is useful
for a long time
well first of all i should have just
asked but if he wanted to find stuff or
learn get in political intelligence for
a long time the fbi did that for
presidents
yeah that's how jaeger whoever stayed in
office all those years was acting as a
political spy for presidents and also
blackmailing them uh getting dirt on
them
but by by 1971 the wind is changing here
there's you know the warren courts there
they're liberal they're starting to
outlaw wiretapping or put restrictions
on the legal wiretapping presidents are
now limited in what they can do and
jager hoover he's no fool he
stayed in office a long time because of
his political instincts he he could see
the wind to shifting and he and so went
so when
nixon says i want you to dig up dirt on
ellsberg find out about ellsberg the
leaker
hoover refuses to do it
he's out of the game of black bags and
and burglaries and illegal he's the
fbi's not doing that anymore so what
does nixon do
he goes in-house he creates his own
investigative unit within the white
house called the plumbers remember them
the plumbers well here's the thing about
the plumbers
they sound like a bunch of arch
criminals uh hunt and liddy those guys
were stumble bumps
in classic washington fashion they
weren't they were you know there was
little talk about hunt was like james
bond and
lydia was a g-man actually
hunt was a fool who'd been dumped on the
white house by the cia time-honored
washington tradition uh dumping him on
the cia because they didn't want to keep
him at the excuse me one dummy on the
white house because they didn't want to
kill him the cia same thing with liddy
liddy was a idiot who had been dumped on
treasury which then dumped him on the
white house so the crack squad that uh
working for the plumbers were hunt and
liddy and they were run by a guy named
eagle kroge
eagle croak is not your criminal
mastermind he was a former eagle scout
his nickname at the white house was evil
krog it was a joke it was a joke he
wasn't evil at all but he was
intimidated by nixon and he ran this
this
crew of clowns and they screwed up they
broke into ellsberg's psychiatrist's
office made a hash of that then they
broke into the watergate they did other
things as well and got caught
not criminal masterminds nixon didn't
even know about these break-in attempts
there's some evidence that is his top
aides air like man and erlickman
certainly did but nixon probably not uh
record's a little squishy on that but
but mostly uh
it was a it wasn't the point is it
wasn't a master conspiracy to violate
the constitution it was a bunch of
hapless guys running around to carry out
the will of their deeply insecure
president
this might be a time to build bring bud
crow on stage
but you make it clear tim again and
again the phrase gutter politics
appears i mean we may think of nixon
just as a man who was out of touch and
had some
devious and totally ungoverned
stumble bum's working for him
but uh but you tell the story in a much
more sinister
way
well they didn't call him tricky dick
for nothing and they had called him
tricky dick for a long time since the
beginning of his political career
but
what
we get in one man against the world is
on top of the insecurity that heaven
talks about the personal deep personal
insecurity
a
sense of a man coming apart
um and there was no better witness to
this than the young
eagle bud kroge
the time is may 1970
a few weeks later hoover would say no to
nixon for the first time saying i'm not
going to do your dirty work anymore and
then slides the creation of the plumbers
in the summer of 1970.
but this is may 1970 nixon has just
invaded cambodia
in search of a non-existent bamboo
pentagon
it was supposedly coordinating
enemy supply routes on the ho chi minh
trail
the campuses explode you all remember
this
the national guard kills four kids at
kent state
nixon at this point
um hasn't been able to sleep for a solid
week
okay and hauled him in notes in his
diary the president's really beat
and he really needs some good rest
and then comes the shooting at kent
state
and then
as a hundred thousand kids are coming to
washington
to protest the invasion of cambodia
nixon's on the verge of a nervous
breakdown he stays up all night friday
into saturday
in his own words
agitated not uneasy making more than 50
phone calls and finally calling upon his
valet manolo sanchez to accompany him to
the lincoln memorial so he can rap with
the hippies about the war
and bud crow was on duty that night at
the white house
and he vividly recalled in an oral
history
at the nixon library
4 30 in the morning
i was in the secret service command post
and over the loud pete speaker came the
words
searchlight is on the lawn
search light being the president's
secret code name and i immediately
punched an airline's home number and
said the president that is out and about
and i think he's on the lawn in the rose
garden and marilyn said render
assistance right now
and so i did and i found where the
president was going and followed him up
to the lincoln memorial
about i couldn't have gotten there more
than three or two or three minutes after
he got there went up the stairs to see
what was going on and found him in
discussion with at the start 10 or 15
young people students who had come in
from all over the east coast now there
were three
women who were there whose eyewitness
accounts of this conversation are the
only ones we have
their names are lynne schatzkin ronnie
kemner and joan pelletier
chaskin he didn't look anyone in the
eyes he was mumbling as far as sentence
structure there was none
kempner someone would ask him to speak
up and that would sort of jolt him out
of wherever he was and he'd look up and
shake his head around but then he'd go
back to looking at his feet and he was
gone again there was no train of thought
and pelagie nothing he was saying was
coherent
at first i felt awe and then that
changed right away to respect and then
as he kept talking it went to
disappointment and disillusionment and
then i felt pity because he was so
pathetic and then just plain fear to
think that he's the president of the
united states i think we all went
through that anyone who lived through
this as i think most of the people in
this room did went from that feeling of
awe to fear
the root of awe is awful as in
terrifying and
this is a microcosm of what happened to
richard nixon
as he disintegrated
over the next
four
years
but that shows the difference between
then and now because it took an entire
presidency for us to reach that point of
fear at the prospect of such a man in
office whereas with trump we've already
gotten there and we haven't even
completed the primaries this is
amazing that's the difference then and
now though isn't it really that you have
these thousands of hours of tapes and we
can hear you've listened to
everything that was said in the oval
office and nowadays we're just we're not
going to have
tapes from the oval office
or emails or emails no they've learned
that
instead the oval office is going to have
all of our emails and tapes of us
so it's kind of inverse
do we really do we really need though
to
bring nixon down so hard tim
i mean it seems like
after reading
the indictment that you lay out
there's really
nothing left of the man i get the idea
that he was so
so
so anxious so afraid constantly and also
was very very effective in
protecting himself
but
did you feel that it was
was necessary he sometimes comes across
as a kind of a political
dracula and that each one of your
chapters is another stake in the heart
it was nixon who famously said i gave
them a sword
and they stuck it in
and twisted it with relish
and i guess if i'd been in their
position i would have done the same
thing
this is a man who said hours before he
left the white house well we all
remember that gray august afternoon in
1974
one of his last words to the american
people
always remember others may hate you but
those who hate you don't win unless you
hate them and then you destroy yourself
and this is the story of a man a
president destroying himself
and doing
serious damage to american democracy
and is a lesson that we cannot forget
i was fascinated by that it's just as
tim said as he's leaving the white house
this is his last day about to get on the
helicopter he makes that remarkable
statement
in which he says you know if you hate
your enemies it's going to destroy you i
rather than i said whoa too late did he
just realize that
i looked and i looked in the record for
some self-awareness because this
runs all the way back to his tricky dick
days it runs all the way back to
childhood of his anxiety about his
enemies was he never
aware that this was a fatal flaw that
this was going to haunt him uh
there are little tiny hints here and
there he says to his son-in-law
ed cox
a few days before he resigns he says
well it's like a shakespeare play or a
play by the ancient greeks it's got to
play itself out i was curious to see
whether they'd ever read a play by
shakespeare
so his papers his high school college
papers are at yorba linda at the library
and he did he read shakespeare's julius
caesar and he wrote about a paper about
it it's a terrible paper
he totally missed the point about hubris
uh and you cannot find he there's a lot
he would talk about his own destiny but
he was just remarkably unself-aware i
would ask people do you think that
richard nixon knew himself do you think
he knew himself brent skalcroft said to
me well sometimes i think he took a peek
and he didn't like what he said
i asked i asked james schlesinger who
had been nixon's secretary of defense
and cia director
did nixon know himself and schlesinger
said no
but then he looked out the window and he
said who does
now that's a fair question and an
interesting question when you deal with
very powerful people think about it
if you're somebody who gets up every
morning thinks you're going to save the
world or do great things you can't be
too worried about where your car keys
are or how you're getting along with
your wife or you know it often great men
have blinders on and great women have
blinders on their they're they're going
in one direction and this lack of
self-awareness which is so haunting in
nixon and so ultimately self-destructive
not entirely uncommon i mean i think
lincoln knew himself but a lot of others
didn't
uh and so it raises sort of interesting
questions about greatness about whether
you can really aspire to do great things
if you are self-reflective or whether
you need to have these blinders on
nixon's a tragic case of somebody who
brought himself down but there are a lot
of gray areas here and other leaders and
you just i wonder i was just was
fascinated by this
it may be it may be
that in the 4 a.m of nixon's soul he
really did know
uh there is a 10 000 page nixon diary
which is still sitting behind closed
doors i asked uh frank gannon who was
nixon's ghost writer on uh on his memoir
who spent three years working on this
has read that uh diary and i asked
gannon is there any self-awareness in it
he said no
uh
but there may be you know one one of the
wonderful things about history is
there's always more documents you think
you're done you're not uh there's always
another round so maybe we'll learn more
about nixon but but i was fat this very
thing that dick that that that tim
raised here about nixon and his enemies
i just found that so interesting had he
was he so blind to his own weakness i
believe so and i think we have
as an authority on this none other than
henry kissinger
who once famously said can you imagine
could have been if anyone had ever loved
him
yeah
and i think a virtue of evan's book is
it is imagining what's what he might
have been if anyone had loved him
um
and
i don't think
that you can
fault a man who produced two daughters
as marvelous
as julian trisha who are really
spectacular human beings and how they
endured
we'll never know he was weirdly a good
family unlike some politicians he didn't
cheat on his wife uh there's a little
tiny evidence of possibly he did but by
i think basically he was not nor did he
sleep with her
yeah
that's actually literally true that's
actually the other thing
she claimed that he was always getting
up in the middle of the night and making
notes and so that they slept in separate
bedrooms
uh
but but that marriage is interesting
because by the by the end of watergate
it's terrible it is terrible in fact
when nixon decides to resign he doesn't
tell his wife he tells rosemary woods
who tells his wife it's that but but but
with nixon and there's always a butt
the early marriage is pretty good i mean
the love letters are real and they go on
for years
and and and he depends on her there are
at least five or six times when nixon
says i'm getting out of politics i've
had it i'm done
and she says no you can't
because she understood him to know that
he would that would destroy him if he
got out of politics that would be the
end and she said you can't you just you
won't be able to live with yourself now
i think he was fishing for that with her
he was needy and he wanted her to say
that but she did and she bucked him up
and she gave good political advice but
unfortunately when he became president
h.r haldeman nixon's chief of staff who
was a good chief of staff in many many
ways but not in some critical ones and
one of the ways in which he was a bad
chief of staff was he really
drove a wedge between nixon and his own
wife well he spent a lot more time with
the president than she did right that is
true
and
she felt isolated
off there on the east wing isolated mad
at holdemon
and
uh she knew when she heard about the
tapes she knew her husband well enough
to know what those tapes were going to
sound like and she wanted to destroy
them so did a lot of other people and
then the question became
are we going to build a bonfire on uh
the white house lawn and if so who's
going to strike the match
king timaho that being the president's
not very faithful irish senator hank
suggested manolo
the butler
yeah uh because that would have been a
obstruction of justice and whoever did
that would have gone to prison for 100
years actually not true i think there's
about a day there before the subpoenas
arrived when i think they would have
gotten away with it they could have
burned the tapes before the subpoena
arrived all hell would have broken loose
but i think his presidency would have
survived that
i know this because i wrote a book about
edward bennett williams the lawyer that
was his advice burn burn the tapes on
the front lawn as long as you do it
before the subpoena arrives you can
weather the storm yeah this is a
subpoena conversation
they could have just given them to
gordon lydian he would have eaten the
tapes
he would have set them a flame and then
held his hand over them
to see how much pain he could endure
exactly there is an uplifting moment on
that last tragic day
um that uh
we do want to take some questions from
folks right yes we do but i think we've
got another seven minutes or so before
we need to do that there there is an
uplifting moment on on that day that
that i would like to close on because i
do not want people to think that this
book is you know 300 pages of of
blood and tears i appreciate you doing
that i think i may have overemphasized
it
um
there was a young man he's
gone now on the national security
council staff
a marine
who went on to become a diplomat
serving in iraq
lebanon saudi arabia syria uh yemen and
he was the american ambassador uh in
bahrain uh during the 1990s and he sadly
died in 2005 at the age of 65 but before
he did he left his oral history
he's on the nsc staff
he wanders into the oval uh into the
east uh room where nixon is making this
tragic
last final address about uh
then you destroy yourself
and he noticed that nixon's in it nixon
is in a trance
the military age who's with him has to
steal him and sort of brace him and tell
him where he is and what's going to
happen what's going to happen next nixon
gives a speech
in the morning as you remember is a
gloomy gray august morning the
helicopter is waiting on the lawn
nixon leaves the white house he says
farewell to gerald ford
and he walks to the chopper and young
david michael ransom then 32 on the nsc
staff steps out onto a balcony on the
south portico to watch nixon fly away
and there are two people standing next
to him on the little balcony if you've
ever been to the white house it's quite
timeless
just enough space for the three of us to
be there
one is this young nsc aide one is the
white house chef who's about six by six
and hans holler and the other is the
secretary of defense james schlesinger
smoking his pipe
nixon flashed his double arm signal of
departure with two fingers raising a
visa and and then he turned and entered
the helicopter rants and remembered it
cranked up very slowly lifted off and
disappeared into the gloom of the
morning it was almost a haunted scene
as the helicopter faded into the fog the
three men looked at each other
schlesinger takes his pipe out of his
mouth bangs it on the railing of the
portico and he says well it's an
interesting constitutional question but
i think i'm still the secretary of
defense
so i'm going to go back to my office and
he looks at the chef and he says what
are you going to do when the chef says
i'm going to prepare lunch for the
president
and the young nfc staff remembered years
later i thought of course the king is
dead long live the king
the cook had it right this wasn't a
matter of abstinence arguments over
constitutional principles
our state was going to carry on the
president would want lunch in about an
hour and a half so the cook went off and
prepared it i've always thought of that
as something very important about our
country we may stumble but we don't fall
tim mentioned a
man who could have two such daughters
there's a short passage i'd appreciate
evan reading that mentions them
evan has many details that show even
while the man was running the world he
was very concerned about the people
closest to him like rosemary woods
and i was really startled to find
in his book that at one point he
redictated an entire letter
so as not to include a word that he was
afraid she wouldn't be able to spell
so he changes the word then starts over
he was very concerned about small
details for people and she was not a
small person
in his life
she's the one who i guess for about 16
minutes of the gap in the tapes she must
have been somehow in the most gymnastic
position where she could be i think
that's a bad rap but
i do remember a picture i think it was
might have been in newsweek that showed
the position she would have had to hold
for 16 minutes with her toe on the
eraser button for the dictaphone and and
her hand on the phone because she was
answering phone calls and forgot for 16
minutes to lift her foot
in any case this is a passage about the
day when the prisoners of war
come to the white house the newly
released 491 prisoners and nixon wants
to give them a a party it captures a lot
of
his style i think
uh
you want me to do the full thing or just
uh from here well the full thing's
awfully good
uh well okay
we still have good time for questions we
should start questions in about four
minutes so that'll work
nixon's one bright light was the return
of the 591 prisoners of war from vietnam
at a ceremony at the state department in
may he greeted them one by one when
everett alvarez the first pilot to be
shot down and captured reached him in
the line nixon grabbed alvarez's arms
and shoulders and began feeling them you
look good he said to the naval aviator
who had spent over eight years in
captivity looking down avoiding
alvarez's eyes nixon said in a somber
tone i tried i really tried
the president and first lady wanted to
give these men some of whom had been in
brutal captivity for years
the biggest party in the history of the
white house on the rainy night of may
24th some 1200 guests dined on the south
lawn and a great white tent that was
larger than the executive mansion itself
beforehand a pow chorus of 35 men sang a
hymn that one of them had written in
prison and the former prisoners of war
and their families were invited to
wander through the nixon's private
quarters on the second floor the men
presented nixon with a plaque inscribed
our leader our comrade richard the
lionhearted
among the invited celebrities john wayne
rose and toasted the pows by saying i'll
ride into the sunset with you anytime
nixon introduced irving berlin the aged
songwriter who in a gravelly voice led
them all in his famous song god bless
america the men shouted and cried the
last words god bless america my home
sweet home
at 12 30 a.m with the party still
growing going strong
nixon kissed pat good night and went
upstairs to the lincoln sitting room
sitting before the fire listening to the
sounds of laughter and music coming from
below he felt he recalled that this
quote that this was one of the greatest
nights of my life then he thought of
watergate and was struck quote by an
almost physical force
picking up the phone he called julie and
trisha in their rooms and asked them to
join him
my father seemed drained as if the
emotion of the evening had been too much
for him julie recalled with the girls
there nixon telephoned his friend the tv
producer paul keyes who would organize
the evening's performances
parentheses bob hope and sammy davis jr
no girly show was the first per the
first lady's instruction
with keys the creator of laughing nixon
tried a few jokes quote but it was
almost painful for us to see how sad
daddy's face looked despite the laughter
in his voice trisha recorded in her
diary nixon hung up there was silence
then the president asked his daughters
do you think i should resign
they burst out with a wave of
exclamations according to tricia don't
you dare don't you even think about it
trisha who knew her father wrote in her
diary he really wanted us to give him
reasons for not resigning
the next phone call
he makes
after midnight
is to al hague yeah
and he says
and he's really
either exhausted or drunk or both
on this tape and he says
wouldn't it be better for the country
you know to just check out
no seriously nixon says
i'm not at my best
i've got to be at my best and that means
fighting this damn battle fighting it
all out and i can't fight the damn
battle
the goddamn thing has gotten to me and
you get to the point well if you can't
get the goddamn job
done
you better put in there somebody who can
and this is 15 months
14 months 15 months before he steps down
yeah you keep hearing him deliver these
lines to his daughters or getting his
wife to assure him he must stay in the
presidency and you wonder has he just
just pulled off a setup has he just
gotten them to tell him what he must do
because that's what he wanted to do i i
think he psychologically does that
repeatedly with with pat certainly and
with his daughters yeah yeah
i think it's time for some questions i
just would note that as i read what's
going on in the papers today there's an
operative
for mr trump who has decided that he
wanted everyone to know everyone who
might be wavering in their delegate
dedication to him
that they would be collecting the phone
numbers of delegates in cleveland and
publishing them so that people could
find them in their rooms and punish them
for their infidelity
roger stone is his name and his first
good political job
committee to reelect the president
working for
richard nixon still at it gone but not
forgotten no
gone but back again
yes please eric hi
um i think both of your books are
extremely valuable in terms of looking
at the individual of nixon and the
people around them the effects of it
thank you thank you at the same time
i think about essentially all the
victims of nixon and kissinger and the
not just in not just beginning with
nixon but going back
at least five years in specifically in
vietnam also in chile
and uh what's a cointel program in the
united states and so on that goes back
to 56. i'm just wondering if both of you
could
comment on that aspect these were
individuals
just as much as richard nixon i think
that
richard nixon
along with j edgar hoover was the most
powerful anti-communist in america
for a very very long time
and
that
as
terrible an economic and political
system as communism was
american anti-communism did destroy
lives
um
and
a lot of people in this country were
ruined
uh by fbi programs um that richard nixon
was fully witting
of as they said
at the watergate hearings and
[Music]
by an american foreign policy that
really goes back to
the rise of
the right
immediately after world war ii
and richard nixon's rise coincides with
that time
uh all true uh with nixon there's always
a but nixon's also the guy who goes to
china i mean he he leverages his
anti-communist reputation
uh to make him
the one who can go to china uh which was
a pretty bold diplomatic stroke
using uh henry kissinger as his front
man but it was nixon's idea not
kissinger's idea
nixon also is the first president to go
to moscow
where he signs negotiates and signs the
first ever arms control treaty
dayton is a nixon creation nixon loved
to confound his enemies uh he liked to
outflank them often to the left
uh one thing that's very
one thing is hard to pin down about
nixon is that there's there's a famous
expression not from nixon but from his
attorney general
watch what we do not what we say
because nixon's rhetoric was often hotly
right-wing and intemperate but his
actions could be moderate
he liked to make deals he was always
making deals with the democrats on
capitol hill democrats control congress
in his time they passed a lot of
legislation
nixon created the environmental
protection agency now did he do that
because he wants to save the rivers and
waters not entirely he did it because ed
muskie
senator from maine
was cranking up to possibly the 1972
presidential candidate for the
democratic party and nixon saw a way to
outflank him
by coming up with the epa with nixon
typical nixon pettiness nixon refused to
invite ed musky to the signing ceremony
for the clean air and clean water this
is why you have to watch what he says
because what he says was the environment
is not an issue that's worth a damn to
us
quote unquote
i'm thinking also beyond the
beyond the political aspects that you're
talking about but just as the
individuals that typified by things like
me like where soldiers were pushed to
the point and encouraged
basically for mass destruction of people
or napalm being dropped on hundreds of
thousands of people for example just the
the tragedy
of and it didn't start with nixon i know
it didn't start with nixon by any means
but the that part of the tragedy of life
of
what their actions i think if you just
want to talk about domestic policy
instead of foreign policy the self-same
attorney general evan mentioned um john
mitchell who went to prison for three
years and eight months for his
obstruction of justice
also said this country is going to go so
far to the right that you won't
recognize it
and he said that in 1970.
well the pendulums
shift
every 30 years or so i think
um
and the country did go quite a ways to
the right but we have
as the young nfc staffers said away we
may stumble
but we don't fall
we have a self-correcting mechanism in
the constitution
just a couple of quick questions
regarding that midnight visit to the
lincoln memorial was there any
indication that it could have been
alcohol fueled in any way
didn't kissinger report that
he
he was lauded
along those lines maybe after he hadn't
slept well for days and he had had a few
okay
um regarding the tapes what was
nixon's initial thought what was going
to be happening with those tapes what
was what to what use
were they going to be put the origin of
the tapes is interesting uh it's it's he
didn't put the system in until february
1971 he actually took out johnson's tape
johnson had a taping system nixon ripped
it out
because nixon didn't want to be
eavesdropped upon by the pentagon the
johnson system had been installed by the
signal corps of the pentagon and nixon
was afraid that the pentagon would be
would spy on him actually nixon was
right the pentagon did spire absolutely
not not through taping but because a
yeoman named radford was going through
the burn bags and the nsc staff and
linking it back to the joint chiefs of
staff you can't make it up
everybody was spying on everybody else
but to answer your question
in the winter of 1971 nixon became
particularly upset about henry kissinger
boasting about his foreign policy
achievements
kissinger was a skillful national
security advisor but the idea is the big
ideas came from nixon going to china
that was nixon's idea not kissinger's
idea so nixon
said wants to be able to rebut kissinger
when they write their memoirs he wants
there to be a record that shows what
really happened that's the impetus for
putting in those tapes as kissinger
later said he paid an awfully high price
for that for that yes
absolutely right to guard himself
against the inevitable and continuing
memoirs of henry kissinger
they're still going on and and also to
write a multi-million dollar
uh white house memoir
so it never occurred to him that these
are going into the presidential library
that many people would be able to listen
to them he thought they were his tapes
okay
and fought that i think he said his
legal fees were something like 17
million dollars before he fought for
years and years and years to keep the
tapes out he ultimately lost but it took
forever okay thanks
please
hi there my name is patrick lester i
used to be a student here i think back
in the day when a lot of this was going
on but i have a question
not so much looking back but looking to
our president and possibly our future i
think you uh made a comment a little
while ago that said
democracies uh
like of ours lasted maybe three four
hundred years i think you said 340 for
us
that was a unique time you had vietnam
you had riots in the cities in a lot of
ways nixon was himself not just his
personal background but the times he was
a reflection of the times so if we
advance from back then until now
thankfully we don't have you know riots
in the cities we don't have a war right
now
but i wonder and my question goes to our
system you say we have a self-correcting
system
but what we have is a system where
back in those days you had liberal
republicans who sided against the
president and to a great extent were
responsible for him stepping down if we
had the polarization then
that we have now
would we have ended up with a
constitutional crisis and an end to
democracy and what does that say about
the future
the polarization thank you evan
the polarization
that gripped
washington
where you had a
uh
an impeachment process in full swing and
there is no question that nixon would
have been impeached in the house
convicted in the senate and then
criminally convicted as a private
citizen
for obstruction of justice among other
crimes
has now spread
thanks in part
to the political strategies of richard
nixon specifically the southern strategy
where he's
peeling off
the conservative southern democrats that
voted for the racist governor former
governor of alabama george corley
wallace who was shot and nearly killed
in 1972 after winning primary after
primary on the
in the democratic race
so if you put the conservative
republicans together with the
conservative democrats
um
on an essentially
segregationist
platform
um
then you can build
a coalition that lasts
um i think that coalition was broken in
the 2008 election
and we'll see if anybody can reform it
in the 2016 election
yes please
[Music]
so tv you need to go to the mic thanks
i'm usually loud enough so i don't need
one of these things thank you uh the
question is process you both have
listened to a lot of the nixon tapes i
presume they have been transcribed and
and indexed and things like that are
they available online on the internet
now
so how did you go about it that's the
question
uh that you you too can go online
there's something called
nixontapes.org a guy named luke nichter
who's a professor at texas a m has one
person has actually listened to all the
tapes every one of them
has put a lot of them online
uh and uh it's fun to roam his site
uh amazingly they have not been
transcribed partly because they're so
hard to decipher
uh i ended up i i listened i did my
listening not online but out at yorba
linda with a headset uh so that i could
actually hear them on the on the tapes
that are out there at the presidential
library
uh
the real this a lot of the best tapes
were done
uh were were from nixon's hideaway in
the executive office building and it's
also the thumps and clatters and you
can't and they're mumbling past each
other yeah
and the transcripts
vary
uh people depending on who's doing them
you know some people will use the word
ambassador is it ambassador or did he
say bastard
[Laughter]
or both
so they're difficult to use
you have to spend a lot of time
on them to really understand them
they have not been transcribed i think
there's some talk again of getting them
transcribed it would be an enormous
project there are other sources the
nixon library itself
has put everything that's available
online online and you can listen online
there is also a remarkable feat
that has been accomplished by
the state department
under law since the civil war the state
department publishes a series called the
foreign relations of the united states
and the historians at the state
department have done an astonishing job
of transcribing nixon tapes relating to
foreign policy
that
have never
had never previously been transcribed
and they are stunning
and revelatory and terrifying
we have time for one more question i
think thanks
okay both of you mentioned when uh the
president talked to general hagen he
said it at some point well isn't it time
to just give this up
was he meeting resign or did he have
something darker in mind
yeah hank has a story that uh
uh towards the end further along than
tim's story uh this is now the summer of
1974.
uh nixon brings up that whole old image
of a military tradition where
an officer leaves a pistol and a drawer
and nixon apparently according to hague
raised this possibility should should
you leave a pistol on a drawer for me
and that made hague anxious that nixon
wanted to kill himself i think other
people were also worried that nixon
would do himself in i don't know you
know it's so hard to know in these when
somebody's in that much trouble how much
of these are cries for help and they're
just seeking reassurance or whether it
it it indicates true suicidal ideation i
think they call it uh the fact is he
didn't kill himself and he had nixon one
thing he's not a life force
one thing about him he would get knocked
down and he would come back again and
again you know he was finished off in 62
remember he's beaten for governor and he
says you won't have dick nixon to kick
around anymore and 1968 he's running for
president again uh
even after he's driven from office and
disgraced
he moves back he he could have just
played golf out there he had this
beautiful house in san clemente it's a
gorgeous house he moves back to new york
and lives a block away from teddy white
and arthur
belly of the beast surrounded by the
very people who hated him and he hated
dude because
he just
he needed to get back in the arena and
he'd have these chinese dinners and
invite journalists over and he just
wanted to be in the thick of things
surrounded by people who couldn't stand
them but he but he just he needed and he
was always sending memos to presidents
in he and bill clinton became kind of
friends towards the end
two months after he resigned he's out in
san clemente
and his chronic phlebitis is october
1974
doubtless compounded by depression
flares up
and
he goes into coronary crisis
and he's rushed to the hospital and his
doctor uh wrote writes in a memoir that
he almost died that night
he came very very close to dying in
october
saying come back wake up richard come
back slapping him
well he did
and he spent the next 20 years of his
life
turning
his career
into the parable of a man who had
suffered died and been reborn and that's
why these two books are so well timed
because
40 years from nixon if you go back 20
years in the 1990s there was an obvious
and
largely successful i think attempt to
reinvent the legacy and create him as
the global statesman
and now 20 years later i think we can
finally use the tapes and
the journals and the
alderman recollections and interviews
and really
get a great sense
of what nixon really was like
so
i wanted to
remind everyone we've been talking to
tim weiner author of one man against the
world
nixon's the one it says
the tragedy of richard nixon
and also to evan thomas
author of being nixon
a man divided
thank you very much
[Applause]
we strongly recommend you buy and read
our books
highly recommended
is
you got a great job
and that wraps up book tv's coverage of
the 14th annual annapolis book festival
you can watch all of the events tonight
starting at midnight
three hundred years three hundred yeah
and we've made it to two forty
c-span created by american policies have
on poverty
[Music]
this week on q and a long time
journalist and author john farrell he
discusses his book richard nixon the
life
[Music]
john farrell better known as jack
author of the book richard nixon the
life at the very end of your book in the
footnotes at the end the source notes
you say this
he hoped that billy graham
or norman vincent peale would handle the
prayers this is at his
funeral and quote doesn't want a
catholic or a jew to participate this
comes from a haldeman comment
what was what was that all about this
was at his funeral yeah
yeah nixon came from a very
provincial background we think of
southern california now as highways and
subdivisions but when he was growing up
it was
the outback it was orange groves and
hills and very small towns in between
and he grew up with a certain provincial
bigotry i think he got some of it from
his father who was a an unlearned man
and over the years nixon learned to deal
with it because he had to nixon could do
almost anything
if he had to
and so he had great advisors like len
garment henry kissinger arthur burns who
were jewish
but in private against
his enemies who happened to be jewish he
could be very ugly and i think that this
was sort of a blanket statement
haldeman had his own biases and perhaps
he
took it down a little bit more severely
than it sounds but
nixon definitely he wanted a a
protestant
mainstream
white american burial
i found the last 120 pages
where they were source notes there
weren't a part of the narrative in your
book uh with some of the most
interesting stuff and i and anybody
watching
usually people are older that watch this
kind of a program they're going to know
who richard nixon was and all that so
i'm not going to try to go through in
the details so that's why i'm
focusing on this
with that in mind yep i want you to hear
something that you know about of course
from one of the tapes
first of all we'll ask you did uh
holdemon know that the richard nixon had
a taping system haldeman and a couple of
others secret service technicians were
the only ones okay the reason i asked
that is you'll see because this is
haldeman and president nixon talking in
the oval office in 1971 and you got it
we've got it on the screen so listen
carefully
[Music]
that proves
something
very interesting things so a few of
those who engage in espionage
are neighbors
very lucky
and good
matter of fact very few of them become
communists
if they do they either like they get in
the angel of neighbors they're hardly an
activist type
and they throw bonds and this and that
but the negroes you ever notice
the crappy negro spies
not intellectualism
not smart
it may be not smart enough to be found
as the jews intellectual the jews are
born spies
you know somebody learned just you know
but up to the next
basic
tediousness
americans
that's what makes us now you know
he puts himself above the wall
now they both knew that they were on day
but what in the world are they talking
about that for
they knew they were on tape but it would
take
far too much
intellectual concentration and effort to
talk all the time
for the tape recorder
and he was confident that he could
maintain control on he had been
eisenhower's vice president and he had
seen eisenhower and truman before them
make vast
claims of executive privilege so he
thought that
he would be able to safeguard his tapes
and his papers
forever and nobody else would ever
hear about them
the bad part about the tapes
is that
they're ramblings they're
spewings they're nixon talking off the
top of the head they don't show any of
the positive signs of nixon and they are
forever going to be this huge millstone
around his neck because every time
somebody tries to write something nice
about him and say well you know this was
a decent president look what all he did
for the environment look he proposed
this visionary healthcare plan um he
created the uh environmental protection
agency and then somebody's going to play
one of these tapes
and it's going to you know drop them
back down on the on the on the list of
presidents um it's a it's it's it's very
revealing it's it's fantastic for a
historian this is we have two or three
presidencies in a row where we have
kennedy johnson and nixon caught on tape
talking to their aides nothing like this
ever before can you imagine if you had
washington and jefferson and hamilton
talking on tape in the cabinet um but uh
this so but they but they will forever
be a just a hindrance to the
rehabilitation of richard nixon how long
is this stuff like that how long did you
work on this book six years from start
to publication why did you do it
i did it because i had a very smart
editor um at uh double day who looked
five years into the future
and said um i think that
five years from now people are going to
be ready with all the new stuff that's
coming out and with this whole new
audience of uh millennials and gen xers
there's going to be an interest to find
out who nixon is and to have a one
volume nixon and uh doubled his name is
bill thomas he came to me and he asked
me whether i would like to do it and i
said took me about five seconds to say
yes
in your acknowledgments um in this book
which is a large book it's got over what
close to 700 pages but if you only want
to read the text the text is only 500.
so you can read it on the beach
it's aimed at people who want to read
this the whole story in a in a readable
way and then i had to do the 200 pages
of footnotes because
i knew that historians journalists
academics would would insist to see
where this stuff came from but also
because there's lots of interesting
questions that you answer that are there
are subtleties that the average reader
when they want to read a story about
dick and pat
julie and the war and watergate are not
going to want to get into a
five or six page debate over you know
what the role the cia was in watergate
so i saved that for the footnotes
in your acknowledgements um you start
off with this paragraph saying stephen
ambrose writing during the nixon's
lifetime took three volumes to tell a
story of the 37th president
and then you list all that's new which
i'll go over in a second to ask you
about it but how many books like this on
the whole life of richard nixon have
been
been written
since the turn of the century i think
there's only one person who has tried to
do a well-rounded biography and that was
evan thomas
everybody else wrote in the 1990s and
they were they were good books you go
back and read them now you're it's
amazing how much they were
able to
get to the essence of the man and uh um
uh find revealing stuff with several of
them he cooperated but people like tom
wicker he didn't cooperate and yet they
still managed to have a very good
perspective on it
in this list and you have a long list of
things that have come since stephen
ambrose
and you say he did he did not have
access to any but a few of the 3 700
hours of white house tape recordings
did you how much of those did you listen
to or read about oh how much fortunately
there are
three or four massive books of
transcripts
and several places online the miller
center at the university of virginia and
also luke nichter's website nixon tapes
where there's lots of transcripts you
don't have to listen to everything
then
there's two ways to listen one is to
listen for greatest hits and other ways
is just to pick a day and listen through
so there were points where i picked a
day and listened through so the spring
of 1973 i picked january first and i
listened through april the pentagon
papers days i did that that month in the
um
summer of 1971. other than that i i
jumped around because it's
they're very hard to listen to
the ones that are in the oval office are
on the telephone are crystal clear but
the ones in the executive office
building uh his hideaway office
um there's the clattering cups he
murmurs he turns away from the
microphone
it's just a bad technological setup and
so it's much more frustrating
again on the list the 400 oral history
interviews of nixon's friends and
families conducted by whittier
colleagues
when did that become public i became
i think it's in there but it's just uh
within the last two or three years and
what was unique about the winter college
oral histories it was great because uh
whittier was where he went to college
and they went out and they talked to all
his old
quaker relatives all the old neighbors
from yorba linda where he grew up on the
farm uh all the people who used the
store
in whittier
that his father ran on on the highway
outside of town and so it was
i think i hope
that the opening chapters that capture
the early richard nixon and the the
formation of his character
are made far far richer because of these
oral histories it was they're just a
huge treasure trove try to come back to
this of course but uh nixon's grand jury
testimony from from the alger hissing
watergate cases
how did that become public and when um
i think both of them were the result
were the result of court decisions i
know the nixon one was i'm
the the alger hiss one is fantastic
because
it's a very contentious debate over
whether his was a spy and what nixon's
motives were and lots of questions about
what happened when in the in the in the
progression and here you have nixon and
whitaker chambers who was the person who
accused alger hiss of being a spy and
hiss
and all the congressional aides and
investigators all called before grand
jury and you know told to raise their
hand on the penalty of perjury and
saying exactly what they did over the
previous six months um so it's it's it's
to me
contemporary testimony given under oath
is about the best you're going to get as
an historian far better than memoirs or
reminisces 20 years later what are your
conclusions about alger hayes i think
absolutely he was a spy were you ever a
doubter
going into it i had to try to
keep an open mind but i had happened to
have a neighbor in kensington who wrote
some of the
books about the winona project which was
a secret american uh eavesdropping
case where they broke the russian code
and found traces that showed that that
no no um
we can look it up okay uh
another thing on the list h.r holloman's
diaries or the transcriptions of henry
kissinger's white house telephone
conversations all of which have since
been open to scholars and when did you
see that and that and did you use those
two sources
again nixon is so wonderful
to do as a biographer because
there's nothing more revelation more
revealing than
haldeman's diary which he kept
faithfully every night and wrote down
almost
everything that happened during the day
and what nixon said and what nixon's
mood was during the day
and then you have henry kissinger who
has his brilliant analytical mind and
he's a wonderful writer
and
put together three volumes of memoirs um
almost immediately after he uh he left
government service and so those are
they're just magical sources that um and
and you could just go back to them time
and time and time again what book is
this for you
third the third the first two were about
i did a biography of speaker tip o'neill
and then i did a biography of the great
defense attorney clarence darrow where'd
you go to school university of virginia
where'd you grow up
um huntington new york and then
rockville maryland how long did you work
for the denver post
i worked for the denver post twice each
time five years stints i worked out
there in denver for five years i went to
the boston globe for almost 20 years and
then i came back and worked for the
denver post in washington and how long
have you not worked for a newspaper uh
since about 2003 i think the buyouts
began the newspaper industry began to
to crater and i had the first book under
my belt and decided that
i would try to do this full time
in your book you make a particular point
of the importance of the following
comment that richard nixon made in the
david frost nixon interviews back in
1977 this is only 25 seconds
i don't go with the idea that there was
that what brought me down was a coup
a conspiracy et cetera et cetera et
cetera
i brought myself down
i gave him a sword
and they
stuck it in
and they twisted it with relish and i
guess if i had been in their position
i'd have done the same thing
from what you learned how long did it
take david frost to get to that point
that was at the end or almost to the end
of the interviews because nixon
opened up the interviews um
almost like a filibuster i mean i think
the first question
that frost asked was about the tapes and
then he went into vietnam and nixon just
talked on and on and on and there was
great frustration on the frost side that
they weren't
pinning pinning him down i think they
knew that they were going to get to
watergate they knew they didn't want to
be
filibustered the way he had done it on
vietnam and and frost does this
wonderfully dramatic thing where he
takes his clipboard
and puts it down on the ground you can
see it in the in the tape and says
mr president you know i'm going to put
this aside i'm just going to let you
have a chance to to say something that
you're going to be very sorry if you
don't have it if you don't really say
this and come to grips with what you've
done to the american people and it's a
great great movement
not as great as the final
goodbye in the
east
east room of the white house that i
think is one of the greatest moments of
american political history bar none did
you ever meet him
richard no i did not the closest i got
was
as i opened one chapter on his
inauguration
he's driving down
pennsylvania avenue with open top
limousine waving to the crowds and all
of a sudden there's a bunch of anti-war
protesters
start throwing cans and rocks and they
had to button nixon back up inside the
limo
and so his presidency got off to a rocky
start because of vietnam and i was there
as a not as a rock thorough as a
spectator
in the crowd and that was the only time
i ever saw him in person
frank nixon his father you have a lot in
your book about him where did you learn
it
mostly from the oral histories from
whittier there's another set of oral
histories from
california state university at fullerton
and it's amazing how many times you come
across the word belligerent stubborn
rude
it just was sounded to be a very
unpleasant man and and richard nixon was
a very sensitive guy
and very sensitive child had two
brothers die in as a youth
and i think that he in some ways was
bruised by uh
by that dad
this fella named rick pearlstein wrote a
book called nixon land and in it he
talks about the very
sturdy um
political trope that
all politicians are trying to
prove that they're as good that as their
saintly mother believes they are in the
face of skepticism from a father for
whom they can never win his approval
so how did you
go about doing this i mean physically
where were you
it's a nightmare if i had gotten the
contract three years earlier i could
have done all the research
30 minutes from my house everything was
at the national archives
in
greenbelt maryland
and in
those three years before i got the
contract
everything was packed up and moved to
yorba linda california to the nixon what
was then the nixon private library and
now has become a national archives
library and so i spent lots of time in
the extended stay motel in yorba linda
so of all the things that you got access
to what what probably
either changed your mind or made the
biggest uh impact on you
the biggest news nugget
was
finding that you've had robert carrow on
who does that's the great series of
books on uh lyndon johnson and he gave
me great advice that somebody had one of
his old krusty editors had given him
which is turn every page
and when you get what you think could be
a good vein
keep going even though you're finding
nothing great and several years ago i
think about 2007
something that nixon had fought for
years to keep private which is his
personal
and political papers from the campaigns
were finally released to the public and
they set out there in uh yerba linda and
if you go through them
they're you know page after page of
holdem and saying um you know okay this
is how we're gonna deal with the bumper
stickers or this is what the polls show
in alabama or this is
where we're going to go next week
and
but if you keep turning the pages as as
bob told me
i came across
this section of of notes that haldeman
captain what what he used to do is he
would sit down with nixon like you and i
are except hulman would have a yellow
pad
and everything the next one would tell
him to do
hauled him right down on the yellow pad
and then he would make the phone calls
to put the
machinery in operation and he'd put a
big check mark next to it when it was
done
and so here was a yellow pad where
alderman
writes down
in the midst of the
october 1968 we're going to monkey
wrench lyndon johnson's peace initiative
this is something that had always been
rumored and bits of pieces had come out
over the years but
nixon denied it at the time to lyndon
johnson and he denied it to david frost
and he denied it to his biographers
always said that he had never played any
role in doing this
but in fact he had used
a go-between a campaign aide named anna
chanel
and had her communicate to the south
vietnamese that they would get a better
deal if they held
back from the peace process
and he got elected and they did he got
elected
and the war went on now
it probably went too far there to leave
the impression that
the war would not have gone on if he
hadn't done this we don't know that
but certainly lbj thought there was a a
decent chance that a peace deal was
possible
and whatever nixon did to disrupt it
i make the argument in the book that
this was far worse than watergate giving
the great loss of life that followed
in your notes long long answers no but
in your you know in your source notes
you say that and channel wanted a job
and didn't get it yeah yeah where did
you find that do you remember again
there was a whole section of not just
haldeman's scrawled notes reflecting his
conversation with nixon but also
it shows a sort of
degree of self-consciousness because
haldeman had collected all the
additional stuff together and so there
were mo's and there were um there were
time slips showing the number of phone
calls that went back and forth between
the nixon campaign and anna and uh it
had all been nicely put aside and
nixon's lawyers had made sure that we
didn't see it for four years
again this is a lot of personal stuff um
and i found it
new but it's in from other books that
you also went to but this is one is from
historian irwin gilman and you say
positive things about professor irwin
gellman
as one of the more foremost one of the
foremost authorities on richard jackson
who is he oh herv is this a wonderful
man who has taken it upon himself to
write
richard nixon's history in in government
and politics starting with a book called
the contender
uh and then he just did a book called
the apprentice and the
princess and the president or the
president of the apprentice and the
president about nixon's vice
presidential years um and he probably
has gone through you know you asked me
how many pages i've gone through well
erv has probably gone through three or
four times as many as i did and uh
he knows the collection in your belinda
backwards and forwards he's a wonderful
guys
great help to me and other nixon authors
who invariably are told well you know
why don't you ask irv where that kind of
stuff is and we do and he and and he's
gracious and he helps us and what would
you put him on the list of people that
have uh and the importance of the people
who have done books on richard nixon
given good health and
and he and he fulfills his
um uh goal which is to chronicle all the
way through the end of the presidency i
think this will be something comparable
to carol's work
here is um
this is from his book as you mentioned
the presidency and the apprentice and
this is all this is very old stuff it
goes back to the 50s gelman notes nixon
was taking three equinil a tranquilizer
during the day
he was also
taking deximil
a stimulant that could elevate mood and
lead to psychic
dependence
during the evening he had two or three
drinks
before going to sleep he had half a
doridin a potentially addictive drug for
those who had trouble sleeping his
physicians also prescribed the
barbiturate secondhal sikanol or seconol
in the 1950s and early 1960s these and
other medicines were often prescribed
for depression sleeplessness and fatigue
that's heavy stuff
well
two things one is nixon was a very
tightly wound guy and in the in the 50s
he was treated rather badly by
eisenhower and so he was always
worried his rise was so quick he went
from nobody to the vice presidency in
six years
and he was overwhelmed by it and
and thrown into this huge battle between
eisenhower and joe mccarthy
so it's not
a surprise that he took to
self-medicating himself or going to
doctors when he had these symptoms of
tension
and and being prescribed these medicines
on the other hand
if you remember
um
the famous jacqueline suzanne naval
valley of of the dolls
in the 50s and 60s this is what
americans did they took a lot they
popped a lot of pills and they drank a
lot uh all the presidents before nixon
were very proud of their of their
ability to to drink or to mix a cocktail
for their guests
so drinking and and the use of
tranquilizers and sleeping pills is very
much more i think as common then as
maybe the anti-anxiety drugs are um
today
as you know i'm reading from the source
notes at what point in the process did
you write all these source notes
i i made this i make keep making the
same mistake over and over again which
is not doing them while i write
the book and then i find that i have to
dig back through the files and because i
i think that i've done enough on a
footnote
then i find out that it didn't exactly
get the date right on that particular
letter and i have to go back and do it
over again so each time i get a little
bit better at it the next book i swear
to myself i'm i'm going to have them all
done when the text is done it seemed to
me that this was unusual your source
notes that they were more narrative than
normal and longer than normal were you
aware of that when you're writing them i
like that and i have a um
a direct editor um chris popolo who
encourages me to do that she likes that
too it's for people who
like the extra what's the
the phrase in new orleans langnet the
extra little
taste uh after you finish the book you
can go back through there you can find
out
about the cia a little bit more about
watergate more about nixon's father and
uh it fills out stuff without blocking
the narrative well here's a note on page
to the reports nixon was fortifying
himself with liquor that fall
uh his daughter julie said this the
drinking rumors were the most persistent
perhaps because it seemed he was
drinking a little more than ever he had
before but at dinner time when he was
trying to unwind he still adhered to his
self-imposed coat of no alcohol
on nights he was attending receptions or
dinners nor did he drink during the day
and then you go on the next page to
include this on alcohol see telcon
meaning telephone conversation with
kissinger and snowcroft
on october 11th
uh
he said the switchboard just got a call
from 10 downing street to inquire
whether the president would be available
for a call within 30 minutes from the
prime minister
the subject was to be the middle east
kissinger can we tell them no when i
talked to the president he was loaded
uh where did that come from i mean how
do you how do you get access to the
telephone conversation
that was a result of a court case filed
to get these kissinger
telecons as they're called
i think
it was filed by the national security
archive um or maybe a public citizen
but they got access to
thousands of pages of
what would happen is when kissinger's
national security advisor would have a
conversation with a foreign leader
he would have a secretary on the phone
taking down notes and this was a common
practice that went back
through
as long as there's been telephones
but kissinger fought very hard he wanted
them
kept under his control throughout his
lifetime
these good government organizations went
to court and they filed suit and they
won access to them again
you know within the last decade how
extensive was the drinking
it was a problem winston lord who
probably i you know if i had to pick one
person on the great scale of reliability
um he was one and len garment was
another i mean just just bryce harlow
was a third people that when they spoke
to me or
just
it was either that i agreed with them
exactly or they spoke such sense
that i was over i was overwhelmed by by
listening to them and winston lord um in
a marvelously long oral history that he
gave
um said yeah it was absolutely a problem
uh we shouldn't over exaggerate it but
it was a problem how many
how many people were you able to talk to
that were close to richard nixon
i talked to um
probably a dozen
one of the problems is is that i'll tell
you a story i talked to mel laird who
was his secretary of defense
and as i'm talking to mel mel
i i said well you know
you were a close friend of jerry ford
who succeeded nixon and pardoned him and
you're a close friend of nixon and did
you play any role
in nixon's resignation and he said oh
yeah yeah yeah he said i told nixon that
he would be pardoned
now everybody and their brother has
denied throughout the years that there
was any deal between jerry and dick that
if he resigned he would he would be
pardoned and here was mel there
in his mid 90s
telling me this and i asked him to tell
me it again he told me again and finally
the third time i said okay
you know
mr laird you know you're telling me
something that's going to be very
controversial
um because there's always both
presidents always insisted that there
wasn't a deal and now you're telling me
that you were conveying word that nixon
was going to get a pardon if he resigned
and laird stopped and he said oh
i predicted
i wasn't conveying word from jerry i
talked to the two of them and this was
my conclusion that i predicted so what
do you do with that then do you do you
put that in the book and you make it a
selling point that you've gotten proof
of a deal or do you realize that a 95
year old man doing his best to remember
these things
over the years having written a memoir
which doesn't say this at all may have
been mistaken but let me jump in with
another source note on another page
pardoned by ford on the same issue after
consulting with nixon hague advised ford
more than a week before the resignation
that the president expected to step down
gave him a whole week
at the same meeting hague presented ford
with the option of pardoning nixon ford
seemed amenable haig then went back to
nixon and gave him a report on the
conversation nixon subsequently resigned
but both hagg and ford insist no
explicit quid pro quo was struck where
did you find that i think
i think there were lots of not uh nods
and wings
um
i think everybody knew what was
had a good idea about what was going to
going to happen and in fact there was a
big there was a congressional
investigation after
after the pardon and all of nixon all
excuse me all of ford's aides over then
and since have all testified to this
meeting between ford and hague and
exactly what happened and how after
jerry finished talking with hague they
all went to him and said my god you
can't say that you've got to call him
back and say you're not
dangling a pardon
it's a big long convoluted um history so
the simplicity of what mel told me was
that oh yeah i was a go-between and i i
passed the word assurance to dick that
he would be pardoned would have been a
nice new piece but
you know you asked me how many of the
people that were close to nixon i talked
to
i wasn't quite as
enthusiastic not enthusiastic i wasn't
quite as diligent in going out and
talking to
um
these old guys because i i questioned
basically their memory
having done the book about clarence
darrell i have a great skepticism about
um testimony from from memory and uh by
the way tip o'neill clarence darrell and
richard nixon which was the most
fun interesting
uh
you know tips always is the the oldest
child so i'm always going to
like tip clarence daryl i i just adored
the personality of the man and nixon was
by far the most fascinating it's just a
great
intellectual challenge and also i grew i
mean you cannot be honest and go to
richard nixon's life and not
have much more sympathy for him because
he really did have a tough life and he
really was
trying to be a good guy
and
and yet he had this part of his
character this great shakespearean
fatal flaw that brought him down
this is from your source notes
politicians have been known to
exaggerate
this is you saying this now politicians
have been known to exaggerate and nixon
was a veteran liar
definitely i mean he once told len
garman you're never going to succeed in
in politics because you're just not a
good enough liar
nixon was a great
high school debater
and in high school debate you have to
and college debater and you you have to
take both sides of an argument you have
to be able to stand up one day or one
round and argue the positive and then
later that day you have to be able to
argue the negative and it gives you a
such a flexibility of mind and such a
a willingness to see that
that facts can be turned in your
advantage
and nixon throughout his political
career was one of the best at that i've
always liked
trying to see how his actions could be
explained in a way that would turn the
tables on the other guy and uh and if if
if that meant line then that meant lying
here's another one from your source
notes i leaked everything
nixon told henry kissinger and haldeman
july of 1971
convict the sob and the press
that's the way it's done
yeah that was during the pentagon papers
um case
daniel ellsberg a whistleblower
had taken the secret history of the
vietnam war and he had given it to the
new york times
and uh the great irony there and the
great revealing thing about that story
is that
it didn't go up to the nixon years it
just was about the johnson years and the
kennedy years it was awful on the
democrats and their first instinct at
the white house was
um leave it alone let the democrats tear
themselves apart over this and yet nixon
because it was the times because it was
a threat to his further conduct of the
war
because kissinger egged him on
he just launched himself into this fight
they didn't have to fight
he lost it
and
in the process he had this big
anti-leaking drive that brought in this
group of men called the plumbers into
his white house
and it was those same plumbers who
ended up being the guys caught at the
watergate
as i said at the beginning this is not
meant to be an interview from start to
finish i'm jumping around all the time i
just tell that to folks that can go out
and buy your book and get the whole
story but this is another thing that i
didn't had not heard nixon was off again
source notes nixon was offered the
chairmanship of the dreyfus corporation
and a chance to serve as commissioner of
major league baseball
see nixon gannon meaning the interviews
between frank gannon and richard nixon
he got sixty thousand dollar advance for
six crises is one of his books when
before he was elected president
uh of which twenty thousand was paid to
the researcher writer alvin moscow
one of the several aides who helped him
um
dreyfus corporation did
the driver's corporate he was he was
friends with
mr
and uh his name is his first name
escapes me right now um and uh the more
interesting thing to that one is that
i'm preparing um a speech i have to give
in boston
at fenway park
and it's going to be about nixon and
sports nixon was a huge
sports fan and there's this one great
moment in the midst of the watergate
crisis where
a reporter asks him at a at a press
conference or or in a
a chance encounter
who he thinks the greatest baseball
players of all time were and nixon
launches himself at camp david and pulls
out all the
there's no internet in those days so he
pulls out the books with all the batting
averages and and he
makes not one list but two lists one is
is his
b4 integration and the second one is
after integration um after the baseball
was integrated by his one-time good
friend jackie robinson um
hunter thompson who hated him the the
the gonzo writer who hated nixon over
politics uh once did a uh a car ride in
his limousine with nixon and they talked
football um the whole time and and that
after the afternoon or in the next
dispatch hunter thompson wrote boy you
know he's not so bad a guy he really
knows you know what linebackers do and
what makes a good linebacker versus a
good safety and he seems to have
mellowed and and so anyway nixon in
sports is fascinating he probably would
have been far overqualified to be um
commissioner of baseball but um
it was in which is why he turned it down
no doubt you also said that he got six
hundred thousand dollars in the frost
interviews that he did um that was a
very long time ago in the 70s but then
this uh footnote money was momentarily
an issue when still in office nixon told
ehrlichman that writing a book was quote
unquote agony
but that corporate law was degrading
and the idea of a former president
accepting honorarians for speeches or
for going on television is abhorrent to
me
it's very it is very ironic that the
president who's most known or not maybe
not most known but is often known for
that wonderful
clip where he says i'm not a crook
people have the right to know their
president is not a cook well i'm not a
crook
was also had these incredibly high
standards when he left office he did
have a reverence for the office probably
because
he had he revered ike and he had watched
eisenhower be president
but there were things that he was that
he was not going to do because
they would they would tarnish the office
and that was one of them he never took
he never took money for paid speeches
here's another story that you recount
from his in the arena book spun an
egregious whopper apparently seeking to
secure himself a place among the vietnam
veterans who claim to have been spit at
when they returned home from the war
do you remember that story yeah um
the story as told in the arena was that
he went to williamsburg virginia for a
conference and while he was there this
young girl came up to him her face
consumed with hate and broke through the
secret service and and spat at him in
the face um and that was his
recollection in in the arena
and i i went looking for it i couldn't
find it in all of the
news coverage of that trip and so i
figured that you know
maybe it happened in private but
probably it didn't happen at all and
then i found a memo from pat buchanan
sort of a memo to the record which
described not a young girl but
a young man
shouting from
the crowd how does it feel to be a war
criminal
and
at in williamsburg at this conference
and so i mean i think that when we
talked about nixon lying and
exaggerating that's a great example of
how what actually happened planted a
little seed in his brain that over over
time became um
bigger and grander and conveniently put
him with the returning pows and the
veterans of vietnam as having been the
victim of being spat on has anybody else
uh from your
uh
research in the last uh 50 years or so
lied from the presidency besides richard
nixon absolutely in fact
you know we had three of the most
amazing presidencies in a row
you know
100 years from now i think they're all
going to be grouped together as the cold
war presidents and they'll all be ranked
as to how good they did and since we're
still sitting here we're not incinerated
radioactive ash they did a good job and
they you know all together they
protected us
they
made these huge swings back and forth
did some
horribly aberrational things like you
know hiring them off jack kennedy hiring
the mafia to try to assassinate
fidel castro
the full report of the church committee
which went into the
history of administration after
administration that spied on
americans opened their mails tailed them
bug bugged their telephones
um
and not just
you know not just the mob but but you
know
peace activists people like john lennon
and even richard nixon when he was out
of office was was was spied on by one of
these one of these programs
um so i think that that people will look
back and they will say
okay they were under tremendous pressure
and there were these awful things but
you know
lincoln suspended hyposcorpus during the
civil war and adams signed the alien
sedition act so you know at times of
crisis presidents
maybe we can make excuse this behavior
but i mean in in the case of just
veracity and and
morality i don't think that you when you
look at roosevelt truman eisenhower
kennedy johnson
um
and nixon that there's there's a huge
bit of difference as to
what they would do to advance their own
political future and to protect the
country he was here 25 years ago on book
notes and
i had a question about the media
and his attitude and then you've got a
interesting source that i'm going to ask
you about in a moment let's watch that
and then we'll
delve into this more
did you ever
ask yourself why so many in the media
are against you
well they didn't agree with what i stood
for this is long before watergate
the his case particularly was very
difficult for the media they all thought
he was innocent and if they didn't think
he was innocent they didn't want him
exposed because it as one individual
said is that it would be a reflection on
the uh on the foreign policy the
of the roosevelt administration which of
course was not my goal at all
uh and so with that it was difficult not
that i didn't have
many friends in the media but media
people
while they try to be objective many of
them do
they also have strong convictions
and
frankly
they are
they generally are not particularly
enamored with the
conservatives
as i am
uh even though i am probably more
reasonable than some of the
conservatives that they go after
what do you think
i really can't argue with
any word that that he said except he
doesn't tell the whole story uh it's a
fascinating relationship um and i and
several times during the narrative i
break and i do a couple of pages about
where where he stands right that at that
moment because it really did twist his
perception it really did feed his
paranoia
over the years but what was really
interesting is that
he he first ran in southern california
as a conservative and at that time the
los angeles times was was the
conservative voice in the country and
dominated southern california politics
and they heavily promoted him all the
way up um into the senate the united
states senate so
he had a very jaundiced view about a
free press a free press to him
was there either for me and they're
going to advance my career because
they're conservative or they're against
me and they're liberals who are going to
tear me down because of that i think
that's reflected a little bit in that
back to your source notes page 632
this is a little complicated but uh
years later amid the watergate scandal
republican chairman george h.w bush
produced affidavits alleging the
democrats sought to eavesdrop on nixon's
hotel room before the second
presidential debate
the evidence was inconclusive but it
would not have been terribly unusual
throughout the 1950s and the 1960s
electronic eavesdropping was viewed as
somewhat underhanded but trifing but a
trifling offense
cbs
had bugged the closed door sessions of
the credentials committee at the 1952
republican convention journalist jack
anderson was caught bugging during the
sherman adams case and nbc newsmen
admitted they bugged a private session
of the democratic platform committee in
1968. harold lipset the chief
investigator for the watergate committee
resigned from that role after someone
remembered that he had been convicted
for an illegal
bugging in 1968 all these incidents were
quickly forgotten and where did you find
all that
um
nixon's defenders over the years
have attempted from time to time to
assemble
collections of
past
misdeeds to show that nixon was the
victim of a double standard and i think
their argument is very
well taken
but he carried like
he carried everything i think a step
further a step too far
and and he wasn't frankly he wasn't as
as good at it um i mean all these people
got caught so they weren't very good at
it either but the way that the watergate
burglars were their team was assembled
was uh clumsy they were they were
cynical burnt out former intelligence or
fbi agents who were
supervised by
uh young men on nixon's staff who just
wanted to be as one of the famous quotes
go
the cat that brought the dead mouse to
the to the president's door so they're
all eager for advancement all trying to
be more macho than the next guy
the amazing thing about
all of watergate is that it was about
something as small as a bugging compared
to that history that you just read which
was sort of accepted practice
but that j edgar hoover saw that times
were changing and that these kind of
practices were not going to be seen
in the 60s the way that or the 70s the
way they had been seen in the in the uh
in earlier years and hoover pulled back
and said now we're going to you know
we're not gonna do these black bag jobs
anymore and so that's what led nixon to
have to bring that capability in house
and and in the end got him into such
trouble
did you talk to either one of his
daughters
i didn't talk to either one of his
daughters julie was very nice and that
every once in a while i would just
find something where i just had to have
an answer that only she would know and i
would send her an email and she would in
most cases she would write back and she
would say
there's a famous photograph in there
at the eisenhower inaugural where david
eisenhower is there with his grandfather
and julia's there with her dad and david
is looking at her it's very cute
considering knowing the history that
years later that they would fall in love
and marry
and i just had to write her and say what
was going on and she said well i he's
not looking at me the way you think he's
looking at me he's looking at me because
i had been in a sledding accident i had
this big black eye
and he was just sort of staring at this
little girl with a big black eye and if
you look very carefully in the photo
then you can see that she did have a
shiner so it's uh she julie was very
gracious in doing that she she loaned me
a picture for the book of nixon after in
his exile years and uh
the three nixon women i think um
if you go to the dictionary and you look
up long suffering their pictures should
be there
their mom and and julian and and trisha
i wish
i could understand their paranoia at the
way there
that they have after seeing how their
father has been treated but they really
could do much better
to follow the example of um
the truman family the truman family
opened up the vaults to harry of harry
truman's letters to his wife david
mccullough went in there and wrote a
book that instantly elevated harry
truman 10 steps up the presidential
ladder and will be forever this great
valentine to harry truman and someday
they will do that and someday somebody
will write a book better than mine
because it will have nixon's diaries
more from nixon's diaries it will have
more letters to from julian and and
trisha but
right now they're still um they're still
pretty burnt and they still
have a
no interview no
no help
why in your opinion does
julie talk
more than tricia
i think it's a it's a case of
personality
there's a wonderful conversation that on
the tapes where nixon and haldeman are
analyzing
the two personalities and and they agree
that you know julie in her way is so
bubbly and such a nice person that the
country uh loves her whereas tricia is
more
of a pristine beauty
and and and nixon says yeah yeah you
know trish is more like like me more
contained
more alone um and uh and you know julie
is the one with the million-dollar
personality that's my understanding i
don't think that's entirely true but
that's the way the perception yeah my
understanding is that edward nixon his
youngest brother is still alive and i
think i saw you quote him in here uh in
one of the notes did you meet with him
nothing nothing was i mean having said
what i just said about mayor laird and
the other 90 year old guys
nothing was more important to me than
that that day i spent with with ed nixon
because first of all he looks like
dick
um and you and he walks like dick and
and you get a sense of from him of what
that family what the nixon men
were like and what that family was like
and um he's a geologist a scientist and
uh i believe and so
um
doesn't have the most sophisticated uh
view of politics but has this um really
sort of keen nixonian
wry sense of humor
and it was it was very enlightening to
me best bester knew you i did and i
which is one another reason why i wish
julie would and trisha would sit down
and just do oral histories for the
library i mean if you don't want to talk
to
um 60 minutes sit down and do an oral
history for the library what'd you think
of the frank gannon interviews and how
many of them were there there were there
were
six six nine something like that but he
was his
a friend of and
it was the
ghost
ghostwriter
frank doesn't like the word ghostwriter
he was the ghost writer the the the
writing assistant for the memoirs
along with diane sawyer
and um and helped him write write their
memoirs and then they decided to
have nixon sit down and and frank got
him
to open up on many subjects it's the
first time it's the only place that for
example i remember nixon calling himself
paranoid
about leaks and about the press here he
is and just a short clip about the
resignation
after the speech i went over to the
residence henry was very very thoughtful
he
he came up to me and he said he'd like
to walk to the residence with me he said
i've always done this after the big the
important speeches
and as we got to the door of
the residence he said
mr president
history is going to record that you were
a great president
i said henry
that'll depend on who writes the history
went down to the lincoln room and made a
few calls to people
heard the chanting outside
reminded me of the vietnam days except
this time the chant was jailed of the
chief
jail to the chief
didn't bother me however you know after
all i'd been heckled by experts
you know there's a footnote in there and
i'm sorry i don't have it to read it you
know what's great about that clip is
that
he
loved the fact
that
he will always be famous
even as the only president to resign
even recounting those than those those
events he's delighted by the idea that
this nobody kid from yorba linda
so dominated the world stage and so
dominated history in in the 20th century
you know even though it ended badly for
him so badly for him and caused him such
grief and almost killed him
um you know
there's a part of nixon who was who was
like boy i showed him
but there is a footnote in here again in
the back where you say is quoting henry
christopher saying he didn't like him
that kissinger didn't like him didn't
like him kissinger had uh had a um well
first of all kissinger was
a great example of nixon being able to
either instinctively or or
brilliantly find somebody and pluck him
and make him his tool
and nixon and kissinger probably lasted
with haldem and probably lasted as long
as longer than than anybody and
kissinger was very very good at what he
did
i'm
i have a basic argument with the two of
them over vietnam that i carry out
throughout the vietnam chapters but
um there's no denying that
they
saw
the split between russia and china the
soviet union and china and decided that
they would exploit it the way that they
did and this led to the opening of china
and changed our world forever and
probably did i mean nixon's goal in
china was to give us um a couple of
decades of peace and he probably gave us
maybe 50 years of peace but if
henry kissinger is quoted as saying he
didn't like him he'd been he was a phony
the whole time then because all the
tapes show him
kissing up after speeches and mr
president you're the greatest
it's somewhere in ken in in those three
volumes of memoirs gishner actually says
it you know perfectly christian has it
has a great way of like witty
self-deprecating nod towards the obvious
um and and he makes a crack somewhere
about the fact that yeah you know the
worst thing about these tapes when they
come out it's going to be that they're
going to show me as a kiss up and uh and
in some cases he was just he was just
awful and it was it's a flaw of nixon is
that he that he needed this too
did he did he talk to you
no kissinger um did not
um talk but
again with
with henry kissinger he's written
probably five or six volumes of books on
the next juniors and and talked
repeatedly given speeches and so um
there was a limit as to what i could
have asked him that could have
um you know should i've asked him one
more time are you a war criminal
roger stone who worked for richard nixon
and has a huge tattoo on his back of
richard nixon's face was here recently
talking about his own book
let's watch what he has to say about
richard nixon and donald trump
the first person to
imagine a trump presidency was not me
but was former president richard nixon
i was working for nixon doing political
chores in his post-presidential years
and he met donald trump in george
steinbrenner's box at yankee stadium
and they hit it off and he called me the
next day
and he said well i met your man
i got to tell you he's got it he could
really go all the way
roger was very
i just sat down and roger private is not
roger public and rogers private sat down
with me and gave me a very helpful
interview about his experience with with
nixon but um that's the difference i
mean private and public well roger in
his books roger on on television is more
of a showman
um but he can also speak
quietly to you and talk to you about
nixon with with depth and insight um i
don't believe that i think that's you
know like i told you about clarence
darrow i think you know people over time
can convince themselves to believe what
they want to believe
you don't believe roger stone's story or
you don't believe the fact that
richard nixon said that
yeah i don't it's just it's too it it
it's a stretch for me to believe that
roger stone would end up working for
donald trump all these years later and
remember that
richard nixon met donald trump in a box
at yankee stadium and came back one day
and said he's going to be president one
day because american history is filled
brian i can't tell you hundreds of
relatives all
sat in their kitchen one day and said to
aunt bertha across the table
that young deck he's a he's a bright guy
and someday he's going to be president
everybody predicts
presidents are going to be presidents
and a lot of your wittier uh oral
histories
have people quoted about
that and after the fact yeah
um
again you didn't answer a question i
asked you earlier
no it was really about where did you
write this what was your what was your
base
my base was here i live uh uh right off
the bat way near the mormon temple
and uh
but how did you set it up did you all
this material you had to know and index
a tremendous amount is online
i mean somebody the other day wrote an
uh
an entire book
um on i can't remember what the topic
was but only online and they sat in
their kitchen and all the research that
they needed was online and we're getting
there
all of clarence darrow's papers became
put online after unfortunately after i
went around the country
finding them
but
in in 20 or 30 years the problem is is
that
they can't put everything
that's at the nixon library online it
would it will take 200 years
so what you tend to do is you tend if if
you're too
lazy you'll only do the online stuff
you'll only do the oral histories that
are online you only do the c-span i mean
i spent hours watching c-span archives
you have a lot about nixon on c-span
and
but if you only do that then you don't
get
into some of the texture that can only
be done by turning every page so
um but there but
in both the darrow and not so much in
the tip books but the darrow and the
nixon book an awful lot is online all
right maybe unfair question last
question
uh
if you were going to pick a chapter in
this book that everybody should read
that is new different unusual which one
would it be
um
it doesn't have the anna chanel stuff
which is the the big historical
piece of the puzzle that i contributed
but i think the the the piece on the
um cambodian incursion in the spring of
1970 that chapter it's relatively short
um it's got lots of new stuff it's got
some great quotes from the tapes that i
came across that nobody had had gotten
before
i like that one and i also i mean i also
love the 1946 campaign
which opens the book
john aloysius pharaoh as we said better
known as jack the book is called richard
nixon the life and we thank you for your
time thanks for reading
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
q a dot org q a programs are also
available as c-span podcasts
[Music]
if you enjoyed this week's q a interview
with john farrell here are some other
programs you might like brought to you
today by your cable or satellite
provider
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening
i'm i'm not sure the microphone is on
can you hear me
well
excuse me
you can okay great
good evening my name is vanessa beasley
and i'm the dean of the martha rivers
ingram commons here at vanderbilt
university tonight it's my great fortune
to welcome you to this panel this
wonderful discussion that we're going to
have about the presidency of richard
nixon and the lessons therein and i'm
also happy to invite you to a
conversation we'll be able to have uh on
that on that same that same theme and
that same question before we get started
in earnest though it is fitting that we
take a moment to remember the space that
we're in and who founded it tonight we
were gathered in the first amendment
center here at vanderbilt university
which was founded by john siegenthaler
for those of you who may not remember mr
siegenthaler or be aware of his legacy
john siegenthaler served for 43 years as
an award-winning journalist for the
tennessean
at his retirement he was editor
publisher and ceo
and in 1982 siegenthaler became the
founding editorial director of usa today
and served in that position for a decade
stegenthaler left journalism in the
early 60s to serve in the u.s justice
department as administrative assistant
to attorney general robert f kennedy
his work in the field of civil rights
led to a service as chief negotiator
with the governor of alabama during the
freedom rides
and during that crisis while attempting
to aid freedom riders in montgomery
alabama siegenthaler was attacked by a
mob of klansmen and hospitalized
in 1991 siegenthaler founded the first
amendment center where we gathered
tonight
housed at vanderbilt university with the
mission of creating national discussion
dialogue and debate about first
amendment rights and values
and one of the first amendment rights we
enjoy is the opportunity to look
critically at our own past as citizens
and members of the u.s democracy and so
tonight to lead us in that discussion
we're very fortunate to have john
farrell
author of the book richard nixon the
life
i'm hot off the presses literally and
available in the back of the room
john farrell is the author of three
biographies
first of the great american attorney
clarence darrow which won the los
angeles times book prize for the best
biography of the year
second of speaker tip o'neill
which won the lyndon johnson foundation
award for the best book on congress
and third of richard nixon the book
we'll be discussing tonight which will
be published on march 28th
somehow we already have copies
he came to biography after a long career
as a newspaperman most notably for the
boston globe and the denver post
and in the late 1970s as youngsters
john and one of our other conversational
partners david marinus competed as
reporters while covering the maryland
legislature for rival newspapers
mr farrell recalls that he did not fare
especially well in that competition
to mr farrell's right is david marinus
david is an associate editor at the
washington post where he has worked for
40 years
he is the author of 11 books including
biographies of bill clinton barack obama
vince lombardi and roberto clemente and
a trilogy of the 1960s
the final book in that series was once
in a great city a detroit story
winner of the robert f kennedy book
prize
marinus also is the recipient of two
pulitzer prizes and was a pulitzer
finalist three other times for his books
in journalism
this semester for the third time we're
so welcome we're so happy to welcome him
back to vanderbilt as a visiting as his
distinguished visiting professor where
he's teaching classes in political
biography and america in the mccarthy
era he and his wife linda have welcomed
vagabonds spending time in washington dc
madison and wisconsin and here in
nashville he is known here mostly for
being the father of andrew marinus the
author of strong inside the book about
vanderbilt athlete and alumni
perry wallace and race and sports at
vanderbilt that has become the freshman
book reading for the second straight
year
our other conversational partner tonight
will be professor thomas schwartz
schwartz is professor of history and
political science at vanderbilt
university
educated at columbia oxford and harvard
universities he is the author of the
books america's germany
john j mccloy and the federal republic
of germany
and
lyndon johnson and europe in the shadow
of vietnam
and with matthias schultz the edited
volume the strained alliance
u.s european relations in the 1970s
schwartz has received fellowships from
the german historical institute the
norwegian noble institute the woodrow
wilson center and the social science
research center
he served on the historical advisory
committee of the department of state
and was the president of the society of
historians of american foreign relations
he is currently finishing a biographical
study of former secretary of state henry
kissinger so with all of the overlapping
interests and expertise i'm sure you'll
join me in welcoming our distinguished
conversational partners there'll be a
portion of the evening when you too will
be invited to be a conversational
partner but with no further ado let's
get started discussing lessons from a
failed presidency
[Applause]
thank you vanessa and i'd also like to
thank
ingrid commons for helping to sponsor
this event along with the
political science department and the
history department and the provost's
office
and thank you to the audience
in the front row we have a few
interlocutors including my great
colleague bruce oppenheimer political
scientist
and three of our students jude cohen
frank spence and joey medlen who will be
part of this
we're going to do it in sort of four
parts first i'll i'll talk to jack about
the making of the book then
professor schwartz and i will we'll talk
about the substance of the book then
we'll have some questions from from
these four in the front row and then
open it up to the audience
you know
as we used to say about richard nixon or
tricky dick
he's back
tanning rested
and
dead um
but who knew that he would be so
relevant again right awful so i'm going
to save jack the trouble of
you know when he was on campus today he
was sort of
and when he was writing the book he was
realizing that he was writing it for the
students of today
who were
you know to whom nixon was like the
teapot dome scandal of our generation
that far back
um and so
you know even the students parents were
just kids when richard nixon was
president in some degree
so i'm going to save him the trouble of
a couple of bare facts for anybody who
doesn't know
richard nixon was born in 1913 he died
in 1994 at age 81.
he was a congressman from california
served on the house on american
activities committee then was elected
the senate the same year as jfk john
kennedy was
served briefly in the senate and then
was vice president for eight years under
dwight eisenhower ran for president of
1960 was defeated
uh two years later lost his running for
governor of california and said you
won't have dick nixon to kick around
anymore
and then he came back
was elected in 68 lasted five years and
then
resigned
after facing articles impeachment for
the watergate scandal
i know that
as an author myself all authors
most hate the question
why
why why another or why this so i'm not
going to ask that
no no i don't want to ask him so i can
ask how
it's really the same question but in a
different way how did you come to this
book and how did you conceive of it
okay there
has been a tide of new nixon material
since around the turn of the century all
the tapes
are not totally all the taste but all
the tapes that are ready for public
consumption have been released
uh
hundreds of thousands of documents
transcripts of henry kissinger's
telephone calls
450 oral histories of nixon's childhood
friends and family
all came out in the last
10 15 years and the last
major
biographer to take a shot at this was
back in the
early 90s when nixon was still alive and
had no use of the tapes whatsoever so
double day my publisher
thought that there was room for a new
up-to-date single volume
nixon biography and asked me if i would
want to do it and i
took me that long to say yes
because this guy had been such a
fascinating uh political leader and such
a major
part of my life in my late teens and
early 20s
but you ask how and i went into it
feeling
that i couldn't do one more hatchet job
on richard nixon nobody would want that
what i had to do was try to write a
straight down the middle biography and i
found that he was much more than the
caricature he was in many ways a fellow
that you could
have empathy for and
one of the things that i enjoyed most
today was talking to some of your
students david and finding that that
came through in the writing of the book
and how did you go about researching it
that's a sad story because
i live outside washington dc and all of
nixon's documents and tapes were seized
by the federal government and they were
put in the national archives about 15
minutes from my house
until three years before i got the
contract for the book and where they
were moved to yorba linda california
which is about as far away from
washington dc as you can as you can get
and so i spent many many hours
in yorba linda staying at the extended
stay motel
and trudging in every morning into this
basement vault and just turning page
after page of uh old nixon records
the easy part of the research was that
so much is being put on the internet
these days that i could do a lot of
research uh at home and i predict a day
probably in the next 20 years you've
probably experienced this as well
where somebody could write a major
biography of a major public figure and
never have to change out of their
pajamas
and i'm always fascinated by the process
of organizing such voluminous material
how do you call and decide what what's
going to go into this single volume
biography and how did you organize it
well the most important thing to me was
to make it readable
and the second most important thing was
to aim it at that huge
part of the american population that had
not experienced nixon and somewhere
between two thirds and three quarters of
the american population either were not
born or were not living in the united
states at the time
nixon resigned in 1974. so that was a
big audience of people that didn't know
anything about his first congressional
race or his time as vice president with
uh eisenhower and so
i really if if anything this book is
weighted away from the presidency and
towards his development as a as a man
and as a political figure as a husband
um and uh the trade-offs that he made as
he went through his career before he
became the the tricky dick that we all
know and and loved
um if you get down to the actual
technical part of
research
biography is very easy or maybe it's the
easiest
book length craft because
the plot is written for you already it's
a person's life from birth to death and
chronology is your is your best friend
and you just start
making chronologies i start off with
decades and before too long that the
decade long chronology is is uh too
extensive and i have to separate it into
five year groups and by the end
in some cases i've got it down into six
months blocks of computer files
and in there i try to
have a mix of
nixon's voice which is very important
the voices of other people who knew him
and can analyze him for us
and the documentation that
for historians is very important to say
well this is a good well thought out and
thorough book was there uh something
about nixon that you became obsessed
with and you wanted to solve that you
were most curious about
um
there were there are there i spent an
inordinate amount of time dispelling
conspiracy theories
because there are many conspiracy
theories about watergate about why the
break-in was passed was plotted and some
of them have gotten very elaborate
and i felt that i needed to sit down
with nixon's uh spokesman from the nixon
foundation
and have them challenge me um time and
time
again
to make sure that the story that it's in
the history books is is correct so that
was my my great white whale was to was
to feel confident that the watergate
chapters um stood up and little did i
know that they would have such relevance
as they have today
but um if there was anything that was
that was a subsidiary goal that was it
which is the elephant in the room
appropriate since nixon was a republican
and so is donald trump
um but i mean it's just
since uh january when a story broke
about your book
and his involvement in 1968 and since
uh then trump's election our
rise to the presidency in january 20th
uh there's been a constant drum beat of
comparisons between richard nixon and
trump
and i'd like to sort of have you go
through the before you share the
contracts and where you see the
comparisons to be invalid um
the most interesting one
is that right before richard nixon was
elected in 1968 he was accused by the
previous president of interfering with a
foreign power to
hack the election
and one of the things i found turning
page after page was a set of notes
from bob haldeman who was nixon's chief
of staff which for the first time put
the words of that conspiracy in nixon's
mouth he had denied it all his life he
denied it to david frost and the famous
frost nixon interviews
and so if there's a little bit in the in
the book that that
moves history a little bit forward um
it's that piece piece of the puzzle and
what happened was that uh lyndon johnson
wanted to end the war before
he left office and he had a peace push
on in october of 1968
and the nixon campaign heard about it
and they had an intermediary go to the
south vietnamese and say hold on don't
go to the talks you'll get a better deal
once nixon is elected and lyndon johnson
heard of this and if you listen to the
johnson tapes on online you'll hear him
call nixon
guilty of treason and
all sorts of other bad stuff he had both
the south vietnamese embassy and the
nixon campaign
tailed to some extent or the other
so there was a
sort of a
debate over surveillance with that
incident as well
and in the end um
richard nixon was was elected because
the south vietnamese
did not go to the peace
process and it sort of made johnson look
like who already had a credibility
problem and it made it look like he was
being clumsy and manipulating the
election himself
johnson then faced a very similar
choice as president obama did when he
got word that there had been contacts
between the trump campaign and russia
and johnson made the same decision that
obama did which was not to go public
with it because of the great shock this
would be
and because they did not have the
evidence to nail it down and directly
tie it to the candidate so that's
probably of the very many
comparisons
that's probably
the one that jumps out with of course
the
additional sweetener
that in both cases
um we were involved in a
we're talking about a break-in at the
democratic national committee in
watergate it was
actual burglars and of course in
russiagate it was hackers so
what about in a larger sense of their
morality their
veracity
and all of those sorts of things they
both had trouble with the truth they
both were very accomplished liars in
fact nixon was famous for telling one of
his aides len you'll never be very good
in politics because you're just not a
good liar
and so
we have that going for us
they both have press secretaries that
have been scorned by the press as being
um
uh untruthful or manipulative and
have become
sort of very quickly jokes on
primetime television
but most of all they both
had what i call the politics of
grievance
they reached out to people and they
touched their fears in times of economic
or
national stress
and made them feel that the elites and
the
two coasts did not paying attention to
them that they gave minorities and jobs
and and money in advance ahead of them
that nobody cared about them and and so
that same sort of
way that you saw donald trump tap the
midlands last year in the election nixon
was very deft at that as as well nixon
was a little bit
i think more subtle
because he had george wallace
running as an independent candidate for
president who was saying everything
blatantly
um and so nixon came come across as sort
of the
the
candidate who
believed in a lot of things that that
wallace did but didn't have to say it
because
he could he could seem like the moderate
voice of reason and so his campaign was
very different from
from uh trump's but both were aimed at
this
sense of resentment in the voters
there's a wonderful quote in your book
describing richard nixon is
as uh going up the walls of life with
flaws
and that evokes so many different images
but i wanted to take it back to where
that started what what his sense of
insecurity where that began and why yeah
how it played out through his political
yeah
i had a very hazy
concept of nixon's childhood and his
upbringing
before i went into this i sort of knew
that he came from
uh some something of an impoverished um
home and uh that he had shown remarkable
resilience and audacity in in winning
his race for congress and race for
senate in california
and they were clouded by
allegations of red baiting
both the house and the senate race
and then of course there was the famous
checkers speech when he was picked by
eisenhower's vice presidential candidate
and accused of padding his own
pockets
with money from wealthy donors
and went on television in what may be
the most brevora television
performance ever
and talked about
his income his wife's cloth coat uh and
the family's little dog checkers which
he
actually reached out to the american
people on television and said no matter
what they do to me we're not going to
give up the dog because the girls love
it and
so it was a very maudlin
performance
so this was all part of the nixon
caricature and what i
as i began to look into his childhood i
found out that it was really it was an
awful childhood his father was a very
unpleasant brutal man
his
mom was a very sort of cold and reserved
religious figure she would
retreat into her closet to pray when she
wasn't working the long hours that her
husband required at the family store
and as nixon once
confessed never in my life did my mother
ever say
that she loved me
and then he would immediately follow
that up and say that was just not the
quaker way
but that was a pretty damning i think
admissions where his where his uh uh
what his home life was emotional home
life was like
um he had two brothers die in his uh in
his childhood a beloved younger brother
was stricken down instantly another
brother caught tuberculosis and died
over a six-year period
and that death the cost of caring for
that brother ruined the family finances
and
ruined dick's dream of going to an ivy
league college so he always had this
chip on his shoulder that
an inferiority complex but also an anger
at those like say jack kennedy who had
everything given to him
whereas nixon had to scrap for for
everything that he got
but the whole experience left him very
insecure and that insecurity was his
great tragic flaw he was never satisfied
with even his greatest accomplishments
you can go to the white house tapes and
you can hear him belittle his china
initiative or belittle the strategic
arms treaty that he struck with the
soviet union and kissinger once uh henry
kissinger once said um uh you know
imagine how great this man would be if
anybody had ever loved him
and elliot richardson another cabinet
member said no if anybody had ever loved
him he never would have been the success
that he had because it was that that
drive and insecurity that made him such
a um a formidable politician
i think you find that to be true with
most politicians that their weaknesses
are their strengths and their strengths
and their weaknesses and it's really
they're inextricably linked and started
to separate them i know the same thing
was true with bill clinton absolutely
people would say if only
you know if only he didn't have these
flaws but it was that same
drive that led him to the flaws and led
him to his successes as well yeah that's
that's certainly the case with lyndon
johnson as well who suffered as well the
resentment of the east coast elites and
the northerners who looked down on him
and thought of him as a yokel so i i i
see that
you know we we set the title of this as
lessons from the failed presidency but
there are many people who would argue
that richard nixon actually was
extraordinarily successful in foreign
policy
that he had a record in changing
american foreign policy that
really few presidents have matched and
i'm wondering um uh as you approached it
or came into it um
did you find yourself uh
being struck by by his successes were um
what what were the revelations or the
the insights that you gained and looking
at that
um the one insight that i gained
immediately was that for all his
brilliance he did not
recognize the us failures in vietnam
and vietnam will always be for he and
lyndon johnson the a black mark although
as as time passes
via the effect of vietnam recedes in our
society and it seems to be
moving towards being put up on the shelf
next to the the korean war um
without the same passions that it
engenders in in my generation
um
the greatness i think of nixon was that
um he had the ability to look out first
of all he had the
drive from his mother's side of the
family the quaker side of the family to
try to bring peace and he's constantly
talking on the tapes about you know
we can get
10 we can get maybe 20 years of peace
and in the middle of the
cold war in the middle of the nuclear
arms race 20 years of peace was a great
deal in the end he
sort of brought us 50 years
of peace
if you're talking about great power
confrontations and he had the ability in
1969 to look across the ocean and see
that
russia the soviet union and
red china were at each other's throats
and that
that this was a time where
the united states could do a triangular
diplomacy
if only the chinese would let him
make the approach and he and
kissinger summit to uh who was his
lieutenant
um made made this very dramatic secret
approach to the chinese carried it out
with a lot of clandestine
uh uh hugger muggery with you know
turned up trench coats and secret
airplane flights and and sunglasses and
uh um kissinger went to beijing he
talked to ma uh talked to ciao and lai
and came back and said yeah they'll see
you and then you had this amazing trip
of an american president
a right-wing american president
um as mr spock says you know it's an old
vulcan proverb that only nixon can go to
china but uh um that actually that word
actually came from
mao mao
is the originator of that phrase he said
only nixon can do from the right what
the men of the left
cannot
so you had nixon the anti-communist go
to china and come back and tell the
american people all right this is this
is in your interest and they believed
him because nobody would ever accuse
dick nixon of being soft on
on communism
he also had
what i found was was fascinating he
wrote this article in
foreign affairs magazine before he ever
took office in which he talks about
um this revolution that is coming and
it's coming in the uh
countries are in the pacific rim like
singapore and and the philippines and
and japan it's going to be all about uh
computers and independent creativity and
so he had this ability in 19 this was
1967
to look far in the future and and and
see what was going on and and and the
only way i can forgive him for
keeping the vietnam conflict going on as
long as it could is i think that
part of him believed that he needed to
buy time for these fledgling democracies
to take root for for democracy to take
hold in places like malaysia and
thailand and the philippines um and uh
but he but yeah i would
you actually make an argument that
i had first heard from walt rostow that
in effect the united states bought time
for southeast asian countries and it is
part of that and i do i i'll press you a
little bit
what was
what would have been a politically
viable
route
on vietnam when he came into office well
as you yourself point out
in cambridge massachusetts or in boston
people voted against unilateral
withdrawal as late as 1970. um so
what was a policy that could have worked
yeah uh i think that he could have
the technical answer is he could have
followed the french algerian model which
is to negotiate a piece that that uh
called for a long withdrawal of the
french forces from algeria left algeria
independent and also took care of the
algerians who had sided with the french
and by doing it over a long period of
time it could have gotten those
algerians that could have gotten the
vietnamese who supported the united
states out but the short answer to the
question the flip answer is is that
this genius who saw and made this trip
to china
who
if only nixon could go to china well
maybe only nixon could have
gotten up there on january 20th 1969 and
said we're going home
and american people trust me because you
know
i'm dick nixon and nobody hates the
commies more than i do but this is in
our interest so that vision that he
showed
in other areas he didn't show in vietnam
and then as you go through the through
the war when he can't get a quick
success full ending to it you see awful
cynicism where he actually stretches it
out
causing you know more and more deaths
expands the war into
cambodia many of these things
individually can be argued as the right
decision at the time
but then
the the
division that he sparks at home helps
lead to the pentagon papers helps lead
to watergate and the whole thing
collapses and we lose everything we lose
prestige we lose the south vietnamese we
lose
a million or two million cambodians and
a million vietnamese boat people and the
united states goes into this period this
funk for another six years where our
foreign policy is is is is moribund and
our defense
policies is suffers the fallout as well
so i mean
i don't think you can divide vietnam
from watergate nixon himself called
himself the last casualty of vietnam
vietnam
and i think that that that's true so
historians looking back i think are
gonna
as i did lump the two together and say
you know he he bungled it how much
better would it have been if if he had
just you know
said at the beginning you know let's go
home yeah
um and and it's not my war anyway this
is a democratic it's a democratic war
yes or no in the sense that he had
always supported it um one of the things
the uglier aspects of nixon is of course
that the tapes revealed a man who who
often said in anti-semitic things and
often talked of jews in very negative
ways on the other hand anyone who looks
at the middle east would argue richard
nixon perhaps was the most devoted
defender of the state of israel and i'm
wondering what you see as his legacy
there yeah
the phrase and yet is used a lot in my
book
because nixon does have these two sides
and he has this incredibly dark ugly
side
and in a few places is it as ugly as in
his anti-semitism
and yet
um henry kissinger was jewish arthur
burns appointed federal reserve board
chairman which jewish alan greenspan and
len garment were jewish so nixon
if you were on his side
nixon was not as ugly he reserved the
real ugliness for
the the
owners and editors of the new york times
or the federal judges in new york who
were jewish who
ruled against him in the pentagon papers
but that definitely that ugliness was in
there and uh to his great
dismay if he's
as somebody said the other day he's
looking up at us
the tapes are going to forever
um
cloud history's uh verdict of i know
what was the second part of the question
well in the middle east
yeah part of that was that this was
great power politics the russians were
trying to to use the israeli egyptian
war to to
increase their influence in the middle
east and so he was
sort of alerted to this because
he was a cold warrior and this was all
about the soviet union throughout his
entire presidency um but on the other
hand um he thought the israelis were uh
he liked israelis he thought they were
spunky he loved golda meir um you know
they the israelis sort of fit his image
of underdogs it was you know um and and
militant underdogs who fought
um and in fact the the defense
department came to him
and they said or the state department
came to him and said we can get these
arms in there
but we have to like be careful and fly
only at night because if the rest of the
world sees we're arming the israelis
it's going to uh affect our calculations
and and nixon said wait a minute you
know what are you talking about they're
saying well maybe three three flights a
night and he said three flights a night
i want you to fly everything you have
because all we have to
have one plane land with stuff for the
israelis it's the same as having 50. and
uh so
the american arms lift to israel was
astonishing astonishingly quick and and
golda meir said that he probably had
saved the state of israel at that time
so if he was truly
truly anti-semitic
um
like like a hitler he never would have
done that but
i think his anti-semitism was
very ugly but it was also a part of the
parochial
southern california outback where he
grew up and and also probably a product
of his father's ignorance
yeah
i'm gonna ask one more question and then
we'll go to the
front row um i'm fascinated by the
the nixon kennedy
uh relationship uh they came into
uh
the senate at the same time they were
sort of buddies in a funny sense
um
and yet by 1960 right this
powerful
uh sense about
losing that election to jfk gave him the
resolve
to never be outdone by a rival's dirty
tricks again sort of setting up all of
the disaster to come yeah talk about
that definitely
they both came in in 1946 and and
because they were freshmen uh they were
put on same committee and they were
the chamber of commerce of mckeesport
pennsylvania had them come up and debate
a labor bill and then they took the
train back to washington together and
they'd both been in the navy in the
south pacific at the same time
they later talked it over and figured
out that they may have even met
and uh that our friendship grew and
jfk respected nixon for beating
um jerry voorhis who was a new deal
stalwart and uh and nixon basked in the
fact that the rich ambassador's son
was his friend and the two of them
the nixons were invited to jack and
jackie's wedding so they were they were
they were close friends in fact in i
think it was 1958 one of nixon's former
staffers went to massachusetts to run
for secretary of state or some lower
office and asked nixon to come campaign
and nixon said no i can't go into
massachusetts because jack's running for
reelection and people will ask me
whether i support his his rival the
republican and i'll have to answer
candidly on behalf of the republican and
i i can't do that um so he stayed out of
the race great to his aides great dismay
so when the kennedys then turned their
money and their charm and their
ruthlessness on nixon in 1960
and d right up to election night where
he believed they stole the election in
illinois and texas
it it seared him not just as a bad loss
but also as a betrayal
um this was somebody that he really i
mean if he
loved is maybe too strong a word but
maybe it's not he really um
admired and had great affection for for
jfk and just to be treated like this to
nixon was was a a betrayal and uh from
that point on uh nixon was just
determined that he was never going to be
out tricked again
um and uh there's a great scene from the
68 campaign where
um a secret serviceman is walking down
the aisle of the plane and he looks and
there's
nixon in his in his uh
um
seat in the aircraft going
gotta be tougher got to be tougher gotta
be tougher
uh and and there was that kind of
feeling that comes out in the tapes and
you see watergate eventually happen and
the tragedy arrive
joey
from suburban chicago from suburban
chicago um like what professor schwartz
was saying it's we're talking about uh
lessons from a failed presidency and one
of the hallmarks of nixon's presidency
that you can see today is the
relationship with the press uh nixon had
a directly adversarial relationship with
the press that might be understating it
and then the role of the press and his
direct downfall
and i'm wondering looking from then to
today if there's anything nixon could
have done using his political
gamesmanship to use to change that
relationship with the press and if that
could have changed the outcome um and
then speaking more broadly if there's
any long-lasting implications of that
relationship between the press and the
executive branch that we can carry on to
today um nixon had several problems with
the president in fact i stopped the
narrative for only two things
in in the book i stop it to talk about
nixon in the press and i stop it two
times to talk about nixon and civil
rights because these are really good
indications of of his character
he grew up
or entered politics as the favorite of
the los angeles times which was then a
very conservative newspaper in southern
california
and came to believe that the game was
rigged that
newspapers declared favorites and there
wasn't any uh tradition of objectivity
in the reporting and when he got to
washington he expected the same thing so
when there were critical articles
written about him
he saw
them as
enemies from the other side he had never
actually run into them in california but
now
here they were and they were against him
and believe it or not
large segments of the american media are
left left-leaning and liberal
and
they didn't like nixon from the get-go
they didn't like him because he had
defeated liberal heroes to get to
washington and they didn't like him
because as soon as he got to washington
he exposed a
former assistant secretary of state as
being a soviet spy who was a darling of
the left and so right from the beginning
there was this confrontation
another man like jfk
more secure in his shell
may have been able to endure this but
not nixon it naught at him he was always
insecure
and that insecurity no matter what his
accomplishment it was never enough for
him because he felt bad about himself as
a person and and and felt that it would
never last he would never be happy and
um so the press was this constant
irritant to him
the the files are filled with advice
from well-meaning aides reporters
friendly reporters saying stop go to the
press bar have a drink with these guys
you know make make connections this is
awfully self-destructive behavior
but it's true in the middle of the
uh
at the end when at the end of his of his
first term when the um
uh
peace negotiations with north vietnam
hit a bump he ordered a massive bombing
of north vietnam called the christmas
bombing and so on the tapes there's this
amazing transcript where
kissinger comes in and they're talking
about military and strategic and
diplomatic maneuvers and then all of a
sudden
nixon starts screaming at henry
kissinger the press is the enemy the
press is the enemy the press is the
enemy the professors are the enemy the
media is the enemy write that on your
blackboard 100 times henry um and it
just it would erupt like that over and
over and over but he didn't tweet it he
didn't tweet it yeah and kissinger
ignored it so that's right
and he didn't say we the press was the
enemy of the american people
which was which is this which is a step
higher um and in nixon's case of lying
nixon had like a
a basic respect for the intelligence of
the people
that his were clever lies
trumps are such blatant lies like you
know paul manafort is was not a major
player in the trump campaign or i've
been uh wiretapped by um barack obama
that it's that it's almost it's it's
almost surrealistic it's almost a a an
insult
that nixon never would have would have
done like that he was uh
i give you an example when they came
back from china they lost they had lost
the chopsticks
and somebody said well you know we
really want to preserve a set of the
chopsticks for
um the nixon library and nixon nixon
simpson
grab any pair of chopsticks
people will never know
so he did not have a basic you know
reverence for truth either
frank since so i attended a talk a few
years ago and it was a guy from
nixon's administration and he was saying
there was a kind of loyalty within the
administration that when he was being
sworn in he felt like he was swearing to
nixon and not
you know to be able to pledge allegiance
to the country
so how do you think nixon was able to
establish that kind of loyalty nixon's
favorite football coach was a guy named
george allen and george allen was a
coach for the washington redskins what
george allen was famous for
it's a common tactic that in its coaches
but george allen was famous for carrying
it to the extremes of making the other
team the enemy making the other the
other team the bad guys um and that was
one thing i think that nixon tried to do
with with his people
he had a very nice long much much much
longer honeymoon with the press and with
the public than trump is having um his
his honeymoon lasted almost six or seven
months
where he was given a lot of leeway
people were patient they wanted to see
what he could do about
about vietnam so
he didn't really turn paranoid until the
fall of 69 when the students got back on
the campuses and they began to protest
the war again
and then the following spring in the
spring of 1970 you have the shootings at
kent state and the paranoia really
ratchets up
and the hatred really ratchets up but
all of that created sort of a siege
mentality in the white house
and so not only was nixon demanding
personal loyalty but you began to feel i
mean at one point they took city buses
and encircled the white house with city
buses so the protesters could not you
know get in and burn and raise the white
house um that's how paranoid they were
about it and uh
and that paranoia in 1971 they begin the
tapes and you hear that paranoia over
and over and over again so
um you know he he had a shot he had six
or seven months and i don't mean to make
it sound like part of that honeymoon
was because there was someone even more
famous than him coming to washington at
the same time
vince lombardi oh
i thought you're going to say elvis
david broder wrote a column is that
right yes about
nixon being overshadowed by another
new presence in town
jude code
so thank you so far this has been great
i am wondering and speaking of
lessons of a failed presence presidency
in the hopes
that now we will have a successful
presidency
what lessons
would you wish to impart from your
knowledge of nixon to our current
president in terms of
isolating and going after groups in the
way
that nixon did in his involvement in the
house on american activities committee
yeah
i think
at this point donald trump still has a
chance to have a very successful
presidency we are so early in the in a
four-year term
but
the question with trump is not that he's
not getting good advice because you can
see it like in the state of the union
speech or um two weeks ago that he can
he can do the reagan-esque
performance if he has to but he has this
his own character flaw which is he has
trump has to be trump and that means
that i have to tweet outrageous things
which means that you know my
inauguration crowd has to be the biggest
inauguration crowd
if he had the self-discipline and
control of somebody like reagan he could
i think he could turn
it around very quickly and you would
have
a democratic nightmare and that an
effective republican president right now
with both the senate and the house
in republican hands and now the
supreme court going back to where it was
you know you really could have great
great changes but right now the greatest
obstacle to
trump's success is donald trump himself
so maybe from that perspective
you don't want him to learn the lessons
or you do or you do
and we're leaving the democrats out too
i mean we're giving them a pass they
haven't they've been very silent
watching
the trump administration self-destruct
but
you know
they
they could be
trying some basic pavlovian techniques
to push trump over over to better
performance i think and they're not
professor oppenheimer
jack
you did a very nice job of discussing
nixon and civil rights
and if there's a new nixon
in running for president in 1968
there's also a new nixon on civil rights
transformed from the nixon
who in the eisenhower administration
along with the attorney general are
really pushing as hard as they can on
eisenhower to take a stronger pro-civil
rights stand
and helpful in passage of the 57 civil
rights act
to nixon who to get the republican
nomination in 68 and then to win the
election uh first gets in bed with strom
thurman and then
allows more of what we call the southern
strategy
to
to prevail
um
is that change something that you can
see coming where does that fit in
in the anal analysis that you do of
nixon yeah like i said i stopped the
book twice the narrative the flow of the
book twice just to like zero in on where
we are on civil rights right now because
i think it really illustrates
his character
all i think politicians are expedient to
some degree
nixon was almost totally expedient
and yet in the 50s
in part again beca and yet uh in part
because um he wanted to get the black
vote in the cities against whoever he
ran against in 1960.
um he reached out to martin luther king
and made friends with martin luther king
he was a good friend of jackie robinson
he attended black social events in
washington dc with no other white
politician he was the first
american vice president to visit
a black family in their home there's a
wonderful letter he
the in whittier the the barber shop um
had a shoeshine man and the shoeshine
man had a daughter and she went to i
think howard university in columbia law
school and then
passed through washington and dick nixon
took her to lunch in the um
senate dining room and that must have
been you know
a shock just by itself there in the
early
1950s and then he writes this wonderful
letter
to a friend of his back in uh in
whittier saying you know it really just
it so affirms my faith
in this country that you know the
daughter of the shoeshine boy from
whittier
is now graduating
from columbia law school a person of
such great of grace and intelligence um
and now has has a um
a positive future ahead of her so so the
feelings were genuine um he really did
take that quaker
abolitionism
[Music]
from his mother his his grandfather had
died at gettysburg fighting for the
union army and there was a rumor in the
family that
the quakers had worked the underground
railroad in indiana so he was he really
was he he had
joined clubs that admitted black members
in the 1920s
um so he really was colorblind
as far as martin luther king could say i
could see and in 1957 when the first
civil rights bill hit the floor of uh of
the senate he was it's
one of its mightiest champions as as you
said
um and then in the 1960 election
um he
loses the black vote because he falters
at
a key moment martin luther king is
arrested
[Music]
and on a trumped-up charge and sent away
to a prison in rural georgia and jack
kennedy and bobby kennedy write the
write the governor get in contact with
the governor of georgia intercede with
the judge in the case uh called uh
martin luther king's wife to
comfort her um and uh make a big impact
with the black population in in america
and the the nixon campaign says no
comment
and martin luther king who had once
said that if richard nixon is not
totally colorblind then he's the most
dangerous man in america because he was
so convinced that nixon was big-hearted
now decides that nixon is in fact the
most dangerous man in america because he
was able to put on this show
of sympathy and support but the first
time it actually cost him votes
he wasn't there when it counted
so then you move on to 1968 as you said
and ronald reagan is running for the
presidency and trying to get the
conservative votes from the south and
nixon makes a deal with strom thurman
and what came to be called the southern
strategy
in which he promises that the nixon
administration is going to
lay off the pro-negro stuff
and
hesitate on the integration of schools
in order to secure the southern
delegations at that convention
um and
then in his presidency
um he
does things like appoint southern racist
judges to the supreme court and
drag his heels on some civil rights
measures
and yet
when the supreme court finally comes to
him and says you have to integrate these
schools he puts together an amazing
effective plan with people like george
schultz and blen garment
and integrates the southern schools
probably more black kids in the southern
schools
got into the integrated classrooms
because of richard nixon than any other
american president so it's complex and
the only one guiding line throughout the
whole thing
is uh expediency i mean he did he did
this he said this is what i got to do
at the moment
the great tragedy of his betrayal of not
betrayal of civil right the civil rights
movement but of his switch
was that kennedy and johnson had put the
dignity of the white house behind the
civil rights movement they had aligned
uh the presidency with civil rights
which was
something that eisenhower had never done
and truman and
fdr had never done they they had come
out and said this is an american cause
that the presidency is
all about
and nixon backed off from that and so
all of a sudden the moral authority of
the white house was no longer with the
civil rights movement he started talking
about civil rights extremists and you
know the civil rights extremists who
want instant integration and force
busing are just as bad as you know the
clan
which is a
horrible
comparison but
again it was because he saw votes in the
south it was the first
not the first but a major step of the
way towards the total republican control
of the south
that you have now
there are so many um
aspects of
nixon's life from all the way through
the 20th century where you can just stop
and write a whole book about you know
from the mccarthy era to vietnam and
watergate
obviously watergate is the defining
issue of his political career
and how did you choose on what to pick
and choose what to write about to
navigate through that what sources did
you go to
um how how much did you draw
my colleague bob woodward and carl
bernstein in their work and yeah in
other scholarly works their files are
down at the university of texas and
they're very helpful there
the university of texas has all their
watergate
um interviews uh of the
from the sources who either released
them from the
off the record guarantee or have passed
away so i went down to
ut i i spent what was supposed to be a
40-minute interview turned out to be a
three-hour discussion with bob woodward
which was invaluable
for my previous books i had interviewed
ben bradley before he passed away so i
had a very good feel for um
for their work
a great admiration for it
but they were also
what they did what was so important was
that they kept the story alive until
um the other the like judge sarika said
later that the reason that he
i'm sorry i gotta slow down a little bit
um
so the break-in happens in uh 72 nixon
gets reelected despite the post's
reporting and then the burglars go on
trial before this judge called judge
sarika and jud sarika later tells
everybody that
he decided he had to tease a republican
judge but he had to take a tough stand
because he had read the posts reporting
that had raised enough questions in his
mind that he wanted them answered
even though the u.s attorney just wanted
a quick conviction of the of the
burglars and so judge sarika then
threatens the convicted burglars with
exorbitant long
prison sentences to force them to talk
and they crack and that's how the
cover-up finally
finally cracks
the thing that i was surprised about was
that the tapes show there's a famous
conversation that nixon has with john
dean
in march of 1973 when dean comes in and
says mr president there's a cancer on
the presidency we've been committing
perjury we've been raising hush money
we've been promising clemency you know
your top aides probably have to go to to
jail and john dean is saying this
because he thinks the president doesn't
know but the white house tapes show that
from
the second day after the
the burglary nixon was in on everything
he was constantly calling in haldeman
and ehrlichman and saying well you know
is magruder reliable is judd magruder
reliable is he gonna does he
will he will he commit perjury and not
in five years blab about it we'll you
know we got to keep
attorney general john mitchell um safe
because we can't afford to lose mitchell
how are we doing on raising the money
the money has to be raised um you know
let's hope that they wash that money
correctly i mean bob i mean and and it
goes on and on and on so by the time
john dean comes in
nixon knows everything except like
one little nugget of information the
exact amount of hush money that they
needed to raise that particular week
that's the only news in that entire
speech as far as i can i can determine
so he was
in the in the in the cover up to his
neck and
um his loyalists have attempted over the
years to try to say that it was that
dean
ran the cover up or that you know dean
and haldeman and ehrlichman betrayed him
um
the tapes don't show that the tapes show
that um right from the start
he was gonna play it
rough the way that they play it he was
gonna be tough tough tough and it was a
a terrible downfall
you want to take some audience questions
now
who's first
was nixon a wealthy man
at any time his life or actress
presidency was he a man of of some
wealth
he was
certainly not wealthy as a child had to
go to whittier instead of a better
school he got to go to duke law school
on a full scholarship
and by the time he did the checkers
speech
his his holdings as revealed then were
so meager as to be
that his wife pat was humiliated that he
was announcing how poor they were on
national
television
and
he made a little bit of money after he
lost in 1960 he became a
corporate lawyer
and lived comfortably for the rest of
his life but
nixon was never motivated by
great wads of money
he didn't want to worry about it because
that was a distraction from what he
really liked to dream about which was
political power and how he was going to
reshape the globe
and become this great hero but
many many rumors spread about hidden
nixon wealth after
watergate and uh
not true the only thing they bailed him
out was the he got i think six hundred
thousand dollars from david frost to do
those interviews and then he ended up
writing books for the rest of his life
to keep the wolf away from from the door
um so money was never a great motivating
factor which is interesting considering
he came from such a poor household
can you talk a little bit about nixon in
title ix
if you go out to the nixon library now
you'll see that there's a display which
lists all of the
considerable domestic accomplishments
of his administration um including
a volunteer army help me out here guys
the
establishment of the epa
the
clean air
act and one of the things that came up
to his to his desk was
this title ix amendment which said that
colleges had to
treat the
female sports programs equally with the
with the men
and the and nixon was a was a big
college football fan and he had lots of
friends who were coaches at notre dame
in oklahoma and uh elsewhere and they
all called him up and said this is you
know outrageous you know it's gonna
it's gonna damage all our sports
programs these gals don't wanna they
don't wanna you know all right some of
them can run track or play tennis but
you know you're talking about we gotta
soccer teams for them we have to have
equal facilities we know and so you can
hear this on the tapes nixon's saying
you know this is crazy why you know why
are we doing this why are we doing this
but they you know it was it was slipped
into another bill that was more
important that he felt he had to sign
and so he signed it and now if you go
out into the nixon library you'll see
that they have a display there that's
saying one of richard nixon's great
accomplishments as president was the
signing of title ix which is technically
true but
something that he had to be dragged
kicking and screaming to do
given the
conservative liberal dichotomy today you
mentioned that he
started the epa could you tell me what
the motivation for that was back then
yeah on
so he was inaugurated on january 20th in
69 and i think it a week later there was
this massive oil spill off of santa
barbara california
and it was heavily covered by the media
nixon was of course from southern
california himself
he flew out there he talked to the
people of santa barbara made a
photo opportunity
but this really ignited the
environmental
movement in the united states
and the republicans the democrats got in
a race or a competition as to who could
do more for the environment
and nixon
nixon won i mean of of if you if you
poll environmental organizations today
they will say that the number one
president was for the environment was
republican teddy roosevelt and the
number two president was republican
richard nixon
it wasn't just epa it was
clean air it was
coastal zone management it was
endangered species act i mean almost all
of the major environmental
legislation uh
was was signed by richard uh nixon at
that time
and by nick center signed by you know uh
both both
it was certainly driven and put on his
desk by a democratic congress but he had
aids like ehrlich men and a fellow named
john whitaker who were very devoted to
the cause and nixon had a basic sympathy
to the cause because he was an admirer
of teddy roosevelt he was from
california he was watching what
was happening in california with smog in
los angeles
and this oil spill and and
other cases but he could never
he'd never go as far as the democrats
and
and that began to frustrate him
and because he was a republican he had a
business constituency which wanted
things like the supersonic transport and
the alaska pipeline which he wanted to
go along with
um and so he never so he got frustrated
and there's a there's a great
tape
filled with profanity so i can't recite
it as i'd like to right now uh we're on
c-spoon but but um
it's from like i think it's from
1773 where he starts spouting you know
i'm i'm i'm not a liberal i'm a
conservative and all i get
on my desk is this liberal crap over and
over again all we're doing is we're
we're reorganizing the chaos a little
bit better you know this all this
environmental stuff is bull and
i don't know why you know i'm doing this
and and so there was that side
of him too so when the issue was hot he
was there
uh
in part it was expediency
and yet
um at one point they put on his desk um
a measure which said that um
we have all this federal surplus land
the military is downsizing we have
military bases who are being closed and
it really would be nice to have parks
for urban families and nixon remembering
his childhood and how a free park was
one of the few things that they could
afford um put his heart behind that and
so that was you know an example of once
again the this very complex character
with all these complex motivations
with an underlying sort of streak of
sentimentality
um and that's why he's he's gone down in
history and
will
always
be honored by environmentalists also a
fantastic fantastically admired
president um by native americans
um he had a football coach in whittier
college who was a native american and
nixon had this
uh great empathy for um
native americans and reversed there was
a horrible policy of assimilation that
he forced assimilation which his
administration reversed so if you go on
tribal councils out in the west there's
still pictures of richard nixon hanging
hanging on the wall
and we talked to one of the students
today who was uh from china
and we asked her where nixon's place was
and she said that well uh he's number
two
in your list of presidents and i said
after it was after george washington in
china richard nixon is the second best
uh president so um
he's slowly climbing up the c-span has a
has a a survey of where american
presidents are and how they rank and
nixon is you know he's jumped up from
the bottom he's somewhere in the low 20s
and probably stay there because of
watergate but um
but you know it's uh he i think he's
going to be endlessly fascinating just
because of
uh of the character that he was
before we get carried away with his
greatness
there was a a
columnist for the you told me today that
it's impossible for a biographer not to
develop empathy
about you
professor schwartz and i both read the
same column by an economist columnist
who wrote that in the end the presidency
is the wrong job for an amoral man
um you know you could probably make a
very good argument that
nixon was no worse than franklin
roosevelt except that franklin roosevelt
pulled it off
the job that roosevelt had to
do his
all the agencies with the three letters
that he
knew might not work
maybe they would work
um and then to take to prepare the
american people to battle the
totalitarian
governments in in world war ii
um took great cunning great expediency
um great powers of analysis great powers
of of leadership
a little bit of demagoguery
um so but those don't add up to
immorality or immorality i'm not sure
that a
i'm not sure this there's probably an
old
you know plato or
somebody like that argued this point but
i'm or maybe it's just machiavelli i'm
not so sure that total immorality is not
an asset for a political leader i think
that sometimes the morality has to come
from
the people to the leader and the leader
has to
pay attention to that but that
i think that
vision and effectiveness i think are
um
are truly important total immorality no
i mean obviously you
you can't go in that direction where
does nixon fall
oh he was he was pretty
he it's hard to find much that nixon
really really truly believed in
or wouldn't do
and
in in that regard he had the capacity to
have been a great president to pull off
things like the opening to china
but it was that same
lack of morality that got him in trouble
there's also there's also in your work
this idea that he was not ideological
now and you know that was actually
something i was thinking about when
you're talking about trump this there is
this option of someone who's elected who
doesn't have the ideologies of the time
and and dixon was of course someone like
that and it gives them wonderful
opportunities but also incredible
dangers i suppose yeah he didn't have a
firm rudder
um
what was i pat buchanan once wrote this
angry memo saying that we are neither
fish nor foul
we're somewhere in the middle and uh you
you are you're walking along the
ideological buffet taking a little bit
of this a little bit of that and the
conservatives in the country are are
getting upset
and right now mick nixon is like one of
our presidents who's a man without a
party the democrats and liberals have
never
fully honored him because of long
memories but reagan came in and the
conservatives took over the republican
party and uh nixon is is seen as a
squish as you know somebody who signed
things like created the epa and uh um
and so he sort of he lingers somewhere
in the uh um
his hope was to create a new political
movement and he just met because of
watergate yeah he was never able to
consolidate the sort of what we later
would call the reagan democrats and the
southern strategy and build that
majority right yeah to bring it full
circle what do you think or know about
what donald trump thinks of richard
nixon
um
i have heard and i'm not sure this is
reliable but i've heard that on his wall
in the oval office he has this letter
from richard nixon isn't that correct um
nixon had met him at some point
when he was still the donald
running around new york and being on the
front pages of the tabloids and uh wrote
him some sort of note which said you
know don you're going to go a long way
and whether or not it's it's in the oval
office or whether it's somewhere else in
the white house i think that he has kept
that and they certainly show it and talk
about it a lot
he could do worse but and and i think he
is doing worse
is he practiced
okay well um we'll take one more
question i'm sorry yeah
boy wait for the microphone please
i'm just curious did you interview um
nixon's daughters
or have a perspective on how being a
father
affected his outlook or if it affected
his outlook he was a very
clumsy
human being when it came to
interactions with fellow human beings
even his family
they would communicate a lot sometimes
with notes
slipped under doors at night or left on
pillows
i asked
julian trish if they would sit down i
think one of the great tragedies of
right now is that as far as i can tell
they have never sat down for a long oral
history about their dad
and so the insights that they could give
with the exception of julie's biography
of her mother
are going to be lost if they don't do it
julie wood if i was at a crisis point
and there was a question i had that only
she could answer
um we'd have an exchange of emails
and
she sent me a picture of a wonderful
picture of her of nixon playing the
piano for
his grandchildren and i could use in the
book so
it wasn't it wasn't totally
forced out but there's still an awful
lot of bitterness and um uh resentment
there about the way they've been treated
by the press and by biographers and
the intelligentsia
and uh so
no it's
it was a lost opportunity i went in
thinking that with my special
brand of blarney i would be able to have
this happen and it didn't happen this
middle name is aloysius
uh in my opinion one of the great gifts
of biography in particular is taking a
subject that we think we know well and
making it making him or her more complex
perhaps creating some sense of empathy
or understanding and so i want to thank
you because even from tonight's
discussion it's really clear that that's
the work you did in this book and i'm
sure we all look forward to
digging into the book and getting to
learn more about nixon so thank you so
much and thank you to our panelists and
to everyone who is here tonight to join
the conversation i would invite you if
you're interested in the book to step
out into the lobby where parnassus our
local bookstore has a has a sales table
waiting for you but again thank you all
for being here tonight and thank you mr
farrell for this provocative work
and i'll be happy to sign
he says he'll sign copies so that's a
pretty nice invitation thank you
[Music]
and check out all of the c-span products
next on the presidency
john farrell talks about richard nixon's
early life and career how they
influenced his presidency and he argues
ultimately led to his downfall
he's the author of richard nixon the
life
the smithsonian associates hosted this
event
it's my pleasure to welcome our speaker
tonight uh john farrell is an author and
contributing editor to politico magazine
in the atlantic
following his career as a journalist for
the denver post
national journal and the boston globe
where he worked as white house
correspondent and served on the
spotlight team
in his capacity as a journalist he's
covered congress the supreme court and
every american presidential campaign
from 1980 through 2012.
in addition he also served as a senior
political correspondent for the center
for public integrity a non-profit center
for investigative journalism in dc
in 1996 he received the gerald r ford
prize and the aldo beckman award from
the white house correspondents
association for coverage of the
presidency the first time anyone had
captured both awards in a single year
he's a frequent guest lecturer at
various universities including stanford
harvard
the military united states military
academy university of chicago and other
institutions abroad
he is the author of three books clarence
darrow attorney for the damned and tip
o'neill and the democratic century
tonight his talk focuses on his third
book about richard nixon
a
biography of the 37th president of the
united states
this book has won the pen america award
for the best biography of the year the
new york historical society's barbara
and david zelaznick book prize in
american history and was a finalist for
the pulitzer prize
after the program please join us in the
atrium where his book is for sale and
signing now please join me in a warm
welcome for mr farrell and enjoy the
program
thanks very much
that was terrific thank you
uh groucho marx used to say after that
kind of introduction i can hardly wait
to hear what i have to say
it's very it's a great honor to be at
the smithsonian because at a time when
history and maybe even
objective knowledge is under fire
um systonia systonia smithsonian is this
great wonderful institution asset that
we have
and uh just today i was
reading through the smithsonian magazine
website and they have this marvelous
story about how the black curator
of
an african-american museum in
virginia got together with the white
curator of the museum of the confederacy
and together
they sat down over beers
he had three great grandfathers who
fought for the south
together they sat down and they combined
their two institutions to this new
museum
called i think it's called the museum of
the civil war in richmond
and it opened up it's a marvelous story
i recommend that you read it like almost
everything in smithsonian magazine
but it's uh i think it's also very
it's a great
uh illustration a great example of where
we can go
if we forget um
a lot of the some will some of the
things that i'm going to talk about
tonight
thanks for coming out on a night where
you could sit home and watch on c-span
events very similar to those 50 years
ago
um
and uh um you know
one of the first questions i got asked
and asked repeatedly was why nixon now
and uh i was accused of being something
of an oracle when the book came out
right after
donald trump had
been elected
facing off against a special counsel
over a break-in
at democratic national headquarters
staging his own saturday night massacres
declaring war on the press and declaring
that the press is the enemy
accused of colluding with a foreign
power to illegally affect the outcome of
a presidential election
obstructing justice democrats muttering
about impeachment
as a friend of mine from the faculty at
the university of virginia told me we've
packed six years of nixon into two years
of trump
it's like nixon speed dating
and i feel a bit like um richard white i
know i don't know uh how many of you are
readers of the great oxford histories of
the american
of america but basically they take the
civil war the revolutionary period the
cold war and they give them to a um a
fantastic scholar and uh he writes a a
book of history about just this era and
and uh richard white got the uh
assignment to do the gilded age
reconstruction uh and the gilded age
from that 1870s to the 1890s and he had
a
reaction very similar to mine he said
i've written a book about a time of
rapid and disorienting change and failed
politics
and i finish it in a parallel universe
which reminds me of what harry truman
said which is that there's nothing new
in human nature
men don't change the only thing new in
the world is the history you don't know
yet
and we can be sure that somewhere
from his perch in the great hereafter
that richard nixon is looking up at us
now
and saying you see bob i told you they'd
miss me when i'm gone
um so why nixon why nixon now
um
well one reason
selling books is a commercial enterprise
and one reason is that we have this
amazing string of 50th anniversaries
this is the 50-year mark of the nixon
presidency
1968 the year that he was elected
began with the tet offensive in vietnam
senator eugene mccarthy's anti-war
challenge in new hampshire
robert kennedy entering the race
george wallace entering the race lyndon
johnson's abdication the murder of
martin luther king the murder of robert
kennedy and the huge
rioting at the democratic national
convention in
chicago and all that led up to
november 1968 when richard nixon was
elected and he almost didn't make it
he won by 500 000 votes in one of the
closest elections ever
and he barely clinched the republican
nomination
profiting mainly from the blunders of
his rival
michigan governor george romney
mitt romney's dad
was a republican front runner
until attempting to change his position
on the vietnam war he claimed that he
had been brainwashed by the pentagon
now romney was already considered a bit
of a lightweight and this did not
persuade a skeptical public that he had
the brains or the guts to be the next
commander-in-chief
and eugene mccarthy rose to the occasion
brainwashed he said when told of
romney's gaffe a light rinse would have
been sufficient
it was during that 1968 race on the eve
of the election that the nixon campaign
pulled off a dirty trick that i argue in
my book was worse than anything he did
in watergate
in october of that year lyndon johnson
announced that he had reached an
agreement for peace talks with the north
vietnamese
at the urging the soviet union
which was the north's armorer and
supplier the united states would suspend
bombing in southeast asia
and in return the russians promised
lyndon johnson that hanoi would engage
in productive talks productive is the
word the russians used
but then there was a hitch the south
vietnamese refused to join the talks
johnson was furious and you can hear
these on the
johnson tapes
which are online uh all the more so when
he learned that anna chanel a nixon
campaign official had been heard
on an american wiretap of the saigon's
embassy in washington
urging saigon to drag its feet they
would get she promised a better deal if
nixon were elected
and johnson got on the phone with
everett dirksen the senate republican
leader we could stop the killing out
there he said but they've got this new
formula put in there namely wait on
nixon
and they're killing four or 500 a day
waiting on nixon this is treason said
lbj
i know said dirksen
so johnson faced the choice that barack
obama faced in the fall of 2016.
he did not have proof of nixon's
personal collusion with a foreign power
and nixon vehemently denied it
does any of this sound familiar
so johnson like obama sat on the
information
he sealed all the records and documents
in an envelope which became known as i
kid you not the x-file
but somehow mysteriously as these things
happen the news of the chanal affair
leaked out
and it became a grail for investigative
reporters and historians to prove that
nixon himself had known of and directed
anna schnaut's activities
so you can google the chanult affair or
go to the united states state department
historian site
with its lengthy chapter on the incident
to see how the pieces of the puzzle were
put into place over the last 50 years as
one journalist or researcher after
another took up the chase
but nixon always denied a personal role
and in his famous interviews with
newsmen david frost he insisted he was
not aware of nor had he authorized any
contact with the south vietnamese and
quote could not have done that in good
conscience
so it was not until 2013 when conducting
the research for my biography of nixon
that i found the scrawled notes of his
chief of staff bob haldeman
recording nixon's orders to quote keep
anna chanel working on the south
vietnamese
and to do what they could do to quote
monkey wrench johnson's announcement of
the peace initiative
now we cannot know what might have
happened if the nixon campaign had not
interfered
in johnson's initiative
most likely for those of you who are my
age you can remember the incredible
enmity and the stubbornness that this
north and south vietnamese displayed
towards each other in the years that
followed
the russians promise of productive talks
very well may have failed
but
i'm a biographer not a vietnam or
military war historian
i judge my subjects by what they knew
and what they did in the moment in the
time
and giving nixon's willingness to engage
in such a dark and risky plot
and given the bloody debacle that would
follow in cambodia and vietnam
the hundreds of thousands of lives that
would be lost
i came to the conclusion that indeed
this was more reprehensible than
anything that took place in watergate
that was 1968.
1969 50 years ago this summer the moon
landing chappaquiddick woodstock
the moratorium and nixon's great repost
to the moratorium the silent majority
the great silent majority speech and
next spring at this time we'll be
witnessing the anniversary of the
invasion of cambodia
and the shootings and the deaths at kent
state
and then comes 1972 and just as we're
beginning to think
really awful nasty things about richard
nixon he pulls a rabbit out of his hat
why nixon now
we live in a world that richard nixon
made
that february 1972 opening to china that
planet stunning handshake with mao
set earth and its peoples on a new and
liberating course it was the first great
crack of the cold war the first bell
tolling for the iron curtain that
indispensable step towards this
integrated world economy that would lift
billions of human beings from want and
grant them as nixon fervently hoped a
measure of peace
you can hear him on the tapes talking
this vision in mind
after losing the 1960 election to john f
kennedy and the 1962 race for the
governor of california the one where he
held the famous last press conference
and said you won't have nixon to kick
around anymore
he moved to new york
and as an international lawyer he roamed
the world for a prominent client
pepsicola
but everywhere he went in those
wilderness years as he called them
he would stop and he would talk to us
diplomats and foreign statesmen many of
whom he knew or had met on international
missions when he was vice president
under president dwight eisenhower
it was like one great postgraduate
seminar
and then in 1967 in an article in
foreign affairs magazine called
asia after vietnam nixon described the
world to come
monolithic communism is doomed
there's a new age coming the new age is
an information age built around a
technological revolution it's going to
be a computer revolution
and this age is going to require freedom
and intellectual nimbleness
not factory lines or collective farms or
five-year plans
and so was especially ill-suited to the
muscle-blown muscle-bound totalitarian
regimes like the
ussr the nations of the pacific rim
japan indonesia singapore malaysia korea
would lead the way in this new age nixon
wrote but there was one great threat
china
the chinese had to be brought out of
their shell and integrated into this new
international economic order
because all that progress and the
promise of peace that could last a
generation could be lost if a rampant
nuclear-armed red china sought to solve
the problem of a billion hungry restless
and enslaved people with violent
expansion and aggression
and so in 1969
almost as soon as he took office chinese
and the soviets engaged in a ridiculous
border dispute over a god-forsaken
riverbank in siberia
and the door to beijing was open to
crack
and nixon was prepared and he had the
foresight and the courage to reach out
to mao and to zhao and lai
and the 20 years of peace that he hoped
for and talks about on the tapes
which he defined not as a time where
there would not be war in the world but
a time free from the kind of
battles he had witnessed in world war ii
where the threat of a nuclear
conflagration and a third world war
is also now at 50 years and counting
and not for nothing did mr spock
urging the hot tempered captain kirk to
negotiate with the evil klingons
remind captain kirk there's an old
vulcan proverb only nixon could go to
china
and there were domestic accomplishments
as well
again in the first week after he was
elected i can't
tell you how what an impact it made at
the time but there was this huge oil
spill off the coast of santa barbara in
in california
um and uh nixon had already been well
placed on the environmental issue he had
had russell train as a adviser to his
campaign and and william ruckel's house
ready to serve in his administration
um and so nixon with a stroke of his pen
doesn't wait for congress to pass a law
creates this thing called the
environmental protection
agency first of the great domestic
environmental accomplishments he follows
it up with the national environmental
policy act
for anybody who's ever been in a fight
over an environmental impact statement
you have richard nixon to thank for
signing it
he created he signed he signed the
legislation creating noaa the national
oceanic and atmospheric administration
he signed the clean air act in 1970
automobile emission controls regulation
of pesticides a ban on ocean dumping
protection of marine mammals and coastal
zone management all in the nixon
administration
and that's not all
he has a very as we'll see a very sort
of convoluted record on civil rights but
there's no denying that he did more to
integrate southern schools than any
president before or since
brown vs board of education was in 1953.
eisenhower kennedy and lyndon johnson
wanted nothing of it they dragged their
feet they had their administration the
justice department go in and file some
some suits
but it fell to richard nixon to actually
get the schools integrated in 1969 when
he came into office there were 186
thousand african-american kids in
desegregated schools in the south
in 1970 a year later that number had
grown to 2.5 million
grants for integration
went from 75 million dollars to 2.6
billion dollars
as the one as the single great expert on
nixon and civil rights has said it was
the greatest school desegregation in
american history
they moved on they created something
called the philadelph philadelphia plan
the first muscular affirmative action
program
and they denied tax exempt status to
segregated private academies
those are the two biggies the
environment and
civil rights but there was more
he passed in conjunction with the
democratic congress of course
tax reform for low-income individuals
increased aid education
increased food stamp budget the social
security cost of living
raises and the system of cost of living
raises that secure old folks from
inflation
the occupational safety and health act
the war on cancer he doubled federal
funding for the arts he signed title ix
he signed the volunteer military he
dropped the voting age to 18 and in one
of the most little noted
uh accomplishments of his administration
but something that if you ever go out
west you'll hear about on almost every
indian reservation
he had a policy called
self-determination for indian tribes
which to this day makes him a hero on
the reservations
he had three biggies that didn't get
passed and you'll chuckle when you hear
what they are
the first was something called uh nixon
care
it's a mandated private insurance with
government subsidies
if a barack obama had gone out on the
first press conference and said i'm
asking the republican congress to pass
or the democrats and republicans in
congress to pass richard nixon's
health program
probably he would have gotten all the
republican votes and none of the
democratic votes but because it was
called obamacare the nixon plan when
presented to the uh
50 years later was shot down by congress
there's also a great memo i found in my
searches through the through the nixon
library
and it's from daniel patrick moynihan
that wonderful guy went on to become
ambassador to india and united states
senator from new york
and it's a it's a memo to the president
and it says you know
the scientists have come up with
something worrisome
we're really worried about this thing
called climate change
and global warming could be quote and
this is what he called it an apocalyptic
danger
to world civilization 1969
and the final third biggie that did not
get passed was something that boynihan
and nixon dreamed of called the family
assistance plan which i think you're
going to see us coming back to sometime
in in our children's generation
guaranteed basic annual income day care
and job training
um replacing the welfare system
completely
all this liberal legislation bubbling up
uh from the nixon administration in
conjunction of course with the
democratic congress
but this is why many scholars like to
look at the nixon years not as some sort
of isolated thing by itself but as the
third act a third act of great
fulfillment of the new frontier and the
great society if you take those
that time period from 1960 um to 1972
it's where we really
built the
modern
government structure and society that we
have today
well we might have seen it coming in uh
young tricky dick um he was elected to
the house in 1946
and instantly made an impression on
their leadership
and when they needed a committee to
travel to europe and evaluate george
marshall's plan
to rebuild that shattered continent
nixon was chosen
he roamed far and wide
impressing all who met him he saw the
shattered cities of france and italy and
germany
he stood amid the ruins of hitler's
chancellery where berlin's orphans came
up to him trying to sell him their
father's war medals
much was at stake
including nixon's future because he came
from
orange county california which that in
those days was rock ribbed republican
and conservative
and the very men who had plucked
lieutenant commander richard nixon from
obscurity sent him to congress built and
paid for the campaign
were thoroughly against the marshall
plan
they saw it as socialism foreign aid a
waste of money
pouring money down a rat hole that's
what they call what they told him and
they warned him they told him not to
count on their support if he endorsed
george marshall's mushy thinking
but nixon saw what he must do
so he returned to his district and for
six months
in 1947 and early 1948 he campaigned for
the marshall plan
he went to every rotary club every
chamber of commerce every vfw and
american legion hall
every crowd that would take him he told
them
he
owed them his best judgment
not his obedience
and he convinced them
when the party primaries were held in
california in the summer of 1948
richard nixon did not just win the
republican nomination he won the
democratic nomination
he had wagered everything and carried
the day he ran unopposed in his first
reelection campaign
and yet and this is the story of richard
nixon i thought often of of calling the
book and yet
and yet not having opposition made him
one of the few republican congressmen
who was available that summer of 1948
to
begin the red hunt
to launch an investigation and try to
chase down the soviets by alger hiss
which is the forerunner to mccarthyism
irony is abound
so why nixon now
it's a compelling story there may be
no american airport named after nixon
but there are films and books and one
hell of an opera
did you know the evil empire in the star
wars films was patterned by george lucas
on the nixon administration
or that the tortured don draper the star
of the mini-series madman was modeled on
the young richard nixon
and there's a reason why in the movies
the bad guys pull on richard nixon masks
as they prepare to stick up a bank
why everyone laughs when they do
he's our only president to resign in
disgrace and it was uh it was senator
bob dole who
joining the u.s delegation to egyptian
president anwar sadat's funeral
walked into the white house and came
upon president jimmy carter gerald ford
and richard nixon
there they were said dole see no evil
hear no evil and evil
[Music]
and yet it was that same bob dole
terribly wounded in northern italy in
world war ii
so wounded that they wrote on his
forehead in his own blood
not to waste your time on this one this
one's gone
he recovered but lost the use of his
right arm and therefore could not
perform the most elemental of political
tasks the handshake
and it was bob dole who will tell you
that of all his fellow senators of all
the republican committee men and
delegates and chamber of commerce
chairmen around the country there was
one man who never neglected to extend
his left hand
when greeting bob dole and that was
richard nixon
and it was dole who broke down his
features contorting
weeping while giving the eulogy at
nixon's funeral
so the original title for the book was
going to be richard nixon in american
tragedy
for his story most definitely has
elements of classic greater
shakespearean tragedy it's not my poetic
original flourish
cabinet members like elliot richardson
and henry kissinger wrote it
talked among each other at the time put
it in their diaries in their letters as
kissinger wrote quote deeply insecure
nixon first acted as if cruel fate had
singled him out for rejection
and then he contrived to make sure that
his premonition came to pass
it was said of kissinger that he was a
self-made man who worshipped his creator
that was not richard nixon
nixon was not an easy man to like and he
knew it
and it hurt
he had a dickensian childhood his dad
was brutal and abusive
a miserly
tyrant two of richard's brothers died in
childhood one the golden curly haired
baby of the family
arthur died in days from tubercular
meningitis
the eldest
the pride of the family harold took
years to succumb from tuberculosis
splitting the family as his mother took
took away took him away to care for him
wrecking the family's finances
young dick the middle brother made it
into yale and harvard but his family
could not afford to send him
and he came to believe that it was his
father's stubbornness that was at fault
for refusing to discard the family cow
whose tubercular tainted milk had killed
his brothers
his mother was cold
she would retreat into her closet to
pray and as nixon said famously never
once did she tell him that she loved him
that was not his family's way
he came to feel as he told david frost
in the famous television interviews
that he was an unlovable human being
and it all left him plagued by an
intense
painful insecurity
and self-doubt
he became iago
to his own othello
whispering in his own ear you're a
loathsome creature
no one likes you
you're no good
and so when he campaigned he campaigned
with ferocity and ruthless aggression
and in doing so he became a truly tragic
figure
we can glimpse the seeds of watergate
in nixon's actions as the precursor kind
of john the baptist for joe mccarthy
his red baiting campaigns which helped
launch the mccarthy era were infamous
but nowhere is that tragic floor clearer
than in the matter of race
and here we come to another and yet
for all the good that he did as
president of the united states
his record on race
is checkered and revealing
he grew up in whittier a quaker outpost
in southern california in college he was
the founder of a social club that
remarkably for the 1930s recruited and
accepted black members
when he first ran for congress in 1946
he spoke out for racial justice and the
local naacp made him an honorary member
in the same season that the clan was
burning crosses in southern california
to defeat a referendum on fair
employment
and when nixon won his first senate race
in 1950 one of his great supporters was
a guy named kenny washington a teammate
of jackie robinson at ucla and the first
black athlete to integrate the national
football league
a year before robinson took the field
for the brooklyn dodgers
and they held the victory party for
nixon's campaign in kenny washington's
home
in the 1950s he befriended both jackie
robinson and martin luther king
quite a daring mood move for a
politician with national ambitions at
the time
after getting nixon's help in passing
the 1957 civil rights bill king wrote in
a letter quote it is altogether possible
that nixon has no basic racial prejudice
and it wasn't just the public nixon
i came across this letter to his old law
partner from the time
uh whittier had a black shoe shine man
who worked in the town barber shop
and saved and sent his brilliant
daughter to columbia university
and when they came to visit washington
nixon had them as guests two years
before brown versus board of education
amongst all the southerners
richard russell sam urban fulbright
in the senate dining room
and nixon wrote in a private letter to
his former law partner never realizing
anybody would see it
she's a very pretty and intelligent girl
it renews your faith in this country to
realize that the daughter of a
barbershop boot black could get a
master's from columbia standing in the
highest percentage of her class
well martin luther king was very
impressed by this kind of liberality
from nixon but
being a perceptive man he was a bit wary
there's a danger in such a personality
king wrote
it will be that it will be turned on
merely for political expedience
when at bottom the real man has
insincere motives
i hope this is not the case with nixon
wrote dr king for if richard nixon is
not sincere he's the most dangerous man
in america
well king's perceptive assessment was
borne out in the 1960 presidential
campaign which nixon lost to john f
kennedy
now there are many reasons for that loss
nixon bungled the first debate he made a
rash promise to campaign in all 50
states and wasted his last week
in alaska
and as importantly in keeping that 50
state promise he found he could draw
large crowds in the then democratic
solid south
and so he like kennedy sought to walk
the edge and to balance a campaign for
white southern votes with that from
black boats
in northern cities
and the telling moment arrived when near
the end of the campaign king was
arrested in georgia on an old traffic
charge
shackled and taken to a backwoods prison
in the middle of the night
his family and friends fearing with
reason he would not emerge alive
john and robert kennedy intercede with
the georgia governor and gets and get
king freed the nixon campaign said no
comment
jackie robinson flew to where nixon was
campaigning in chicago and begged the
candidate to intercede nixon refused and
robinson left the hotel suite with tears
of frustration
anger and disillusionment
i had known nixon longer king recalled
he had been supposedly close to me he
would call me frequently about things
seeking my advice
and yet when this moment came it was
like he'd never heard of me you see so
this is why i really considered him a
moral coward
and so it was the kennedys who did a
better job at walking that line that
fall holding on to enough border states
while turning out majorities in the
black districts in the northern cities
to make a difference in a race that was
decided by a hundred and thirteen
thousand votes
and when nixon ran again in 1968
jackie robinson supported nelson
rockefeller
and when richard nixon was elected
president the nixon white house had
jackie robinson investigated
and a dossier compiled by the fbi
now there was evidence in 1960 that the
kennedy campaign had stolen votes enough
to win
in illinois and texas
and jack kennedy was dick nixon's friend
pat and dick had been invited to attend
jack and jackie's wedding
and nixon had refused to campaign in
massachusetts in the year when kennedy
ran for reelection to the senate
he's the kind of man the country needs
said the young kennedy after meeting
nixon in the house of representatives
and nixon prayed aloud when kennedy
dodged death on an operating table at
walter reed in 1954
poor brave jack is going to die oh god
don't let him die
so the hurt and the anger were twice as
intense
when nixon concluded that the kennedy
has had stolen the sixty election
and nixon's daughter julia said it was
the experience of 1960 that left her
father with the grim resolve of never
going to be out cheated again
nixon took his anger and his hatred and
he honed it
and he used it
and he had an unequaled ability to tap
grievances and resentments of class of
race of envy he could see in his
audiences
what he felt in himself
in part through this self-discernment
nixon recognized the defects of human
character
and he employed that knowledge to poison
and manipulate the voters he persuaded
americans to gnaw as he did on
grievances and resentments and to look
at each other as enemies
if you want to look back for the start
of the great polarity go back to richard
nixon
he was the first post-war politician and
certainly the most successful to build a
career on the deliberate and contrived
polarization of the american people on
issues like class and race
his staff wrote internal memos calling
for quote the calculated and carefully
contrived form of polarization that
would occur by telling white americans
that their rights and taxes were being
taken quote to appease a lazy racial
minority
they re the repercussions echoed today
fox news style was founded by roger
ielts who was richard dixon's media
advisor
and don't let the revisionist tell you
that watergate was a hoax that nixon was
somehow railroaded out of office by a
democratic congress or the liberal press
the white house tapes are all online you
can listen to them wherever you want
just like you can read the mueller
report
the case of nixon you have to stomach
the cynicism the cruelty the insecurity
and the anti-semitism
the little boys on the white house staff
don't know how to play the game nixon
told holdeman in the spring of 71 he
would have to coach them himself
quote i want bob more use of wiretapping
he told holdeman why don't you put your
money on surveillance and so forth
maybe it's the wrong thing to do but if
i've got a feeling if you're going to
start we have to start now
maybe we can get a real scandal on any
one of the leading democrats
scandal the leading democrats aldermen
echoes now you're talking says nixon
so this too is nixon's legacy and his
mark upon our world a country divided
clawing at itself as he did
and he did not recognize all this until
the end
but
there's no scene in politics law
art or commerce to match that of august
9 1974
the tormented nixon standing in the east
room
pouring out his guts in a rambling plea
only in war assassinations to americans
experience
such mythic moments
no scene in a career of astonishing
spectacle
was as memorable as nixon's farewell
talk to the white house staff
that friday morning
the actor met the moment it may well
have been the most raw acutely painful
and unforgettable speech in american
political history
his daughter trisha
recorded the scene
do not trip over wires
stand on name marker reach for mama's
hand hold it applause daddy is speaking
people are letting tears run down their
cheek must not look must not think of
that now
she wrote in her diary
the real nixon was being revealed as
only he could reveal himself
by speaking from the heart people could
know daddy it was not too late
he tried one more time to tell him who
he was how lonely how alone
no one will ever write a book probably
about my mother he said
well i guess all you would say is about
your mother my mother was a saint
and i think of her two boys dying of
tuberculosis nursing four others
in order that she could take care of my
older brother
and seeing each one of them die and when
they died it was like one of her own
she'll have no books written about her
that she was a saint
and came proof of his astonishing
resilience
we think that when someone dear to us
dies we think that when we lose an
election we think that when we suffer a
defeat
that all has ended he said not true
it's only a beginning always
young must know what the old must know
it it must always sustain us because the
greatness comes and you're really tested
when you take some knocks
some disappointments
when sadness comes because only if
you've been
in the deepest valley can you ever know
how magnificent it is to be on the
highest mountain
there was a faded doom about the man
kissinger thought
men in the audience wept
and in the end from richard nixon came
words as wise as any ever spoken in the
great old house
rich in self-knowledge purchased at a
price
always remember others may hate you
but those who hate you don't win unless
you hate them
and then you destroy yourself
dick and pat made their way out to the
south lawn walked down the long red
carpet shook hands with a venereal vice
president and climbed the steps of the
presidential helicopter
army one
at the last nixon
turned and grimacing gave one sweeping
defensive wave as if to ward off
unquenchable grief
and then he thrust his arms skyward
flashing the trademark views for victory
and entered the helicopter
army one lifted from the lawn rose above
the muggy capital the national mall
dimmed in a summer morning's haze
below l'enfants grand boulevards
brumidi's halls and corridors
pulsed with visionaries parva news and
hustlers
with dreams and scheming with avarice
ambition rivalry
and purpose
the chopper soared over statues of
heroes and monuments to great statements
whose ranks
with such american audacity the awkward
grocers boy had presumed to join had
come so near only to fail
it's so sad pat said to no one in
particular
he spent the night
the flight to california alone each in
his or her cabin on air force one
the president had a cocktail at noon
somewhere over missouri
the resignation took effect
why nixon now
it's essential that we learn from
nixon's parting words
today's hate and polarization are more
than just political phenomena they
threaten in this 21st century world the
american ideal
and that ideal is this of course that a
self-governed people varied in national
origin and faith
in the color of their skins can still be
like ronald reagan told us as john
winthrop preached upon the ship arbella
to his fellow pilgrims as they sailed
toward massachusetts bay
a city upon a hill
that the new world beacon not only
shines for others about such virtues as
liberty and equality but demonstrates
that in nations as diverse as ours these
values are achievable
that is the challenge americans face
right now
if we lose this battle in this country
with its wealth
and sturdy institutions and deep abiding
beliefs and we surrender all the
hard-won gains we've made in quality of
gender race
sexual orientation then it's difficult
to see
how other democracies resist hatred
there
i would argue that that was the meaning
of barack obama's nobel prize obama
hadn't done anything particularly
wonderful to qualify for it except to
win an election it wasn't awarded to
him it was awarded to us
it was the world saying to us bravo keep
it up you inspire us keep being america
but we were that people then and we'll
be that people again but we have to work
at it
american success is no done deal
we may be exceptional
but we're not predestined to succeed the
american experiment is just that an
experiment
and experiments can fail
dr benjamin rush signer of the
declaration said after the revolution
nothing but the first act
of the great drama has now closed
and john adams said we cannot guarantee
success but we can do something better
we can deserve it
our exceptionalism doesn't guarantee
we'll always make the right choice and
the price today of the wrong choice is
steep after writing three books i've
been christened and historian now
by the new york times no less
quite heady stuff for an old newspaper
man
and one thing that historians get to do
is quote abraham lincoln it's sort of
like getting your union card
and in 1838 pursuing civil war for
seeing civil war lincoln told his
countrymen quote
all the armies of europe asia and africa
combined with all the treasure of the
earth with a bonaparte for their
commander could not by force take a
drink from the ohio river
if destruction be our lot we must
ourselves be its author and finisher as
a nation of free men we will live
through all time or die by suicide
nixon taught us that teaches us that as
well why nixon now
it's only a beginning always he said
there in the east room on the day he
relinquished the presidency
and last year i've been invited to
lecture at vanderbilt ole miss uva
and little flagler college in florida
mary washington university of chicago
brandeis washington and lee montgomery
college mcgill university of texas
it's reassuring having toured these
campuses and engaged in conversation and
debate with my children's generation
that these millennials have it figured
out long before parkland
i saw their values are good fair and
generous
so our task i believe i submit
in the immediate future is to give them
a chance to not tear ourselves apart to
not die by suicide or succumb to hatred
we always rally to meet outside threats
war natural disasters terrorist attacks
my parents generation proved that an
army of free men and women an arsenal of
democracy
but as lincoln warns us the threat today
comes not from afar but from ourselves
because others may hate you but if you
hate them
that's when you destroy yourself and
that's the real answer to the question
why nixon now
so we have some time for questions
um i can go on forever and his life is
immensely rich and we will have someone
with a boom mic
so c-span can get everything down
and here he is
[Applause]
so did nixon ever have a friend
did nixon ever have a friend
well he had he had one famous friend a
fellow named diva rebozo when he was in
the presidency
and uh and and
everybody pretty much agreed that the
relationship was like this
that they would go out on bb's boat and
be would say nothing and nixon would say
nothing and they would turn around and
come back two hours later and get off
the vote
and nixon val valued him because
nixon had this amazing brain
because he was so personally awkward
almost everything had to be rehearsed he
would go through these massive week-long
rehearsals for his press conferences
um
there's there's a story that i was told
about
after he left the presidency he was
making his comeback
he brought a bunch of reporters and
journalists and editors to his home in
new jersey
and after they'd all sat around and had
chinese food
he stood up and with no notes gave this
amazing
tour de force
about the world situation and the
american political situation
and they were astonished they were just
amazed at this at this brain
uh and then one of the guys had to go to
the bathroom and he went upstairs and as
he was walking down the hall there was a
table on the hall and there
on the table was one of nixon's famous
yellow legal pads which he always wrote
all his thoughts out on and there almost
word for word was the speech that they
had just heard which they thought was
spontaneous
at the table so that was that was
nixon's way of doing things he would sit
in an armchair with his feet up on a
hassock with these yellow legal pads and
there's tens of thousands of pages of
them at the nixon library
um so what he wanted was he wanted quiet
his brother told me that one of the uh
things that that
nixon loved was the sea and i said why
why did nixon love the beach so much and
his brother said ah white noise the
waves they
create this barrier of everything else
so that that amazing brain could keep
ticking
so a close friend his closest friend
probably was pat and that was a rocky
relationship over the years his
relationship with his daughters was
sometimes strained he was just a
an awkward human being somewhat peculiar
henry kissinger
makes the argument that
a large part of the allegiance
of people for nixon is because they
identify these qualities in themselves
in him they feel sorry for him and they
sympathize and they empathize for him
and i have to say that as i wrote the
book i did too
there's no contest as far as intellect
is concerned but how would you compare
the moral character of nixon and trump
how would i compare the moral character
of nixon and trump
um i think it's safe to say now that
we're not going to see
a comparative
record of accomplishment
at the end of the
trump years unless something miraculous
happens in the next year that we don't
know about
that i
again as i wrote the book there are
always surprises that you that come to
you and the surprise to me was it's just
this amazing record of accomplishment
that nixon left behind
um and uh
as somebody said in
in in my speech um
nixon was all about expedience
there really was not
too much that he had it locked in his
heart as a guiding principle
pat buchanan said that
the ideological buffet of the nixon
administration was like a smorgasbord
was like you know pick a little bit of
conservative here a little bit of
liberal here didn't make a difference he
was not
an ideologue
that the great moral
admirable character that nixon had
characteristic that nixon had i think
is this amazing devotion to peace he had
been
this
young soldier in world war ii young
sailor in world war ii
served in the same south pacific the
same south pacific battlefield
the solomon islands as jfk joe mccarthy
ben bradley
and john mitchell and richard nixon all
served there at the same time never knew
each other
all within a couple of
miles from each other
but he came home like many of the guys
from world war ii determined that they
were going to stop it from happening
again and he had this great devotion to
his mother who was
a quaker
and so he was he was determined his
great the great
moral characteristic that he had was
this drive for peace and um i don't i
don't see it um
in the current president uh but
uh it's it's early yet
um presidents have a way of surprising
us when the diaries and the in the books
come out later but
um
nixon definitely wanted to bring home
this
chinese moscow
um
peace plan and and lay it out on his
mother's on his mother's grave and say
see mom see what i've done
um sure
how could such a flawed man
with such a flawed character
accomplish so much
he had
how could such a flawed man with such a
flawed character
accomplish so much
if you think about his story he was
amazing he comes back from war in 1946
and nobody knows his name except for a
few of the
burgers back in
orange county who decide that you know
we get we get some young service man and
he'll be the sacrificial goat against
the six-term new deal democratic
congressman jerry voorhis
and nixon goes out and
the governor doesn't know him the two
senators don't know him los angeles
times has no idea who he is and he wins
that race
in six years he's vice president of the
united states
it's an astonishing meteoric rise and
then eight years after that he's running
for
president
so um
he was smart
he was shrewd he had that great ability
i think to
as i said to
recognize the grievance in his audience
see it in himself
and then make that connection because
they shared it
it might not have been over the same
thing but that sort of feeling of
um of resentment
and
when he could when he did focus his mind
on something like
um this
what he called his structure of peace
and he used to do he used to do this he
used to hold up his hand and used to say
united states
russia
china japan europe
that's the structure of peace that's the
world that's the way we keep the peace
for again he said 20 years and we've
kept it for 50.
um so he did have vision um
amazing resilience i mean to come back
as many knocks almost done from the
ticket by eisenhower comes back loses to
kennedy comes back loses the 62 election
makes the greatest political comeback
ever and gets elected by
um 113 000 votes
uh i'm sorry 500 000 votes um and then
goes on and wins the greatest one of the
greatest landslides ever
plummets again in uh in watergate um and
reaches some kind of uneasy
um peace with himself enough that
people give him credit as a
elder statesman um in his later years
but
there was just no holding him down he
was uh he just had that amazing grit
sure
sir
you obviously
interviewed many people who dealt with
them during his life is there any one
interview or one statement by one of
these people that
stands out to you when you're doing your
research
is there any one statement or one
interview that i did that stood out
when i did the research
with all my biographical characters
there comes a moment
months or years into the process where
all of a sudden you see this shadow
across the stage
and you say wait a minute
and you walk over there and you follow
him and you say that's him
you know it's finally i got a glimpse of
the real him and that moment came when i
interviewed his brother ed
who was a geologist many years younger
than um than dick and lived up in
outside of seattle
but looked
almost the same as him and uh and
carried many of the same
um
family traits um and some of the same
resentments but we had this
he must have been 84 for something at
the time
we had this marvelous discussion and he
said you want to get some lunch and i
was of course saying sure you know uh do
you have a restaurant around here that
you know i'll be glad to have the
company the publisher pick it up
and he said oh come on so we go out in
the driveway and he's an old pilot of
course and old pilots always have hot
cars and we get into this pontiac and he
zips out onto the interstate going 80
miles an hour
and he says next exit burger king
um but uh
jokes aside he was he he gave that was
the
that was the moment that i really got a
sense for uh who dick was as a young man
especially since the physical it was
like i was talking to um to nixon
himself
all right cool go back there a little
bit
why did eisenhower pick nixon and then
why did he keep him
why did eisenhower hate nixon and white
kick nixon and and why did he keep him
um
eisenhower was as
maybe with the sight of churchill or
franklin roosevelt eisenhower was one of
the great
titans of world war ii and then it comes
home and he
wins the presidency and he's told by his
advisors they need somebody young be
nice to have somebody from the
younger generation who fought the war
california would be great so why don't
we pick this young kid nixon so it was
never really a um
a love affair was more like an arranged
marriage by the republican party
and i didn't really not like
nixon as much as i just sort of ignored
him because
nixon was staff
eisenhower had liberated
europe he was used to palin around with
churchill he knew what young lieutenant
commanders were for they were to take
this
this uh
telegram over to that office over there
and of course nixon having gotten this
far and being having these wonderful
assignments like go out to andrews and
welcome churchill when he arrives and
sit back in the car with him on the way
back
was just gaga with the idea that he was
then he wanted eisenhower's approval um
and he and he couldn't get it and that
brought out a lot of nixon's
worst traits his nervousness his
drinking
and uh and eisenhower then began to look
at him like he made him uncomfortable to
have him around and so given the chance
to get rid of him um after four years
um eisenhower
tried but nixon's base in the party was
was too strong
but even that was like so unfair because
ike had his heart attack in the first
term
and nixon was if you were to sit down
and write a script of how the vice
president united states should behave
richard nixon just clicked every single
one of those points off he if he had to
talk to talk to a cabinet officer he
went to their office he never took over
the oval office he
he was he was respectful he was diligent
he was just everything you want somebody
to be and eisenhower calls him up
to the farm in pennsylvania afterwards
and says thanks a lot dick how'd you
like not to be vice president the next
term
um it's that kind of thing just you know
when you already have this fragile
personality that kind of thing
drove him nuts in the end i kept him
because nixon just had um
you know that what was known then as the
taft wing of the republican party the
conservative wing of the republican
party
um was was very strong behind nixon and
nixon had
you know he'd done the the famous
checker speech in 1952 and made a name
for himself and so
um i in the end eisenhower just didn't
have the guts to to kick him off the off
the ticket
given the way he had to leave office how
how did how did nixon interact with
the presidents who came after him before
he died
given the way he had to leave office how
did nixon interact with presidents who
came after him um
his advice was taken seriously
on foreign affairs
um not so much on he liked to
write these long memos and pass them
around about who's going to win the
nomination
next time out and stuff like that and
that was
he was never that good at that
and george schultz told me that he was
never that good on foreign affairs
either
but he had enough of a reputation that
the president's listened um
reagan of course had known him going way
back and reagan was too smart a man not
to know that nixon thought reagan was
stupid
um so
reagan sort of took him with a with a
grain of salt
george h.w bush
uh always thought nixon had
toyed with him uh used him
and um and and there's this amazing
letter in george h.w bush's letters to
his sons talking about how nixon had
underspoiled that beautiful white house
um and uh
but
uh he did
they did talk to nixon
um and uh it was at a crucial time of
course because gorbachev was there and
we didn't know you know we kept saying
to ourselves you know let's not get
carried away
it wouldn't be prudent to get carried
away and think this guy's going to be a
hero with everything we know about the
soviet union
but let's give it you know
bush was an optimist schultz was an
optimist baker was an optimist and they
wanted to continue to see what what
would happen after the wall fell and
nixon was obdurate no no gorbachev is
just another
um
another stalin and a velvet glove
and so he was wrong on that one and then
he got in a pissing match with bush and
wrote a very nasty op-ed in the new york
times
saying that
bush was mishandling this important
relationship which if you remember the
obituaries after george bush died every
single one of them was led by
you know president
bush who masterfully handled
the fall of the iron curtain um so nixon
was was wrong on that one bill clinton
um talked to him a lot which was which
was
strange considering that
no two people could have been no two
politicians could ever been
more opposite
and hillary of course had been on the
staff of the judiciary committee that
voted to impeach him but uh but clinton
respected him and and and listened to
him
um and nixon was sort of uh
he wasn't he didn't despair about the
fact that that he didn't have a great
deal of influence um in his in his exile
years
um but he was a realist enough to know
that um
he was not like
he was he at that point he didn't even
reach the class of kissinger who really
did have all their ears
and probably did have much more
influential input
yes sir
in light of all you've learned in all
the research if you could interview
richard nixon what one question would
you most like to ask him
what one question would i like to ask
richard nixon if i could interview him
other than why didn't you burn the tapes
um
i'm fascinated when i do biography about
the formative years people say that i
write too much about the early life
rather than
about the presidency
um so if i could if i could take a walk
with richard nixon i would just probably
just say tell me about the lemon farm
and how did you feel when your father
you know wouldn't get rid of the cow
what was you know that's you know i
would try to get to that um
there is a uh you know the arthur
schlesinger who was jfk's court
historian
left a marvelous collection um at the
new york public library of his diary and
records and he records these
conversations with kissinger where he's
saying to kissinger how can you work for
such a man and kishner is saying to him
you know you have to understand
this amazingly tortured
shakespearean personality and you have
to feel empathy for it and and the thing
that struck me i mean they're not very
happy with me now because i didn't
particularly like the book but the thing
that struck me when i talked to the old
nixon hands
was the ones who were still around are
still carrying the standard
there's such devotion there's and
there's love and there's empathy
you know they understood this guy they
understood that he rose above all these
twisted facets of his of his character
and did still manage to do
great things when it seemed the entire
world um
including a very liberal democratic
press um was against him so um that
that's what i would just like to get him
you know if if i could ever get richard
nixon just to
talk about uh
um
and of course he recognized it in
himself
to address that question that would be
the one i would ask him
can we get some of those ladies
in the back there
guys and ladies
go ahead
you start out your
speech talking about the
1968 attempts to sabotage the paris
peace talks or worse than anything
nixon did in watergate yet the secret of
68 has been secret for decades it's only
in the last several years in 10 years
we've gotten learning about us why was
that not
vetted or broken during the early 70s
and if it had been would he have lost
the 72 election
um so the question is
given how awful the chenault affair
was and
the stakes that were played in 68
um would he have lost in 72 if that had
come out and why didn't it come out
um
to answer well to answer the question
directly it's because lyndon johnson
decided that
if he let the country know three days
before the election that this was going
on
that
not only would the country turn on
nixon possibly would turn on johnson
because johnson was bugging his
opponent's campaign
and most definitely it would turn on
south vietnam for for supposedly being
our ally but snubbing us when we ask
them to do this diplomatic chore
on behalf of of peace
so rather so hubert humphrey knew and
hubert humphrey chose not to
reveal it as well
but almost immediately of course you
know you're a washington audience you
know that nothing is secret so almost
immediately it began to leak and it
leaked out in little bits
you know anna chanel wanted a really
nice job with the
nixon administration and never got it
because she was radioactive
theodore white writes a little bit about
it in the making of the president in
1968 and a few years later julius
whitcover writes it in a book about um
nixon and and the 60s and uh and little
bits come out enough that when he has
the famous interview with david frost
frost directly asks him you know
did you know what anishinaa you know was
doing
and then the big break comes in
just after the turn of the century when
um lady bird johnson decides that
brilliantly decides that full disclosure
is the best thing that she can do
and so she opens everything
in texas and all the johnson tapes which
are supposed to be sealed for 50 years
are opened the x-file supposedly sealed
50 years is now open and
lyndon johnson
becomes this much more
human character vietnam begins to fade
in people's memories they remember the
civil war uh the civil rights movement
and the civil rights act and all of a
sudden you find little in all those
ratings of presidents like the one that
c-span does
you find lyndon johnson creeping up with
openness same thing happened with harry
truman uh his family opens up all the
records and harry truman you know begins
to climb uh sadly the nixons you know
haven't done that and so he's like mired
down in the in the low 20s in their in
in the rankings um of american
presidents
but
um throughout all this time of course
his tapes are sitting there like a
ticking time bomb and his papers are
there
and finally the nixon foundation says we
can't afford to store these papers
anymore let's give them to the
government and i just happened to be the
guy who in
2013 whatever it was
paging through
as the great biographer robert caro says
turn every page
came across haldeman's notes
they were always like two great white
whales in the nixon story one was
watergate and one was the chanalta fair
and um this was one of the pieces
um you all are washing tony and so you
know that when you go to ocean city in
the summer time
when we did
you set up a a card table and dump a
1200 piece jigsaw puzzle and on the
rainy days or when you're having coffee
in the morning or late at night
everybody goes by and tries to put a few
pieces of the puzzle together and it was
my lot to have found this particular
piece and add it that's the way history
is written
down here
i've lived through the vietnam war and i
got the impression nixon
dragged out the war to use it as a
campaign issued in 1972
is that correct
um
i had to of course i had to address
vietnam but the question is is did nixon
drag out the war for his own political
purposes
and i really had just had to study it
and the best that can be said for nixon
is that
he and nick he and kissinger
coldly immediately identified vietnam as
a backwater
and that for all the money in the lives
that were
being spent there
was not as important as the great game
of thrones
that he was playing
with beijing and with moscow
and that all he wanted to do was tamp it
down
um
probably towards the end of his term
they did make some cold calculations as
to
you know when's the best time to
announce the pieces at hand when's when
do we really need to make sacrifices
um it's about a year and a half before
the election
he and kissinger announced that the
north vietnamese army would be able to
stay in south vietnam vietnam
as part of a peace deal and and you know
i don't know why
but we americans never put two and two
together and said well that's not peace
that's
you know
um
that's a that's a that's a recipe for
what happened a complete catastrophe um
but you know on the flip side is that i
think that um
being a historian is sort of humbling in
that you think people ask me what do you
think historians 50 years from now or
100 years now will think about
and i think vietnam is fading already in
historical importance
whereas this technological revolution
that nixon spoke about is and the civil
rights movement and liberation of women
and all these other things that happened
in the last century
are so much more important to future
historians than this little war in
vietnam and
nixon's people kissinger's people will
argue to this day that
um
that we bought time in those five years
and in that time we allowed indonesia
and korea
taiwan japan
to become the asian tigers
and
bring this structure of peace to the
world um that i'm sure would be nixon's
argument if you were um
alive today
but you have to ask and this is the
question that i finally came down to
which is that you know
when de gaulle had the same
issue with algeria
um he went on television and told the
french people we lost
we're coming home
you know not my fault he just elected me
those guys
screwed up we're bringing the troops
home and we're going to figure out a way
to get the algerians who stuck with us
home and it took a long time but it took
like four or five years but they did it
and uh and there's no reason why richard
nixon the great visionary who
could see what was happening
in beijing and in
tokyo and in taiwan could not have
gone on television and said this is a
democratic war johnson has totally
screwed this up
we're bringing the troops home rent it
because um i
i cannot find
an objective historian who thinks that
the deal that we ended up getting was
anything better than what we could have
gotten in nixon's first months of office
that's it anybody else yep in the back
um speaking of these
tapes
it's impossible not to cringe when you
hear some of the
remarks from
nixon regarding
anti-semitism and i'm just wondering how
it's possible to reconcile that with
the people he had on the staff um
sapphire
kissinger garment etc it's herbstein
how do you reconcile the anti-semitic
comments on the tapes with
the fact that nixon employed on his
staff people like kissinger
um
arthur burns was named federal reserve
chairman
len garment was
a long time advisor
um
bill sapphire was a speechwriter
nixon sort of addresses that on the
tapes
and he does that also in the case of
gays
gay americans and he basically says that
if you're
a pro-nixon
gay american if you're a pro-nixon
jewish american you're okay
you know i got a problem you know um
it's their nature of course
what really drove him crazy was not so
much i mean it seems to me that the
anti-semitism was something came down to
him from his father in particular
um and his time
in rural southern california where
um anti-semitism was quite prevalent bob
haldeman was
an anti-semite along the lines with
nixon
and some of the things that he says are
ugly or uglier
so uh
nick again in nixon's case the
expediency
wins
and if you were valuable to him like
kissinger
you know
it was something easily
um put aside
so it wasn't that deep
no matter how ugly the comments are it
wasn't that deep a
hatred of jews that he would not
use them to great effect and put them in
the most powerful positions in the
government and the economy
does that answer the question
yes
can you talk a little bit about nixon
and his ability to reach across the
aisle to accomplish his domestic agenda
i feel like we live in a time where
nobody reaches across the aisle anymore
and he obviously had an art to it
you spoke of his
kind of friendship with moynihan how
deep did it go how did he get his robust
domestic agenda passed and what have we
lost
well um
basically all the question the question
is how did nixon reach across the aisle
and what has changed since then that
keeps us from that keeps us stuck in
this polarized position politically
as i said the republican party was split
there was a conservative wing of the
republican party but there's also this
very liberal
wing of the republican party at that
time hard as it may seem now
um to think of it nelson rockefeller and
lowell wiker and you had
new hampshire and vermont and maine and
hugh scott from pennsylvania you had
lots and lots of of moderate republicans
the
civil rights act made it through
the house of representatives
on liberal democrats and liberal recover
republican votes
outnumbering
southern democratic conservative votes
so there were already and that was
during linda johnson's administration so
there were already
these patterns of
conservative republicans half the
republican party joining with half the
democratic party the southern democrats
and being a conservative bloc
and outside of that um you had a
tremendous amount of room
for politicians as you said to reach
across the aisle
um this went up uh
i worked at national journal about maybe
10 years ago and we did a survey every
year of
polarity
and when we first did the survey there
were about
10 or 12 or 15 republicans who voted to
the left
of the most conservative democrat and
there were 10 or 12 or 15
democrats who
voted to
the right of the most liberal
republican and by the time i got around
to doing it in the in the 90s there was
zero it was just like you know and and
there's lots of reasons for that part of
it was the um civil rights and the
effect that the civil rights movement
had on the south and the south becoming
solid south for the republicans and newt
gingrich's brand of
of uh um
of
techno prisoners
um
campaigning and the rise of uh fox news
seeing how to make a buck by dividing
people talk radio i mean there's many
many reasons
why
the guy that i'm working on now is my
next book is going to be senator edward
kennedy and this was a guy who was for
all his flaws was a master at reaching
across the aisle even into the 90s
and the early 2000s so it's not that it
can't be done
i bet that if
there was
you know just something that the
tea party republicans would forget or
the talk show republicans would forget
about that there's enough reasonable
republican senators right now that they
would could easily pass a bill like on
infrastructure or something but but
everything gets gets turned into an us
versus them
and uh it's going to take some kind of
of uh
lightning bolt to
sort of shatter that up i believe and
i
i'm not smart enough to tell you what
that's going to be
yes ma'am
um
the question is about the invasion of
cambodia
so in
[Music]
1970
having committed himself to
policy of a very slow withdrawal from
vietnam
nixon and kissinger decide that
they won't the south vietnamese will not
be able to make it in the long run if
the north vietnamese are allowed to
continue to operate an impunity from a
strip of land along the cambodian
border
this is nothing new johnson had faced it
there had been some
isolated bombing and some
u.s special ops
missions into that area
but nothing like
this decision by nixon to go ahead and
send the south vietnamese army and with
the american army
along with them
crossing cambodia
he believed that this was a way to
safeguard vietnamization and eventually
get us out
with peace peace with honor
most everybody um
um to the left of maybe barry goldwater
in the united states saw just saw oh my
god we're now invading another country
um
one of the saddest bits of congressional
testimony ever henry kissinger was i
think maybe when he was
had hearings for secretary of state but
he was asked about
what happened with cambodia and he said
well you know
we just did not foresee that this would
set a row of dominoes in motion that
would end up with the khmer rouge coming
into power and
all the sacrifices that
hollywood made so real in the movie the
killing field
and it's a
it's a chilling bit of testimony it's a
good lesson for any statesman that the
unintended consequences
of your actions need to be factored in
not just
i mean you probably could argue that
george w bush could have just gotten
that
lesson before he um
uh invaded iraq but um you know it's
what
rumsfeld used to say that things you
don't know or the known knowns the known
unknowns whatever that phrase was but
you always should be very
modest and humble about what you don't
know when you're doing
making life and death decisions like
that
it also had a big impact here
in cambodia yes it did i was i was a
high school senior
and uh the campuses
exploded
kent state happened uh in the senate you
had the first few
cutoffs of funds resolutions um passing
first to democratic caucus and then um
moving towards passage in the senate
putting pressure on nixon so that
he knows he has to
cut a deal um
it was a and of course then
it also was
so stressful for nixon that he makes
this famous
trip in the middle of the night to the
lincoln memorial to meet with the kids
who are protesting and then he gets in
his limousine
and he drives up to capitol hill with
his valet and he puts his belly in the
speaker's chair of the house and lets
him bang the gavel and he meets with the
cleaning ladies at six in the morning
and starts talking about his mother and
the bible with them and
um
so it was very uh
incredibly stressful and it's kind of
scary to read bob holdeman's diary for
those days because they really thought
that the president united states was
coming close to a nervous breakdown
sure one more question yes sir
uh was there a president or any other
prominent figure that nixon particularly
admired
oh yeah it's interesting
presidents get to put oh was there any
was there another president nixon
particularly admired
presidents get to put um portraits up
uh in the uh i think it's the cabinet
room to sort of signify who their um uh
great uh uh presidents of them are so
one was teddy roosevelt because of
course he was the man in the arena and
nixon always saw himself as the the
fighter in the arena
one was his it was idol eisenhower but
the other was woodrow wilson
and wilson because
his mother had been a great admirer of
woodrow wilson as a quaker what he had
done with the league of nations
and nixon
sought to draw inspiration from
from woodrow wilson all his life
and in fact on his in on his
tombstone
see if i get it right
i think he says the greatest
the greatest honor that that uh
um history can bestow is the title
peacemaker and that's what's written out
there in europe linda and i urge you if
you happen to be in southern california
to go see the museum because it's
it's a spectacular um they've redone the
whole thing they they kept the objective
tough watergate gallery and have added
all these other things about vietnam and
the domestic record it's really um
worth the uh um the trip
and uh there's a if you go to the
national portrait gallery the portrait
of nixon that's chosen is by um
i know i want to say well rogers but not
rogers what's the guy who did all the
paintings for the saturday evening post
norman rockwell thank you
um
and it's a famous painting it's over
here it's about this big and they've
blown it up to about
20 by 80.
so as you walk up the drive there's
nixon by rockwell staring at you as you
walk in
so thank you very much for coming out
folks
from george washington to george w bush
every sunday at 8 pm at midnight eastern
we feature the presidency